Scholastic audio presents Wings of Fire.
Book 9, Talons of Power, by Tooey T
Sutherland.
Read by Shannon McManus.
The Jade Mountain Prophecy.
Beware the darkness of dragons.
Beware the stalker of dreams.
Beware the talons of power and fire.
Beware one who is not what she seems.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
Something is coming to scorch the
ground.
Jade Mountain will fall beneath thunder
and ice.
Unless the lost city of night can be
found.
Prologue.
Three years ago.
The royal hatchery was supposed to be a
warm, safe, peaceful place for eggs to
rest quietly until it was time to hatch.
It was not supposed to be a death trap
that gave you the creeps.
It's not a death trap, Coral would
protest.
Whenever Gil brought this up.
Seawing princesses and princes have been
hatching there for 1000s of years, I
hatched there, and it was safe and
beautiful.
It's part of our heritage.
It's a sea wing tradition.
There's nothing wrong with the hatchery.
The problem is our useless guards.
They're doing their best.
Gail objected.
You can only expect so much of a dragon.
I'm not expecting the 3 moons in a bowl
Coral growled.
All they have to do is protect my eggs
until an air hatches.
Why is that so hard?
Gil didn't know the answer to that.
He didn't know why they'd lost 6 female
eggs in the last 5 years.
He didn't know how his other 3 daughters
had died.
Coral was sure there was an assassin in
the palace, but Gil didn't understand who
would want to kill so many little
princesses.
His heart ached as he swam through the
deep palace, thinking about all the
dragonettes they had lost.
Coral was trying so hard to hatch an air
that she was having eggs every year now.
The palaces were overflowing with all the
sons who had survived the many hatchings
sea wing princes were everywhere, to the
point where an entire wing of the deep
palace had been set aside for them to
live in.
Gil tried hard to remember all their
names and tell them apart.
Coral didn't bother.
But there were 24 of them already, +3
more waiting to hatch.
He sometimes wished they didn't have the
animus touched balance that indicated
male versus female eggs.
He wondered if they were making it easier
for the assassin, separating the eggs so
clearly in the hatchery.
But then he wondered if it didn't
matter.
Without a way to tell them apart, perhaps
the assassin would just have destroyed
all the eggs.
His wings took him toward the hatchery as
they did all the time now, sometimes 5
times a day.
So far, Carl's latest plan had been
working.
It wouldn't be much longer before the
eggs hatched, safe and sound.
And then they could be taken out of the
royal hatchery, which would be a relief
to Gil.
Although, given what happened to the
other princesses, he wasn't really sure
they would be safe anywhere.
The new council chief of Dragonette Care
was nervous but dedicated.
Abalone had a deputy chief to help him
and together they rotated in and out of
the hatchery, so someone was watching the
2 princess eggs at every moment.
Abalone and Snapper were 2 of Gil's most
loyal soldiers.
He had talon picked them himself.
And yet.
And yet, he couldn't stop checking on
them, just to be sure, just to be safe.
He slid open the door and swam inside the
dark, egg shaped room.
His wings fluttered in the bursts of warm
water that bubbled through the hatchery
keeping it at the perfect temperature for
the eggs.
Abalone?
He flashed an aquatic.
It was very quiet.
The marble statue of his daughter Orca
loomed over the nests, watching over her
future brothers and sisters.
Gil wished the statue could protect them
as fiercely as her face suggested.
He wished Orca were still alive, so she
could protect them herself.
But if she were alive, Coral would be
dead.
He shook his head.
He would never understand why Orca
challenged her mother for the throne at
such a young age.
If she had only waited.
They could have had so many more years
together as a family.
Unless the assassin killed her too.
He shivered, and swam farther into the
room.
Abalone was slumped over the nest with
the 2 princess eggs in it, his wings
covering them.
Abalone?
Gil hurried over, worried.
Abalone never slummed.
He hardly ever even sat down.
He was always on full alert, always a
model soldier.
Gil shook his friend's shoulder.
With a soft groan.
Abalone sat up, and Gil realized that the
council chief was a strange white color
around his gills.
His eyes were bloodshot, and there were
flecks of foam rising from his scales.
I'm sorry, Avalone flashed, with a
phosphorescent scales under his wings.
I've been waiting for someone to come.
But I won't leave the eggs.
I won't.
They'll be safe.
I promise.
He reached to cover them with his wings
again, and staggered sideways.
You're sick, said Gil, catching him
before he could land on the eggs.
You shouldn't be here.
I'll go get help.
Yes.
No.
Avalone flashed.
Afraid I'll drift off.
Everything, spinning.
Can you make it to the healing room on
your own?
Gil asked.
If I stay here to guard the X?
Maybe.
Abalone tried to paddle forward, shifting
his wings, and instantly violent tremors
shook his whole body.
He gasped and curled into a small ball on
the smooth floor of the hatchery.
All right, stay here.
Watch the eggs and don't fall asleep.
I'll grab someone and send for help.
Gil swam to the door as fast as he could
and powered up the ramp to the main floor
of the palace.
Three little dragonettes, all about 2
years old, were wrestling in the entrance
hall, kicking and squeaking gleefully.
Three of his sons, Gil realized, the ones
from 2 hatchings ago.
There was only one female egg in that
group, and she didn't even make it
halfway through incubating, he remembered
with a fresh stab of grief.
He flashed his scales at full brightness
to get their attention.
They turned toward him, blinking, and he
flashed, I need help.
Who's going to help me?
The princess glanced at one another
nervously, and then one of them paddled
forward a little bit.
Me, he flashed.
I'll do it, Father.
Good, said Gil.
Thank you.
He hesitated.
Turtle.
The dragonette flashed.
I'm turtle.
I know.
Gil answered, although he hadn't been
sure.
Turtle.
This is very important.
I need you to go find Snapper and send
her to the Royal Hatchery.
Tell her to hurry as fast as her wings
can swim.
Can you do that?
Sure, Turtle nodded, his green eyes
wide.
I'm counting on you, turtle, Gil said
touching his son's shoulder.
It's really important.
I know you can do this.
I'll be waiting.
All right?
Yes, sir, turtle answered, shivering a
little.
Go then.
Hurry.
Turtle swam away toward the kitchens with
what felt like agonizing slowness.
Gil reminded himself that Turtle was a
prince.
He wouldn't fail.
He'd find Snapper, abalone's deputy chief
who could watch the eggs while Gil took
abalone to the healing room.
Gil rushed back down to the hatchery.
Abalone was still awake, crouched by the
eggs with his front talons pinned across
his chest, Gil realized with alarm that
there was now a growth on abalone's neck
a large, round lump that hadn't been
there a few moments ago.
He touched it lightly, and abalone
flinched away.
It was blazingly hot.
Gil had no idea what kind of disease this
was.
Is it safe for him to be here?
Could he infect the eggs?
He needed to get abalone out of the
hatchery.
For the safety of the eggs, but also
because abalone looked closer and closer
to death every moment.
Hurry up, turtle.
They waited in painful silence.
Was the growth getting bigger?
Turtle, where are you?
Come on, come on.
The lump was expanding, little by
little.
Pushing abalones, silvery blue scales
into strange, jagged shapes.
It looked as if it might explode any
moment now.
You'll be all right.
Gil flashed at Avaloni.
Hope is coming.
Help didn't come.
Time crept by, dragging its long, long
tale.
Nobody came.
Abalone started making a low, whimpering
sound, ragged, like claws scrabbling up
the inside of his throat.
His gaze was fixed on the eggs, and he
kept his wings tucked in close to him
rocking softly.
Turtle, Gil thought, with helpless fury.
This was his own fault.
What a useless command he'd given.
He should have sent all 3 dragonettes to
find Snapper.
No.
He should have told them to find any
other adult dragon, or to summon one of
the healers, or he should have swum
straight to the healing chambers the
moment he saw that Abalone was ill.
Now he could see there would have been
time to make it there and back with a
healer.
But with each moment that passed, Abalone
looked closer and closer to collapse.
The truth was, he should have done
anything other than what he did.
He'd made a terrible mistake.
But where was Turtle?
Couldn't he figure out a smarter option?
If he couldn't find Snapper?
Somebody come.
Please, please, somebody.
Finally, it became unbearable.
Abalone would die if he didn't reach a
healer soon.
It might already be too late.
Gil couldn't wait any longer.
Oh, leave.
Abalone flashed weekly. as Gil moved
toward the door.
I can't let you die like this.
Gil flashed back.
Just stay awake until I get back.
He hesitated in the doorway, worrying.
Abalone was no match for an assassin in
this condition.
McGill would only be gone a short time.
It would be truly uncanny, terrible luck
for the assassin to show up during those
few moments.
He swam.
He swam for Abalone's life and his
daughters.
He burst through the palace like a
typhoon, swooping up to the healing
chambers.
His sons were gone from the main
hallway.
He saw no sign of turtle or snapper
anywhere.
Help!
He flashed at full brightness as he
reached the healing floor.
Dragons came pouring into the hall
curious, and a flurry of bubbling gasps
went up as he explained abalone's
condition to the healers.
Three of them grabbed their kits and swam
after him.
Back down, down, down to the royal
hatchery.
They found abalone unconscious, his wings
drifting in the current of the jets.
For a moment.
Gil thought his neck had been slashed.
Then he realized that the blood running
down abalone scales came from the growth
which had burst.
The healers hurried toward him, then
stopped, turning heartbroken faces to
Gil.
No.
Gill's scales flashed without him
realizing it.
No.
The 2 eggs had been crushed, apparently
by huge, heavy talons.
The dragonettes inside were dead.
Two more lost princesses.
Gil roared his pain and fury, roared
until his throat gave out, and then he
whirled and swam away.
He never wanted to see the royal hatchery
again.
Find my son turtle, he snarled, at one of
the gawking dragons in the hallway.
Upstairs, he saw a group of dragons
approaching through the gardens, Queen
Coral, returning from the summer palace
and are meeting with blister.
How could he tell her what had happened?
What had happened again?
But she saw it on his face as he swam out
the door toward her.
She sank suddenly, as if a boulder had
been dropped on her.
Touching down amid the coral and
anemones.
Her wings came forward, and she covered
her eyes with her talons.
She didn't want to see him spell it out
in aquatic.
I'm sorry, he flashed anyway.
I'm sorry.
She didn't move.
Didn't look up.
A movement caught Gil's eye, and he
turned.
Some distance away, there was turtle
swimming slowly through the garden of the
wounded, peering at each recuperating
dragon's face, his brothers were behind
him, joking and laughing, and shoving one
another back and forth.
Gil tore across the gardens, seized
Turtle's wing, and flung him around to
face him.
Where have you been?
Gil roared.
Turtle flinched, and shielded his eyes
from the intensity of gills scales.
I can't find her.
He flashed nervously.
I'm still looking.
Out here?
Gil waved his talons at the nearly empty
section of the coral reef where injured
soldiers were taken to rest and recover
surrounded by color and beauty.
Gil wanted to rip that beauty to shreds.
He wanted to tear apart the coral reef
and kill all the creatures that lived on
it.
Well, I I couldn't find her in the palace
so I I didn't know where to look.
I'm trying.
It's too late, Gil growled.
Your new sisters are dead, and it's your
fault.
Turtle blanched.
But how I didn't.
You were too slow.
Gil backed away.
Glaring at the other 2 princes, who were
huddling behind an outcropping to watch
with wide eyes.
I'm sorry.
Turtle bowed his head, fiddling with a
piece of coral in his claws.
I, I don't know what snapper looks like
and nobody knew where she was.
You shouldn't volunteer for things you're
incapable of doing.
Gil said harshly.
You shouldn't offer to help if you're
going to be useless.
I really tried, Turtles said.
Ringing his talons.
I really really did.
I promise, daddy.
You failed.
Gil stared down at him.
He felt a small pang of guilt at the
crushing despair on the dragonette's face
but his anger was too strong to hold back
right now.
I am very disappointed in you, he said.
Maybe one day he would forgive Turtle.
Maybe one day he'd be able to think
clearly again.
Even now, he knew deep down that blaming
a 2 year old dragonette, for his own
mistakes, was wrong.
One day, when his grief had subsided
maybe he could find the words to tell his
son that.
But not today.
Gil turned away from Turtle's stricken
face and swam back to Coral.
She was watching him with vacant, sad
eyes.
What did he do?
She asked dimly.
I sent him for help, and instead he
flapped around, looking in all the wrong
places and goofing off.
He's only a prince, she said.
What can you expect?
She reached out and seized one of Gil's
talons.
The next one is going to live, Gil.
Oh, Carl, he said.
Maybe we shouldn't.
I'll stay with her this time, Carl said
fiercely.
No one else can do it except me.
I was right about our incompetent
guards.
It wasn't Abalone's fault, Gil
protested.
Doesn't matter. she said, flicking a claw
at the palace.
I sent word to have him and Snapper both
executed.
Coral!
Gil cried, appalled.
He tried to pull away, but she gripped
his talons even tighter.
I'm going to keep our next daughter alive
Coral said.
I'll stay in the hatchery with the egg to
keep it safe, but I need you to run the
kingdom for me.
I'll do anything.
He promised sadly.
He couldn't argue with her in this
state.
Not right now.
I'll keep her by my side all the time, her
whole life if I have to.
Coral's eyes glowed, reflecting her
scales as she spoke.
I'll never leave her alone.
She's going to be perfect, Gil.
You'll see.
She glanced down at the spot where she
had landed, at the sea anemones waving
long, pinkish blue tendrils over her
claws.
And we're going to call her.
Anemone.
Part one.
A dragon awakes.
Chapter one.
The nightmare rose out of the mountain
vast and glittering.
Turtle had never seen a dragon so large.
He never seen eyes so sharp.
He knew instantly that this dragon could
and would happily kill him in a
heartbeat.
Terror pounded through him like waves in
a storm, building higher and higher.
I need to hide.
He desperately wanted to disappear, to
vanish into the dark sky as if he'd never
been there.
He wished he could melt away, like a
camouflaged rain wing.
Why did I ever let anyone notice me?
I'd be safe if I'd stayed boring and
forgettable.
This is what happens when someone sees
you.
Soon everyone will see you.
And one day, that everyone will include a
dragon who wants to kill you.
He couldn't have explained how he was so
sure.
Dark Stalker was smiling at the
dragonettes below him.
In fact, he looked absolutely delighted
not particularly murderous.
And yet, as his eyes darted past Turtle
Turtle thought he saw a flash of hatred
there, deep and fierce.
For some reason, this legendary dragon
the most powerful night wing who'd ever
lived, loathed turtle with all his
heart.
Turtle was sure of it.
He's going to kill me the 1st chance he
gets.
This wasn't how he'd expected his story
to end.
Turtle had always loved stories.
He loved histories, and animus tales, and
stories of war, of skyfaring pirates, or
enchanted treasure, of scavengers who
could speak the language of dragons, of
lost tribes and faraway lands.
But his favorite stories were about
heroes.
Especially the ones in the scrolls his
mother wrote.
Since she was so busy with running the
kingdom, writing her scrolls, and
protecting her heirs, Queen Coral didn't
have much time or interest to spare for
any of her 32 sons.
Reading her stories was as close as
Turtle could ever get to her.
He loved scrolls about brave dragons who
saved the day and stopped the forces of
evil.
One of his favorites was about a dragon
named Indigo, who'd rescued the entire
tribe from a deranged killer.
Another starred an insignificant gardener
named Droplet, who'd discovered a secret
invasion of Mudwings and fought them off
before they found the hidden palaces.
The more Turtle read these stories, the
more he imagined a story of his own, a
story where Turtle was the hero, a story
where Turtle battled squadrons of sky
wings and storms of sand wings all on his
own, a story where turtles stood at the
gates of the palace and swung his spear
in ferocious arks, stabbing their enemies
as strong as a whale.
While his older brothers and the rest of
the tribe cowered inside.
A story that ended with his parents
cheering and hugging him, and then his
mother would ride a scroll that was all
about him.
Turtle, the strong and mighty.
Turtle, a tale of a hero, heroically
doing hero type things.
How turtles saved the entire kingdom with
his awesomeness.
Sometimes, when Turtle had a moment alone
or when he wasn't paying attention in
class, he would secretly write pieces of
this story on scraps of slate, he kept
hidden in his room.
He dreamed that one day he'd have a whole
manuscript to show his mother, and then
she might say, oh, son, I know one of my
daughters will run the kingdom
eventually.
But you are the true heir I've been
waiting for, the next rider in the
family.
A hero or a writer?
Or both?
Why not?
That would be Turtle's place in the
world.
But then, too soon and disguised in a
confusing shape, his chance came.
His one opportunity to save the day, and
be a hero in his parents' eyes.
But he didn't even know it until it was
over, and he'd failed.
He failed, and they hated him.
And he'd never get that chance again.
That night, when he'd failed to find
Snapper and save his unhatched sisters
Turtle destroyed every bit of writing
he'd ever done. and swore he would never
write again.
He'd stop dreaming.
He'd stop imagining that a useless dragon
like him.
Could ever save the day, or make
something wonderful.
He wasn't the hero.
And he wasn't the storyteller.
He was the idiot, who fell over his claws
in the 1st chapter, had to be rescued in
the 4th, nearly ruined the whole plan in
the ninth, and ran away at the end, or
died, if he was really extra stupid.
So he hid his one power, and stayed
exactly where he was supposed to, under
the surface of the water.
In the middle of his pack of brothers
ordinary, unmemorable.
A dragon nobody would expect anything
from, and so nobody could ever be
disappointed by him again.
And that had worked for quite a long time
until he made the mistake of caring about
some other dragons, and trying to do a
couple of little things to help them, and
where did that lead him?
Right to the feet of the most terrifying
dragon the world had ever known.
This is the part where I die pointlessly
the one who gets sacrificed, so the real
heroes can get on with saving the day.
His wings were shaking so hard, he
couldn't stay in the air.
He dropped down beside Moon and Kibley
clutching the ground with his talons.
Winter and peril were still hovering in
the sky, their wings beating, silver and
gold flashing in the moonlight.
I need to hide, turtle thought.
But how could anyone hide from the most
dangerous dragon in the world, a mind
reader, an animus, and a seer who knew
the future?
He can't read my mind, though.
Turtle's gaze dropped to the 3 remaining
Skyfire stones in his armband, which
shielded him from mind readers.
Maybe he had a millisecond to do
something, anything, before dark stalker
foresaw it and stopped him.
He scrabbled his talons along the
ground.
Keeping his eyes on the towering night
wing.
His claws closed around something small
and rough, a broken stick, from one of
the trees that had fallen when the
mountain cracked open.
Hide me, Turtle thought at it
frantically.
Hide me from dark stalker.
Dark Stalker stretched his vast wings and
grinned at peril.
Oh.
That's infinitely better, he said.
Nice to finally meet you, Parel.
Thank you so much for your help.
Peril roared furiously, and threw herself
at him, claws outstretched, and flames
blazing from her mouth.
Carol, moon shrieked, as fire engulfed
dark stalker's face.
Oh, no, no, no.
Dark Stalker said, waving away the
smoke.
He pressed one of his front talons into
Parel's chest, and held her at arms
length, while she struggled and tried to
bite him.
Peril.
Very brave, but tisk, tisk.
First of all, I'm your friend.
Although I realize you're new to that
whole concept.
Second of all, invulnerable scales over
here. didn't you know that?
Surely that detail came up at some point
in the great scary legend of Dark
Stalker.
There's nothing you can do to me, little
fire scales, so settle down, and let's
start over.
Peril fell back, breathing heavily and
brushing at her scales, where Dark
Stalker had touched her.
The smoke rising from her wings, twisted
into the thin clouds in the sky
overhead.
Turtle's heart was still pounding.
Dark Stalker turned toward Moon, and his
eyes went right past Turtle, as though
the sea wing prince was not there.
But turtle still didn't feel safe, not
completely hidden, not yet.
Dark stalker paused with a slight frown.
Weren't there?
More of you, he asked, touching his
temple.
Wasn't there someone I particularly
wanted to see?
Moon glanced around, confused.
Particularly wanted to see.
Does he mean me?
I need a better spell.
Turtle thought in a panic.
He gripped the stick harder.
As long as this dick is near me or
touching me.
I enchant it to hide my entire existence
from Dark Stalker.
That means he cannot see me or hear me.
He cannot remember that he's ever heard
of me.
He cannot hear about me in other people's
minds or conversations, and he cannot see
me anywhere in his futures.
I enchant this stick, to completely erase
the dragon holding it from dark stalker's
awareness.
The furrow disappeared from dark
stalker's forehead.
Moon, he cried, beaming at her.
We're finally meeting.
Isn't this amazing?
Wow.
You were a lot smaller than I thought
you'd be.
That's you, actually.
Kibley said, finally finding his voice.
You're a lot bigger than you probably
remember.
Dark stalker looked down at the ground
held out his talons, and flicked his
massive tail, knocking a shower of
boulders down the slope.
He wasn't really as big as the entire
mountain, although it had seemed that way
to turtle at first, but he was at least 3
times as big as the biggest full grown
dragons turtle had ever seen.
I really am.
Dark Stalker said, delighted. 2000 years
of slowly growing.
I must be the hugest dragon that ever
lived.
Also, the oldest.
By all the shining moons.
I'm ancient, aren't I?
Beware the darkness of dragons, Moon said
taking a step back.
Beware the stalker of dreams.
Oh, that's not me, Dark Stalker said.
Moon, come on.
You know that.
I don't slither about in the dreams of
other dragons.
Apart from fixing your nightmares.
I'm guessing that part of the prophecy
was about Queen Scarlet, who, you might
remember, was chalk full of darkness.
On the other talent.
Something is coming to shake the earth.
That's totally me.
Watch this.
He stomped one foot on the ground so hard
that tremors shuddered out in all
directions.
Turtles stumbled and the closest small
tree fell over.
Dark Stalker grinned at Moon.
Pretty impressive.
Right?
He paused, thinking, I guess being this
big is the upside of being alive for 2000
years.
Even if I slept through it all.
By the claw shaped moons, I am so
hungry.
Does anyone have any food?
How did you get out?
Winter demanded.
The look Dark Stalker shot at Winter was
as unfriendly as the one he'd given
Turtle.
He doesn't like ice wings either.
Turtle realized.
But Dark Stalker's answer was cordial.
Oh, that was all peril here, he said.
Tapping the sky wing on the head.
Harold blue eyes were blinking fast, and
her claws kept clenching and
unclenching.
When she set my scroll on fire.
Dark Stalker explained.
All my magic returned to me.
So I could use it to free myself.
Wasn't that kind of her?
Pearl's wings slumped.
She looked as though she'd just rescued a
baby dragonette from a trap, only to
watch it immediately get eaten by a great
white shark.
Turtle wished he could make her feel
better.
He wanted to fly up and tell her this
wasn't her fault, but his wings were
still shaking too hard for him to take
off.
Also, he hadn't completely convinced
himself that the magic was working.
What if Dark Stalker could see him after
all?
He didn't want to draw the night wing's
attention, just in case.
Wait, Moon said.
That means, You lied to me.
She unfurled her wings and pointed at
Dark Stalker.
You told me to destroy the scroll.
If it looked like it would fall into evil
talents, you made it sound like then
you'd be trapped forever.
But it would be worth it to protect
everyone else, but you wanted me to
destroy the scroll all along.
You knew that would send your power back
to you.
You were tricking me.
Yes.
That's true, said Dark Stalker.
But lucky for me that I did, right?
Otherwise, you might never freed me.
Not very kind, Moon.
I'd say, I did the right thing.
He looked at her without a smile for the
1st time.
His eyes odd and glittering.
You called us friends, men said, in a low
voice.
You shouldn't trick your friends.
Yes.
Well, you also should leave your friends
trapped under a mountain for the rest of
their immortal lives.
Dark soccer said briskly.
Good point.
Dog stalker.
Listen, I can't even talk anymore.
I'm so hungry.
Let's all catch something to eat, and
then you can show me around Jade
Mountain.
There are some dragons there.
I can't wait.
To me.
He lifted off into the air, then turned
to beckon at moon.
Come on, Moon.
I just want to have friends again, to use
my voice, to hunt and fly.
Can't we save thee?
Oh no, but you're so sinister and evil.
Talon ringing for later.
What do you say?
Give me a chance.
Moon glanced at Kibley, looking torn.
I'm not going with you, Peril said.
You're not the queen of me.
Me neither, said Winter.
The ice wings have legends about you.
We know what you did to us, and I don't
take orders from, I'm not ordering you to
do anything, Prince Winter.
Dark Stalker said, turning to look at
Winter.
The ice wing fell silent.
But I think you know that those old
legends don't tell the whole truth.
You know that a dragon should not be
judged by what other dragons say about
him.
And the more time you spend with me, the
more I think you'll find that I'm really
an absolutely wonderful dragon.
He smiled, with all his teeth.
Winter touched his temples for a moment
then stared at Dark Stalker with
something new in his blue eyes.
You're right, he said.
Let's start over.
Winter?
Kibley said sharply.
He darted into the sky and up beside
winter, brushing the silver dragon's
wings with his own.
Are you all right?
Of course, said Winter.
He tipped his head toward Dark Stalker.
I am trying not to judge dragons too
quickly anymore.
Let's hear him out.
That doesn't sound like the winter I know
Kibley said to Moon.
Does this seem weird to you?
You don't know me that.
Well, Winter objected.
Snorting a tiny cloud of ice crystals.
Dragons can change.
I've changed.
Maybe he has too.
Without question, Dark Stalker said
nodding.
I've had a lot of time to think about my
mistakes.
Kibli backed away from them, worry
spilling across his face.
Moon, he said carefully, as though he
were reaching for the only island in a
vast empty sea, she flew up beside him
ducking her head to look into Winter's
eyes.
Did you do something to him?
Moon asked Dark Stalker.
Of course I didn't.
Dark Stalker protested, and no, he didn't
cried Winter at the same time.
Dark Stalker, Moon said.
You have to promise me.
You cannot put spells on my friends.
I'm really offended by this, Winter said
haughtily.
I'm such an open minded dragon.
Peril and Kibley snorted in unison.
Moon.
Dark Stalker said reasonably.
I wouldn't waste my animus magic, and my
soul.
On some tiny hush up and ice wing spell.
I mean, seriously.
Don't you remember the whole point of my
scroll, that I made?
To keep your soul safe.
Moon said hesitantly.
She swooped around winter, studying him.
But stop worrying so much.
Dark Stalker nudged her with one of his
giant wings.
Boy, you remind me of someone I used to
know.
Can't you be excited for me?
This is a great day.
Let's go celebrate.
Tell you what, I promise, if I feel the
need to use animus magic, I'll let you
know.
And you promise not to hurt my friends.
Moon asked.
Dark Stalker sighed gustily, sending a
hurricane of leaves swirling around
turtle's feet, I'm hurt, that you even
need to ask me that.
He said.
But of course, if it makes you feel
better, I promise that these 3 are
officially the safest dragons in Pyria.
He waved his talons at Kibli, winter, and
peril.
Moon opened her mouth, then closed it.
She and Kibley simultaneously looked down
at Turtle.
Turtle crouched lower, pressing his
underbelly into the ground, and shook his
head at them.
Let's hunt now, as Dark Stalker suggests
Kibley said, nudging Moon, and figure out
what to do next after that.
He shot a significant glance at Turtle.
Oh no.
That glance had a meaning, a message.
Kibley was expecting Turtle to do
something, and Turtle had a bad feeling
that something wasn't turtle flying all
the way back to the kingdom of the sea
finding a deep trench and staying there
forever.
A queasy, tense feeling started bubbling
through turtle's stomach.
Good idea, said winter.
Moon nodded, and then she gave Turtle a
meaningful look too.
By all the moons.
What did they think he was going to do?
Attack a dark stalker, like peril had?
Obviously that wouldn't work.
If peril couldn't hurt him?
Turtles certainly wouldn't be able to.
Did they want him to hide them as well?
He winced.
He should have thought of that sooner.
A good friend, a better dragon.
A hero would have thought to protect
everyone instead of just hiding himself.
But they all wanted to talk to Dark
Stalker, didn't they?
I just wanted to hide.
That's what I always do.
As the dragons flew away, veering
southwest, Kibli twisted in a spiral
looked at Turtle again, and flicked his
tail in the direction of Jade Mountain.
Oh.
Turtle realized.
They want me to go warn the school.
I can probably do that without messing it
up.
I think.
For a moment, Peril hovered mutinously in
the sky behind them, and then she swooped
down to Turtle.
Aren't you coming too?
She asked.
Don't we all have to follow his grand
mighty lordship's sinister face?
Turtle shook his head and held out the
stick.
He can't see me, he whispered.
I hid myself from him.
Pearl's face lit up.
Of course, she said.
That's awesome.
You have animus magic.
You can kill him.
Oh, said Turtle, flustered.
No, I, I don't really kill anyone.
A brief flash of scales and blood darted
through his mind, and when he looked down
he saw his claws curling dangerously.
He jumped and shook them out until they
looked like his own talons again.
That's not my thing, he said. tamping
down a wave of panic.
I know, I know.
It's my thing, Pearl said.
But I can't kill him because of his
stupid magic growl.
So you have to.
Don't worry, it's not that hard, and it
would be such a relief.
For me, I mean, because I'm having this
feeling, I don't know what to call it, but
it's kind of big and heavy and annoying.
And it's filling me all up inside, like
everything is awful and it's all my
fault.
Like maybe all the bad things in the
world are my fault.
I really don't like it.
So if you can make it stop, that would be
the greatest.
I think what you're describing is what we
call guilt, said Turtle.
But it's not your fault he tricked us.
I still think you did the right thing.
Burning the scroll.
Well, thanks, but the universe disagrees
with you, Peril said.
Jerking her head at the enormous crack in
the side of the mountain.
Peril, called one of the dragons in the
distance.
Good luck, peril whispered.
Make it something really cool, like his
insides exploding.
Or his face falling off.
I'm kidding.
I'm a little bit kidding.
I mean, insides exploding would be pretty
cool, right?
Never mind, it's up to you.
Destroy him and save the world.
Three moons.
I wish I could do it.
She took off and flashed away, fast as a
firework.
Turtles shivered.
Save the world?
That's not my thing either.
I would definitely mess it up.
That's way, way too much pressure.
I'm clearly not a hero.
He raised his eyes to the shadowy peaks
of Jade Mountain.
But I know where I can find some.
Chapter 2.
The sun was starting to sneak over the
mountains, nervously spilling little
beams around the peaks, as if it were
making sure Dark Stalker was gone.
Clouds were visible in the north, with a
gray haze of distant rain below them, but
Jade Mountain was still dry and clear and
sunlit.
Turtle tucked the broken stick, knobbly
and half stripped of its bark, the most
ordinary, insignificant looking thing in
the world, carefully into the pouch
around his neck.
He tied the pouch shut twice as tightly
as usual, and put his front claws over it
as it rested on his chest.
Anxiety twisted inside him.
I'd better not lose this.
He'd lost other animus touched objects
before.
It was a little embarrassing, actually.
When he was three, his many, many older
brothers used to make fun of him for
being the slowest sea wing prints in the
ocean.
Guess somebody gave you the right name.
Ha ha.
Careful or clownfish will catch you.
You swim like a sea cucumber.
So Turtlehead enchanted a strand of
purple kelp, wound 3 times around his
upper arm to make him just a bit faster
than some of his brothers.
He couldn't make himself the fastest, that
would attract attention.
Attention was the last thing he wanted.
But he could be faster than the other 2
from his hatching, octopus and cerulean.
He could be a tiny bit faster than a
couple of the 4 year olds, and that's
where he'd stop.
Then he'd be nothing remarkable, and his
brothers would move on to teasing someone
else.
It worked.
They got bored and left him alone after a
couple more races.
But he still wished he hadn't lost the
kelp a few weeks later.
It drifted off in his sleep one night, and
he often wondered if there was a startled
seahorse tangled up in it somewhere out
there, speeding along the ocean floor.
He knew he should be smarter about what
he enchanted.
He should pick things he couldn't lose
things that would last a while.
But usually he didn't spend enough time
thinking about his spells beforehand to
plan them that carefully.
His spells were all so little, just small
magic to make his life easier, and he
generally used whatever he could grab
with his claws when he needed one.
Like the very ordinary looking river
stone in his pouch, bumping along with a
stick.
It could heal surface wounds and aches
and pains, and he'd enchanted it to make
himself feel better after a long day of
lying.
But it was a silly thing to enchant.
Peril was right about that.
If he ever lost it, he'd never find it
again.
Same with his stick, so he had to be
careful.
He flew toward the main entrance of Jade
Mountain, where he had landed on his 1st
day as a new student.
He remembered how excited he had been, a
new school, nobody knew him here.
It was the perfect place to be a
background character in other dragons
stories.
No one would expect anything of him.
He'd be far away from octopus and
cerulean, who knew about his biggest
failure, and surely must think about it
all the time, even if they never
mentioned it.
Here, he could blend in, be ordinary, and
keep an eye on his little sister Anemone
who had been acting strangely ever since
the attack on the Summer Palace.
None of that had quite worked out the way
he'd planned.
It was his own fault.
If he hadn't chased after the other
dragons in his winglet, he could be sound
asleep with the rest of the sea wing
students right now.
A splash and a peal of laughter caught
his attention, and he soared over Jade
Mountain, following the sound to an
opening in the roof of a cave.
Down there was the underground lake.
And there were dragons swimming in it
even now, at the crack of dawn.
Turtle never woke up early if he could
help it.
But anemone was often up at sunrise, which
meant one of those swimming dragons might
be her.
I should warn her.
Her more than anyone.
He tucked his wings into a dive and
arrowed through the hole, but he somewhat
misjudged his speed, and ended up
smacking into the cold lake, like a hippo
dropped from a great height.
Yow, he yelped, surfacing and rubbing his
eyes, his scales stinging from the
shock.
Turtle?
said a voice nearby.
Turtle, you're back.
Wet wings were flung around his shoulders
dunking him underwater in a cascade of
bubbles.
Anemones glow in the dark scales flashed
happily at him in aquatic as she dragged
him up into the air again.
Hi, he sputtered at his sister.
Hey, you nearly landed on the princess.
Pike shouted in his ear.
The skinny gray blue sea wing had always
been a little louder and more aggressive
than turtle thought was strictly
necessary.
But he'd been much worse, since they'd
arrived at Jade Mountain Academy, thanks
to some secret instructions from Queen
Coral.
Turtle new from eavesdropping, that Pike
was here specifically to be a covert
bodyguard for Princess Anemone.
Anemone, of course, had no idea.
She never seemed surprised that Pike was
so easy to boss around.
In her mind, that was how all sea wings
were supposed to behave around her.
Oh, shush, I'm fine.
Anemone splashed water up Pike's snout
and he backed off, shaking his head
irritably.
Turtle, where have you been?
I had the weirdest nightmare just before
I woke up.
I thought there was an earthquake, but
nobody else felt it.
Did you find your winglet?
Are they here too?
Turtle seized her front claws in his.
Anemone.
I need to talk to you.
You are talking to me, fish face?
she said.
Did you find the rain wing you were
moping about?
You mean Kinkaju?
A little rain wing was sitting in the
shallows of the lake, tilting her ears
toward them.
Her scales were spiraling pale peach and
citrus green, except where they were
covered by swaths of bandages, and
streaks of black scorch marks.
A poultice of damb leaves was tied over
her eyes.
Is Kinkaju all right?
I'm sure she's absolutely fine, Cameron.
Pike said kindly.
He jabbed Turtle in the shoulder with one
claw, much less kindly, and jerked his
head toward Tamarin, scowling.
Turtle hesitated.
The last time he'd seen Kinkaju.
She was lying in a hospital bed in the
town of possibility, unconscious.
Her usually bright, shifting rainbow
scales, had turned white and still.
She had hardly looked like Hinkaju at
all.
But how could he say that to her best
friend?
To Tamarin, who was suffering from her
own injuries after the explosion that
rocked Jade Mountain Academy.
She was alive when I saw her a few days
ago, he hedged.
I'm sure she'll come back to Jade
Mountain, just as soon as she can.
If it's still here when she wakes up.
Oh.
Tameron said softly.
Good.
Anemone, Turtle said.
Come flying with me?
You are being such a jellyfish right
now.
Anemone side.
I don't want to fly.
I want to swim.
Can't you just say whatever it is right
here.
Pike and Tam won't care.
Oh, they might, thought Turtle.
But he could see that anemone wasn't
moving.
This was Anemone's new stubborn, petulant
personality.
The princess who'd risen to the surface
after she was cut free from mother's
harness.
This anemone, made him feel nervous.
This anemone made him feel guilty.
All right, fine, he said.
You're in danger, and you need to leave
Jade Mountain right now.
What danger?
Pike barked, swiveling his head to glare
around the dark cave.
And go where?
Anemone demanded.
Home?
Back to harnesses and boredom, and
mothers staring at me all the time.
No, thank you.
I'm staying here.
She scrambled up on one of the boulders
that jutted out of the water and coiled
her tail around her talons.
But there's a big, scary dragon coming.
Turtle protested.
Anemone looked archly down her snout at
Turtle.
Who are you talking about?
she asked.
I thought our illustrious teachers
defeated all the bad dragons.
This is a new one.
Turtle glanced anxiously up at the sky
above them, which was shifting closer and
closer to full daylight.
His name is Dark Stalker, and he's been
trapped underground for 2000 years and he
just escaped.
I don't really understand the whole story
but I know he's a mind reader and an
animus, and he seems nice on the surface
but...
An animus?
Anemone cried, interrupting him.
She stood up. flaring her wings.
Really?
A real animus?
Yes, turtle said cautiously, but a bad
one, like albatross.
Oh, how would you know?
Anemone scoffed.
I've been dying to meet another animus.
I visited the old fossil living in this
mountain, and he was useless.
His great helpful advice was that an
animus dragon should never use her
power.
I mean, come on.
He was all, but look what happened to
me.
Wheeze, moan, glug.
And I wanted to be like, didn't you put
this dopey stone scales spell on
yourself?
What use is your perfect soul if you
can't move a muscle?
So pathetic?
If there's a real animus coming here, I
want to meet him.
No, Turtle protested.
He'll probably kill you.
He's really smart.
He'll see another animus dragon as a
threat.
If he's really smart, he'll see that I'm
awesome, and want to get to know me.
Anemone said, tossing her head.
Princess, I think your brother is right
Pike interjected.
This sounds like a dangerous situation.
You should hide while I assess this
stranger.
What?
Anemone threw her wings up in disbelief.
I'm not going to hide like some kind of
nervous shrimp. 3 moons.
Turtle, did you actually see him kill
anyone?
No, but according to history, he killed
his dad.
And according to history, she said
dismissively, has he hurt anyone since he
escaped?
No, but he probably will.
He doesn't like ice wings, and he doesn't
like me.
Well, I am not a nice wing, and I'm not
the most boring prince on the planet, she
said.
So I think he'll like me just fine.
Pike, shut up.
Pike closed his mouth and ducked his
head.
Anemone clapped her front talons
together.
This is so exciting.
Another animus to talk to.
Guilt warmed through Turtle's heart
again.
He had thought about telling his sister
his secret a 100 times, if he had ever
admitted that he was a fellow animus
would she be more willing to listen to
him?
Should he tell her now?
Would that stop her from wanting to meet
Dark Stalker?
Probably not.
And to tell her in front of Pike and
Tamarin, just didn't seem like a good
idea.
Pike was one of Queen Coral's most loyal
followers.
He'd definitely report back to her the
1st chance he got, even anemone.
Would she keep his secret?
He wasn't ready.
Better to stay hidden and keep quiet
safer that way.
Anemone dove off her rock and paddled to
the tunnel that led back to the school.
Last one to the main hall is a rotten
oyster. she called, galloping away into
the dark.
Pike hissed softly, twisting between the
disappearing princess and the injured
rain wing by the lake.
It's all right, Pike.
Tamarin said.
She waited out of the water, limping, and
rested one talon lightly on the wall.
I can find my way back to the infirmary
on my own.
Can you go with her?
Pike asked Turtle.
He was halfway to the tunnel already.
Make sure she gets safely to the
infirmary.
I can take care of myself.
Tameron said, through gridded teeth
limping another few steps.
Turtle nodded, and Pike leaped out of the
lake to run after anemone.
I know you 2 were making secret faces at
each other.
Tamarin said, as Turtle climbed out of
the lake beside her.
I don't like it when dragons do that
around me.
Sorry, Turtle said.
I was only responding to his secret
faces.
So is Kinkachu really all right?
Or were his faces making you lie to me?
She asked.
She set off toward the tunnel.
Stepping cautiously but confidently along
the rocky lake shore, Turtle winced.
She did get hurt.
He admitted, following her, pretty
badly.
She's still unconscious, as far as I
know.
But the doctor's impossibility thought
she'd be all right.
If she wakes up soon.
Oh, poor Kinkaju.
Tameron cried.
She stopped and pressed her talons to her
face.
I knew it was too dangerous for her out
there.
She's always running straight at the bad
things, instead of hiding, or at least
thinking first.
That's true, Turtle realized.
That was one of the things he liked about
Kinkachu.
That she was nothing like him.
Queen Glory sent rain wing healers to
watch over her. he said.
She's not alone.
I wish I could go to her, Cameron said
with a sigh.
She set off along the main passageway.
After a moment, she said quietly, I
didn't know anemone was an animus.
Turtle felt like an idiot.
He'd been so worried about hiding his own
powers.
He'd forgotten that anemones were
supposed to be kept secret too.
The other tribes aren't supposed to
know.
He said.
Tsunami's friends do, but they swore not
to tell anyone.
I won't say anything.
Tamron promised.
That must be hard on anemone, keeping a
secret like that.
I guess.
Turtles said uncomfortably.
He'd been keeping the same secret his
whole life, but from everyone.
Was it hard?
Maybe sometimes.
Like whenever something happened, that he
knew his magic could fix, but he had to
go ahead and leave it broken.
Like Tamarin's eyes.
I could fix them.
I could do it right now.
I could enchant that bandage, so when she
takes it off, she could see for the 1st
time in her life.
That was the kind of thing he wished he
was free to do, and it felt awful to have
to stop himself, but he still figured it
was a lot easier to be a secret animus
than an animus everyone knew about.
I wouldn't want to be ananimous, Tamron
said.
She paused at a spot where the tunnel
branched into three directions.
I don't know how anyone could stay a good
dragon with all that power.
What if they only used it for good
things?
Turtle asked, a little stung.
But who gets to decide what's a good
thing?
Tameron asked.
Dragons would always be asking for spells
or telling you your choices are wrong.
And I think sometimes it's hard to tell
what's good, and what's just easy.
Turtle gave her a puzzled look.
Aren't those the same?
What's wrong with trying to make life
easier?
It depends.
Tamron said.
For instance, an animus dragon might
think.
I'll make all our medicinal herbs appear
magically in the healer's treehouse, so
we never have to go looking for them
again.
That seems obviously good, right?
But then we'd stop learning how to look
for them, and we'd stop experimenting
with new ones to see how those might help
dragons in different ways.
We'd stop thinking about it at all
because everything would be too easy.
Don't we lose something when everything
is done for us?
Turtle blinked at her, confused.
I thought rain wings were all lazy, he
said.
I thought your lives were easy, and you
liked them that way.
Not mine.
Tamron said.
Gesturing to her eyes, not Kinkaju.
Maybe we're a little different from the
others.
She shrugged.
Anyway, I can see why Anemone wants
another animus to talk to about it.
Right, said Turtle.
His thoughts had snagged on Kinkaju, and
how she wasn't anything like the rain
wings he'd read about in mother's
stories.
He hadn't thought about that before
because he didn't think Rainwing when he
saw her, he only thought Kinkaju.
I'm really fine from here, said Tamron
flicking her tail at one of the side
tunnels.
You go find clay or tsunami with your
news.
She strode off to the left, limping as
fast as she could, as if she wanted to
prove she didn't need help.
Turtle took the path all the way to the
right, winding up through the mountain
toward the great hall.
Halfway there, he heard voices coming
from one of the caves.
Instinctively.
He slowed down and snuck closer on quiet
talons.
He'd always been good at eavesdropping
and made his life easier, knowing what
other dragons whispered about behind
closed doors.
He'd avoided several palace scandals and
feuds that way.
This might be the kind of thing Tamron is
talking about.
He realized uncomfortably.
A way I make my life easier.
That's not exactly good.
Mother feels terrible, said one of the
voices quietly.
She can't figure out how they escaped.
Can she trust her guards?
asked another voice, which turtle
recognized as his sister tsunami?
Maybe she needs to replace them all
without claws?
Everyone knows their undying loyalty to
Thorn.
But she needs her best outlaws in other
parts of the kingdom, said the 1st
voice.
That must be sunny.
Turtle realized.
There was an explosion at one of our
Western oases a couple of days ago.
Two dragons were killed, and we have no
idea why.
Was it one of those viper licking cactus
bombs like the one here?
asked tsunami, growling.
Seems like it.
Sunnyside.
But it makes no sense that a sky wing
would be out that far west, or targeting
these dragons.
Anyway, mother has enough problems, and
now she's worried that Glory will be mad
at her.
She won't be, right?
Glory knows how tough it is being a new
queen.
Of course, said tsunami.
On the other talent, Thorn did promise to
hang on to those prisoners for her, and
who knows what they'll do now that
they've escaped?
I bet they'll go try to kill glory or
you.
They hate you too, don't they?
See, this is why I come to you with my
problems, Sonny said, because you're
always so comforting.
I can make a stab at comforting?
Tsunami joked.
Let me try.
Um, hey, it's only 2 dragons, right?
Uh, they won't be able to do anything.
Deathbringer will totally stop them if
they go anywhere near her.
I mean, that is his entire purpose in
life as far as I can tell.
And if they kill him, glory will take
them down with her magical death spit.
So don't worry, pat, pat, pat.
Hmm, said Sonny, that was very stabby
comforting.
There was the scrape of claws against
rock. and Turtle realized they were
coming toward the cave entrance.
He backed up to act as though he was
walking along the corridor when the 2
dragons emerged.
Turtle!
Tsunami's face lit up with such delight
that he felt ashamed of spying on her.
By all the moons, Sonny, look!
A student from the Jade Winglet is
actually here at school, where they're
supposed to be.
What a glorious honor.
Is it my hatching day?
or am I hallucinating?
All right, enough sarcasm.
Sunny said, elbowing her in the chest.
Turtle, we've been really worried.
Is everyone else back too?
Well, they're coming, he said.
I'm here to warn you.
They're coming with someone else.
Maybe a bad someone else.
Have either of you ever heard of Dark
Stalker?
Sonny jumped and gave him a startled
look.
I have, when I was chasing fierce teeth
and the others.
I heard them talking about this ancient
night wing legend, a dragon called Dark
Stalker.
They were crazy scared of him, like he
might actually be hunting them right that
minute, even though he died, like
centuries ago.
Um, so that's the thing, said Turtle.
He didn't so much.
Exactly die.
What?
Tsunami demanded, lashing her tail.
He's woken up, Turtle said.
And he's on his way here, right now.
There was a gasp from farther up the
tunnel.
They all turned and found a Nightwing
Dragonette standing there, staring at
Turtle, with his face contorted in
terror.
Chapter 3.
Mighty Claus, Sonny said, holding out her
talons.
Wait, don't overreact.
We don't even know.
I have to warn the others, he cried.
He bolted up the tunnel toward the main
hall.
Oh, good, said tsunami.
School wide panic.
We haven't had any of that in at least 2
days.
Mighty Claus, Sonny called, running after
him.
Wait.
Tell me everything.
Tsunami said to Turtle.
He hurried to keep up with her as they
strode along the winding stone tunnel.
The violet and rose glass lights overhead
reflected off her thoughtful expression.
He didn't tell her everything.
He didn't tell her about his own magic.
He sort of skimmed over the part where he
hid from Dark Stalker, implying that tall
bushes and fallen trees were involved, but
he had to tell her about Moon's powers
although he felt as though that should
have been Moon's secret to share.
Still, there was no other way to explain
the prophecy and how Moon had been
communicating with Dark Stalker.
Arr, no, tsunami said, sweeping her tail
across the floor.
More powers and prophecies?
Seriously?
I thought we were all done with that.
Turtle had told Sunny about Moon's
prophecy before, after his winglet left
but he'd left it up to her to decide who
else to tell.
Apparently, tsunami hadn't been on that
list.
I hate prophecies.
Tsunami muttered darkly.
All cryptic and demanding, most useless
way to communicate in the history of the
world.
Is Dark Stalker as terrifying as he
sounds.
That night wing student looked like he'd
just been bitten by a ghost shark.
He scared me.
Turtle admitted.
He felt a little better now, here in
tsunami's shadow.
The dragonettes of destiny could deal
with Dark Stalker.
He didn't have to do anything.
He could leave saving the world in their
talons.
Let's swing by the library and ask for a
lecture, tsunami said, grinning at
turtle.
It'll make Starflight's day.
They took another branch of the tunnel
and soon came to the wide open cave lined
with scrolls.
One of the leaf windows had been torn
apart when icicle leaped out of it, and
it still hadn't been fixed, allowing a
burst of bright sunbeams to cut across
the otherwise cool green light.
Starflight was behind his desk with fate
speaker, nudging scrolls into 3 different
piles.
His forehead was creased with worry, as
it often was.
Turtle liked Starflight.
He was quiet, and better yet, he led
other dragons be quiet.
After the rest of Jade Winglet left the
school.
Turtle would often sit in the library by
himself.
And Starflight never asked questions or
made him talk.
Hey, Starflight.
Tsunami tapped the desk lightly, so the
blind librarian would know where she
was.
Don't explode with joy or anything, but I
have a historical question for you.
Really?
Starflight's phase lit up, turning toward
the sound of her talons, which era?
I have no idea, tsunami snorted.
Is there an era of sinister bad guys?
What do you know about a dragon called
Dark Stalker?
Something clattered to the floor across
the room, and Turtle realized there was a
trio of ice wings studying over by the
windows.
They'd dropped their scroll when they
heard tsunami's question, and now they
were leaning towards Starflight with
sharp, curious expressions.
He was a very powerful animus nightwing
who disappeared over 2000 years ago.
Starflight said cautiously.
The stories say he was betrayed by his
friend, a sea wing animus named Fathom
and perhaps also by his girlfriend
Clearsight.
But nobody knows exactly what happened to
him.
He didn't really disappear, said one of
the ice wings.
He spent years lurking in the shadows and
killing ice wings.
And you're leaving out the part about him
killing his own father, said another ice
wing, flicking her wings back, who was an
ice wing prince?
By the way, Whoa, really?
Tsunami said, giving Turtle a worried
look.
That story has been highly oversimplified
said Dark Stalker, poking his head in
through the broken window.
I mean, don't any of the scrolls mention
that he totally deserved it.
The ice wings shrieked in unison, loud
enough to break glass.
They scrambled over one another to get
away from the oversized night wing
knocking down an entire shelf of scrolls
in the process.
Paper unfurled across the cave in
cascading fountains.
Turtle froze, trying to sink into the
floor.
How had Dark Stalker gotten here so
fast?
Was he already done hunting?
Where were turtles friends?
What's happening?
Starfly cried.
Who was that?
Oh, really?
Really?
Really big night wing?
Fate speaker yelped, clutching his arm.
I haven't had any visions about this.
This seems seriously vision worthy.
Powers, help me out.
She closed her eyes.
Oh no, I see.
Darkness ahead.
That's because you have your eyes closed
you ninny.
Dark Stalker said pleasantly.
Who are you?
Tsunami demanded.
You already know, he said, startled.
This is amazing.
How empire did you know I was coming?
He paused.
I can't even find the answer to that in
your mind.
What in the world?
A fascinating mystery.
Don't think about it too hard.
Turtle prayed.
Don't figure out there's a secret to
uncover here.
So you are dark stalker.
Tsunami lashed her tail.
You'd better not hurt any of my
students.
What?
Starflight sputtered.
Dark stalker?
How?
Why would I hurt any of your students?
Dark Stalker protested.
There's literally 0 motivation for me to
do that.
Dragons today, so full of mistrust and
hostility.
Now, in my time, no wait.
We were exactly the same.
He poked at the ragged green edges of the
leaf window pane.
That's one of the many problems I was
going to fix.
It's the dark stalker, shouted one of the
ice wings.
Die, you monster.
She leaped across the cave, blasting
frost breath in Dark Stalker's face
landed in a roll right in front of his
snout, and slashed her serrated claws
across his nose.
All of which, of course, did nothing to
him.
The ice wings staggered back, shaking her
arm as if she'd just smashed it into a
rock.
Dark Stalker gave her a bored look.
Then reached one of his long talons
through the window, and casually pinned
her to the floor.
All right, he said.
Now, I'm a little motivated to hurt
somebody.
Tsunami started toward him, and he
chuckled.
Oh, I won't, he said.
I promise.
No need to get all ferocious with me
tsunami.
But you might want to add a manners class
to your curriculum.
Or is it fine with you if your students
attack innocent visitors?
Let her go.
Tsunami growled.
Dark Stalker lifted his claws, and the
ice wing scrambled away.
All 3 ice dragons bolted out of the cave
as fast as they could run.
I don't think I'll fit through the
tunnels to get in here.
Dark Stalker said regretfully, glancing
around the library, but I love what
you've done with the space, Starflight.
Could you please bring any scrolls you
have about Clearsight and meet me in the
main entrance hall?
Scrolls about clear site, Starflight
echoed.
You're, uh, the dragon, you...
Yes, said Dark Stalker.
The dragon I loved.
Specifically, about what happened to her
after, well, after our unfortunate
misunderstanding.
But nobody knows, Starfly blurted.
She disappeared at the same time you
did.
Maybe there's a clue somewhere, Dark
Stalker said.
Or a terrific librarian.
If anyone can find it, you can.
His eyes narrowed.
Perhaps it would also be useful.
To bring any scrolls about what happened
to fathom.
I, I, Starflight stammered, moving his
claws along the desk.
Fate speaker grabbed one of his talons
and leaned into him.
Thanks ever so much, said Dark Stalker.
Now, if you'll excuse me, someone is
trying to attack my tail.
He swung his head out the window, and
Turtle heard him say, seriously, you
too.
Does everyone believe everything they
read these days?
Tsunami hurried over to the window.
Turtle managed to breathe again, managed
to move one foot slowly in front of the
other to follow her.
Outside, 2 small night wings were dive
bombing dark stalker, shooting trails of
flame across the scales.
Turtle saw his friends hovering in the
sky not far away.
Moon was trying to call to the night
wings, but they weren't listening to
her.
Dark Stalker lifted off from the
mountainside and turned in a large, slow
circle, watching the night wings without
fighting back.
He looked faintly amused.
Tiny dragons, he boomed.
Listen, I'm impressed, but this really
isn't necessary.
We're not going to let you hurt our tribe
shouted one of the dragon ants.
It was hard to tell from a distance, but
Turtle thought that was Mighty Claus.
By the shining moons.
I'm not planning to herd the tribe, said
Dark Stalker.
It's my tribe too, isn't it?
I'm a loyal night wing.
All the stories ever mention that.
Come on now.
Nightwings are usually so clever.
You must have noticed this isn't
working.
He caught mighty Claus gently in his
talons and set him on a ledge.
The other Nightwing darted in and wrapped
herself around Dark Stalker's neck, trying
to plunge her claws in between the scales
of his underbelly.
I don't mean the attack itself.
Dark Stalker went on, as if he barely
noticed his new violent scarf, although
that's not working either.
I mean the distraction.
It's not actually possible to distract
me.
Because guess what?
Mind reading.
Plus also visions of the future.
But good try.
He whipped around, dove toward the forest
and emerged a moment later with a 3rd
night wing dragonette struggling between
his talons.
No, no.
Dark Stalker shook his head at her.
Listen, I understand.
If I were you, I'd want to sneak off and
warn the rest of the tribe too.
But you know what they'll do then?
I do.
I saw it in a vision.
They'll run away and try to hide from me
again, without even giving me a chance to
introduce myself.
We know all about you, Mighty Claus
yelled.
We know you've been trying to break free
for 2000 years so you can get revenge on
our tribe.
That makes no sense, Dark Stalker said
reasonably.
I did just escape a 2000 year trap.
But the tribe didn't deceive me and stick
me underground.
That was 2 foolish dragons, using magic.
It was nothing to do with the other night
wings.
I adore my tribe.
I'm wildly excited to rejoin you and let
everyone see the real me.
He set down the night wing next to Matty
Claus, and unwrapped the other one from
his neck as though she were a harmless
sloth.
So, we're not going to ruin the surprise
all right?
We can all go together to tell the tribe
I'm back.
Trust me.
It'll be great.
Much less bloody and horrifying than what
you all have in your minds.
More feasting.
And rainbows.
Hang on.
Where did that come from?
Ah, I know.
Dark soccer turned toward the landing
area that led to the main school
entrance.
Clay and Sonny stood there, both of them
breathing heavily, as though they'd been
running.
Feasting.
Dark stalker said, pointing at clay.
And rainbows.
He pointed at Sonny and grinned.
Step away.
From my students.
Sonny hissed.
Sonny!
Dark Stalker cried, with enormous
delight.
He swooped down to land facing her.
It was so tiny for such a shaker of
worlds.
Don't you know who I am?
I do.
You're the dark stalker, she said.
It's just dark stalker.
He corrected her.
Not sure where this the came from.
That makes me sound like some kind of
lurking Kraken type monster.
Clay cleared his throat.
Isn't that, um, kind of what you are?
Not at all, Dark Stalker said with a
laugh.
Sonny, get this.
I'm your great, great, great, great
great.
Okay, I'm losing count many greats.
Great uncle.
He bowed.
Surprise.
More funny looking family for you.
He spread his wings, and Turtle realized
he had a line of silvery scales against
the black along the curve under his wings
where they met his body.
Those must be from his ice wing father.
Sonny hesitated, glancing around at all
the listening dragons, lit by the pink
orange sunrise sky.
The 3 night wings stood close together on
the ledge where Dark Stalker had put them
shivering, but unharmed.
Overhead, the sunlight glinted off the
scales of turtles' companions, winter's
bright white, Kibley's pale yellow, and
peril's fiery copper.
Moon landed beside Sonny, and they
brushed wings for a moment, each
reassuring the other silently.
Turtle wished he could read minds like
Moon did.
What did Sonny think of Dark Stalker?
She'd obviously prepared to defend her
students from a monster, only to find a
charming relative instead.
Beside him in the library window, tsunami
was lashing her tail, as though she
couldn't decide whether to go out and
attack him or not.
Uncle?
Sonny asked dark stalker.
Really?
Great, Uncle Dog Stalker.
The huge night wing shook his head
chuckling.
That sounds so weird.
Like I'm a 1000 years old.
I mean, I know I'm technically ancient.
But I sure don't feel that way.
Did Whiteout end up marrying that glass
blowing dragon with the spectacles?
I'll have to ask Starflight.
I bet he knows.
Sonny.
You have my sister's eyes.
Hers were bluer, of course, not so green
but the same shape.
You would have loved her.
How can you say that?
Sonny asked.
You don't know me.
Of course I do, said Dark Stalker.
I can read your mind and see your
futures.
Remember?
I woke up several months ago.
To find myself under a mountain, and 20
centuries older than I was, when my
friends betrayed me.
Since then, I've had nothing to do except
read all your minds, and dream of
freedom.
All our minds?
Clay asked.
That's kind of nosy, isn't it?
Literally, nothing else to do.
Dark Stalker said apologetically.
But don't worry, Clay.
Your thoughts are all very sweet.
Especially when it comes to certain
dragons.
He winked, and Clay managed to look
embarrassed, alarmed and confused all at
the same time.
But wait, what makes you think we are
related, Sonny asked.
Your father's a night wing animus.
Dark Stalker pointed out.
So he must be descended from me or
Whiteout.
And I know I didn't have any
dragonheads.
Although I was supposed to.
He caught a fragment of cloud between his
talons and watched it fade into empty
air.
So, your sister, White Out, was my great
great, great something great's
grandmother, Sonny asked.
She must have been, Dark Stalker said
shaking himself.
But there's so much I don't know.
All my friends and family are gone
sonny.
I miss them, and I have no idea what
happened to them.
So I've asked Starflight to find some
scrolls for me.
Just to fill in the gaps and answer my
questions.
I hope that's all right.
He smiled, but his eyes were sad.
Turtle glanced over his shoulder.
Starflight was hurrying around the
library, pulling out scrolls and putting
them back, checking their titles with his
claws.
He kept slipping on the loose scrolls and
catching himself.
Every once in a while, he paused, and
gave a scroll to fate speaker, who wrote
the title down on a slate.
Maybe this really is all dark stalker
once.
Turtle thought.
A few answers about what happened all
those 100s of years ago.
Maybe he's as friendly and harmless as he
seems.
And yet, and yet, the way he'd looked at
turtle in winter, that flash of darkness
deep inside him, peering out.
Not to mention the ominous prophecy, of
course.
Turtle touched the pout that rested
against his heart.
Don't be noticed.
He would stay hidden until he was
absolutely positively sure it was safe.
Dark stalker!
A voice called from above, a peal of
thunder boomed off the clouds like an
echo.
Turtle looked outside again and up, just
like everyone else, including Dark
Stalker.
Lightning flashed, illuminating the
outline of a dragon against a sky that
was suddenly and rapidly getting darker.
She spread her front talons, and wind
rushed up behind her with a howling force
that made even the giant night wing
stagger back a few paces.
Her wings twitched, and the thunder
rolled again, louder and closer, and more
menacing than before.
Dark Stalker gathered his wings and
planted his feet, watching the dragon
overhead.
A slow smile spread across his face.
Anemone, he said.
Just the dragon I was looking for.
Chapter 4.
Oh, no.
Turtle breathed.
Me?
Anemone echoed. sounding as young as she
was and heartbreakingly delighted.
She flicked her claws to make the
lightning flash again.
Now illuminating her face.
You were looking for me?
And you made it more than easy for him to
find you.
Turtle thought.
Not to mention announcing your power to
everyone else who didn't know the sea
wings have an animus.
Now, every tribe in Pyria would know
about anemones magic.
Apart from all the dragons outside.
He could see faces watching from nearly
every window in the school.
Students roused from their beds, either
by the commotion outside, or by the
panicked ice wings.
Oh, anemone.
Why would anyone ever draw so much
attention to themselves?
Tsunami snapped her tail, hissing, What
is she doing?
She cried.
Before Turtle could answer.
Not that he had any sort of answer, unless
maybe losing her mind counted.
Tsunami was out the window and flying up
toward anemone.
One moment, big sister, Anemone said
holding out her talons.
The wind spiraled up and around, spinning
tsunami away from her.
Below them, Clay and Sonny both started
forward with a gasp, but tsunami caught
herself on the 2nd spin and hovered where
she was.
Why were you looking for me?
Anemone asked Dark Stalker.
Because I sense to kindred spirit. he
said, gesturing at the storm rising
around her.
I've been listening to your mind since
you arrived at Jade Mountain.
And I saw instantly how special you are.
A dragon, as smart and practical as I am
and of course, a fellow animus.
Did he know about me before I hid
myself?
Turtle wondered.
Only Winter, Kibli, Peril, and Moon knew
about his anima's power, but neither
peril nor moon wore skyfire to protect
their thoughts.
Dark Stalker could have lifted that
information from either of their minds.
Or he could have seen it in a vision of
the future.
If there was a crazy future where Turtle
used magic in front of him.
That's me.
Anemone said, lifting her front claws
into the air.
Lightning sizzled down from the clouds
and gathered in her webbed talons like
deadly trapped moons.
The light gave her face an eerie glow
shining over her scales, like an aquatic
birthmark, making sure everyone could see
how different she was.
Finally, someone who understands me.
Anemone, tsunami said, her voice
cracking.
Oh, I know you love me, Anemone said to
her.
Plenty of dragons love me, but
understanding me?
See, that takes another animus.
I'm not sure it does, Turtle thought.
He'd never felt further from
understanding her than he did right this
moment.
I did this all wrong, like I always do.
I should have told her the truth about me
or I should have lied about Dark
Stalker.
I should have come up with something that
could have stopped this from happening.
I'm very impressed, anemone.
Dark Stalker said, spreading his wings at
the churning stone colored sky.
You know, I've never tried controlling
the weather.
What a clever idea.
What did you enchant?
Dark clouds now blotted out the sunrise
bloated with rain that was forbidden to
fall.
Small flickers of lightning curled in the
depths of the clouds, like the breath of
newly hatched sky wings, the air smelled
like the sea was hiding overhead, ready
to drown everyone.
These, anemones said, displaying 2 beaten
copper armbands on her wrists, the metal
rippling like waves of fire.
I wanted you to see what I could do.
She said proudly.
But anemone, tsunami choked out.
Your soul.
I feel fine, tsunami, anemone said
flicking her tail.
I mean, we are supposed to use our powers
sometimes, right?
She asked Dark Stalker.
Like, when it's really important, and
couldn't these be totally useful?
She reached up again and opened a small
hole in the clouds for the sun to pour
through.
Absolutely.
Dark Stalker agreed.
They're brilliant.
Don't worry, tsunami.
Anemone is many spells away from
massacring anyone.
And now I'm here to help her without soul
problem.
Come on down, princess, and let's talk.
Anemones soared down to him with no
hesitation.
Turtle watched her go with the same sick
sinking feeling that had hit him the day
he heard his father had been captured by
Queen Scarlet's troops.
There's nothing I can do.
He could feel peril watching him, but he
couldn't meet her eyes.
Don't wait for me to fix this.
I can't.
I don't know where to start.
And I don't have any good ideas, and
whatever I tried.
I do it wrong anyway.
As Anemone and Dark Stalker stepped into
the main entrance cave.
Anemone looked back up at her sister, and
the other dragon still outside.
She smiled.
And the rain began to fall.
Heavy droplets pelted turtles' wings as
he flew up to where his friends were
gathered in the sky.
I'm sorry, he said, as soon as he was
close enough to speak.
I did try to warn the school, but I guess
it didn't make any difference.
Warn the school about what?
Winter asked.
The giant 2000-year-old super dragon that
just climbed out of a mountain?
Turtle answered.
Oh, he's not here to hurt anyone, said
Winter.
I know.
I was worried at 1st too, but dark
stalker's not a monster.
He just wants to make friends and start
over.
See, I feel like that's true, said Kibley
but then winter, of all dragons, says
something like that, and I get nervous.
Cut off the exploding gets plan, turtle.
Pearl called cheerfully, swooping around
them with their wings, carving paths of
steam through the pelting rain.
He's not evil after all.
Wait, really?
Turtle tried to blink away the rain that
kept pulling on his snout.
Are we sure?
What happened to change your mind so
fast?
Well, he's been super nice to me, said
Pearl, which kind of never happens.
So he's obviously more awesome than the
average dragon.
And he pointed out that animus powers and
fire scales are the same, because other
dragons are always scared of us, but they
shouldn't be, totally true, right?
I mean, I wouldn't want my insides
exploded by magic just because someone
thinks, I'm scary.
You are scary.
Kibli said to her.
But I'm also in favor of you staying in
one piece.
Why, thank you, she said, pleased.
So it makes sense, right?
Turtle?
If we deserve a chance to prove ourselves
good, then why doesn't Darkstalker?
That's right, said Kibli.
That's a good point.
But didn't he already have that chance?
Turtle asked.
And didn't it end with killing his own
father?
Oh.
That's a good point too.
Kibley scrunched his eyes shut, as though
his head hurt.
My brain feels like it's trying to swim
through honey.
That father business is ancient history
said Winter.
We don't know exactly what happened.
I'm sure he has a good explanation.
Me too, said Pearl.
So we're all.
We're not worried anymore, said Turtle.
Welcome back, Dark Stalker, carry on.
Do all the magic you'd like.
You just need to spend a little time with
him and you'll see.
Winter said.
Are we done with this boring
conversation?
I'd like to go get dry, if you please.
He shook off his wings and dove toward
the caves without waiting for an answer.
Never tell him I said this, said Pearl
but I agree with a chili prince.
Off with your hiding spell, turtle, and
onward with your face.
She gestured toward Turtle's pouch, and
he shied away from her. covering it with
his talons.
Or you can keep skulking around, she said
with a shrug, whatever you want.
I'm going to go say hi to Clay.
I mean, to uh, him and his friends.
So I can tell him what I did to Scarlet.
I mean, tell all of them.
What Ruby did, technically, but with my
help.
He's going to be so excited, don't you
think?
So excited.
I mean, not that it's any big deal.
Well, I guess it's kind of a big deal
that I stopped his like super worst enemy
from coming after him.
He'll be happy about that, right?
Not that it matters.
Why am I nervous?
I'm not.
Stop being nervous, Parel.
Ha ha.
That'll work.
Three moons.
Just go talk to him, you unexpected
flutterhead.
Kibley said with a laugh.
I will.
I'm going, peril said.
Don't wish me luck because I don't even
need it, because why would I?
Because who cares?
She shook herself from horns to tail.
Wipe to raindrops off her snout and
spiral down to the school.
Wow, said Kibley.
Am I like that around Moon?
Are you?
Turtle asked. only half listening.
Peril did seem like the kind of dragon
who could change her mind about someone
at a moment's notice.
So maybe this was normal.
And maybe Dark Stalker was as great as
they all thought, and Turtle was wrong to
be so anxious.
But something didn't feel right.
Just kidding.
Kibley said quickly, forget I said that.
Um, turtle.
I think actually, don't unhide yourself
yet.
Really?
Turtle twisted toward him in the air.
Raindrops kept splashing in his eyes and
making it hard to see.
It felt as if the clouds were gathering
lower and lower, as though they might all
pile on top of his wings at any moment.
My instincts tell me I can trust Dark
Stalker, Kibley said.
Tilting his claws to watch the raindrops
side in different directions.
But my head says to be more careful.
So maybe it's smart to have one dragon
who can watch him without being seen for
a little while.
Can you do that?
Watch him, and then tell me what you
see.
I guess.
Turtle tugged the webs between his talons
nervously.
But like what?
What if I missed something?
What am I looking for?
I don't know, Kibley admitted.
But whatever you see, come talk to me
about it, all right?
We'll figure it out together.
All right.
Turtle said uncomfortably.
He stayed in the air for a moment as
Kibley flew away.
At least I'm not the only one who's
worried.
But he couldn't shake the dread that
crept along his wings.
It was a lot of pressure, being the one
who had to keep an eye on Dark Stalker
being the only one who could, really.
He didn't like the feeling that Kibley
was relying on him.
I don't want to be the spy.
In all the stories.
Spies are competent, and quick thinking
and clever, and I'm none of those things
or else they're incompetent, and then
they get caught, and their part of the
story ends in a dungeon, or a quick
death.
Not exactly the character arc I was
hoping for.
I'm not the right dragon for this.
He followed his friends slowly, listening
to the thunder roll overhead, and
wondering where the lightning would
strike.
Chapter 5.
Inside the main entrance cave, Turtle
crept around the small groups of gathered
dragons until he was huddled behind the
bronze gong.
Nobody noticed him.
He'd perfected the art of moving slowly
of being boring and forgettable and
ordinary, and it certainly helped that
everyone had a much bigger, flashier
dragon on their minds at the moment.
It's such a vague threat.
Dog stalker was saying to anemone, as
turtle curled into his hiding spot.
I mean, what is a soul?
How do you really know if someone's
losing theirs, or it's going bad, or
whatever the big danger is supposed to
be?
Right, Anemone said, as though she were
pouncing on a scuttling crab.
I mean, there haven't been that many
animus dragons in history, have there?
What if Albatross was already bad, and it
had nothing to do with his magic at all?
Turtles shivered.
He'd had these thoughts himself.
Many times, but it was unsettling to hear
them spoken aloud.
He wanted to believe that his soul would
be fine no matter what he did.
He would still be the one making all the
choices, good or bad, wouldn't he?
And he was a good dragon.
But perfectly nice, harmless dragon, with
no reason to hurt anyone.
A plume of blood flickered through his
memory.
Was it only 2 days ago?
Or three?
He remembered the clammy feeling of mud
between his talons as they confronted
that dragon, Perel's father, sore, or
chameleon, or shapeshifter, the one with
many names.
He'd been holding Dark Stalker's scroll
and Turtle had used animus magic to take
it from him.
The truth was, he hadn't just taken the
scroll.
He'd attacked Chameleon with it.
Bashing him in the face and probably
breaking his nose.
It was the only violent spell he'd ever
cast.
Once more, he noticed his talons were
clenched against his will.
And he had to force them straight.
Deep breaths.
I am in control of my own self.
I am not a bad dragon.
He'd never done anything like that before
in his life.
He certainly wouldn't be able to do it
with his own claws.
But with magic.
It was different.
It didn't feel like he was really hurting
someone else.
Except for now, in his memories, where
the screaming dragon kept appearing over
and over again.
But he hurt Kinkachu.
Turtle reminded himself.
He put her in a coma.
He also tricked peril and put a spell on
her to make her work for Scarlet again.
He deserved it.
He brushed his front talons together, as
though he were wiping off wet sand.
Was this what it felt like to lose part
of his soul?
Was this the 1st step toward darkness?
He still felt like himself.
But maybe a slightly more powerful
version of himself.
Was that bad?
I know what you did.
Dark Stalker rumbled softly, and for a
moment, Turtle's heart stopped.
I know what you worry about.
You do?
Anemone whispered.
Turtle peeked out and saw that the cay
was almost empty now.
Only dark soccer, anemone, tsunami, and
moon remained.
She was protecting us, tsunami said
quickly.
She was saving us.
Turtle felt a flash of panic.
What did anemone do?
Something terrible?
When?
How did he miss it?
I agree, said Dark Stalker.
You shouldn't feel guilty, princess.
I don't, Anemone said, lifting her chin.
He deserved it.
Turtle heard the echo of his own thought
and winced.
Who was she talking about?
But did it change you?
Tsunami asked.
Do you feel?
Soulless?
Anemone laughed.
A little too brightly.
No way.
I think I have a pretty normal soul for a
dragon.
But you won't ever have to worry again.
If we protect that soul, like I protected
mine.
Dark Stalker flicked his tail.
With a different spell this time though.
We're going to need something to
enchant.
None of my talismans survived the 2000
years underground with me.
I can find us something, Anemone said
jumping to her feet.
I have some great treasure.
Mother always gives me the best jewels.
It doesn't have to be fancy, Dark Stalker
said.
It just has to be sturdy.
So our souls will be safe forever.
He smiled at Moon.
I know that would make certain dragons
here a lot happier.
I don't know, said Moon, studying him
with a wary expression.
Your soul was protected before, and you
still killed your father.
Oh, by all the moons, Dark Stalker said
crossly.
He reared up, filling the cavern with his
giant wings.
Listen.
Arctic was about to betray the whole
tribe.
He was trying to sell my sister to the
ice wings in exchange for his own
safety.
He would have made her marry an ice wing
and live in their kingdom forever.
And he was mind controlling her.
If I hadn't stopped him, Sonny wouldn't
even exist.
And maybe the night wings wouldn't
either.
Because Arctic was going to help the ice
wings wipe us out.
He was a traitor, who had to die.
Dark Stalker pointed at Moon.
I was protecting you, and all the tribes
of future descendants.
I'm shocked that everyone has completely
forgotten about that.
Well, said Moon.
Watching a dragon disembowel himself
probably has kind of a traumatizing
effect on one's memory.
Wait, what?
said tsunami.
Dissum, what now?
Did you really do that?
Anemone said.
Looking up at Dark Stalker.
But Turtle didn't like her expression.
There wasn't nearly enough disgust or
horror there.
He didn't like it at all.
Did I say disembowel?
Dark soccer waved one talon?
I was exaggerating.
It was a simple honor suicide.
Even he knew he deserved it.
Moon crossed her front talons, arching
her brows at him skeptically.
Wow, said Dark Stalker.
Oh, we sure clear sight didn't have
dragonets after I was gone, because you
do an uncanny impression of my true
love's disapproving phase.
I'm only trying to make sure you don't
overuse your power.
Go crazy and hurt someone, Moon said.
Moon, Dark Stalker said reproachfully.
I can see the future, remember?
I know how to stop myself from doing
that.
Do you want me to show you where our
paths are going?
He held out one of his talons to her.
I can take you along the whole timeline
for the next 100 years.
If you like.
His tale nudged her mischievously.
One to see which one of them you should
choose.
I can show you what the future looks like
with both options.
Although frankly, I think neither of them
are good enough for you.
No, no, no, thank you.
Moon said quickly, covering her ears.
I don't want to hear it.
I have no idea who you're talking about.
I mean, what you're talking about.
Stop thinking about them.
La la la, ignoring you.
Hey, what about me?
Anemone interjected.
I want to see the future.
Will you show me what's going to happen
to me?
Tsunami looked from her sister to Dark
Stalker.
Her expression wavering between concern
and curiosity.
A vision could show us that anemone turns
out all right.
Turtle thought.
We wouldn't have to worry about her soul
anymore if we saw a peaceful future ahead
for her.
Anything you want, Dark Stalker said
expanding his wings to their full width.
You both have so many possible amazing
futures.
And now that I'm here, if you trust me, we
can make sure you get exactly the right
future for you.
Anemone's eyes were shining like the
Skyfire comet.
Even Turtle couldn't help thinking, It
would be nice to know my future.
To have someone who could tell me the
right steps to follow, to make sure my
life turns out all right, which spells
are safe to cast, how to protect myself
and my soul.
What I'm here for.
Dark Stalker raised one of his talons, and
Turtle nearly ducked behind the gong
again, out of sight, but he managed to
stay put, sinking into a crouch, and so
he was watching, as Dark Stalker lifted a
claw to gently touch the earring in his
ear, pale against the black scales.
An earring.
Had that been there before?
Turtle tried to think back, to remember
what dark stalker had looked like when he
rose from the earth, he thought he
remembered no jewelry.
And didn't Dark Stalker just say that
nothing had survived the 2000 years
underground with him?
But now he was wearing an earring.
A plain white half loop stabbed through
his earlobe.
Turtle squinted at it.
It looked as though it was made of bone.
Like a bone one might get from one's prey
after hunting.
Could Dark Stalker have made the bone
earring and enchanted it today?
While Turtle was flying to Jade Mountain
to warn the school?
And more important.
If it was animus touched, what was the
spell?
A short while later, tsunami and moon
went off to separate parts of the
school.
Turtle crouched in the shadows, watching
them leave.
He felt like stalagmites were growing
through his talons, pinning him to the
floor.
He didn't want to be left alone here.
The only one keeping an eye on Dark
Stalker.
Who would ever think that was a good
idea?
He couldn't be trusted to do anything
right.
Maybe I need to enchant someone else to
be hidden with me. someone who could be a
better observer.
A better spy.
A real hero.
He thought about that while Anemone
brought Dark Stalker several pieces of
treasure from her travel chest.
Turtle remembered that chest, because
he'd had to help carry it here from the
kingdom of the sea, and it was
ridiculously heavy.
Now, seeing the ropes of pearls, bulky
silver neck bands, and sapphire laden
tiaras she laid out on the cave floor
turtle could understand why.
Although he still wasn't entirely clear
on why she needed any of this for history
lessons and math classes.
Together, dark stalker and anemone, picked
through the jewels, discussing the merits
of each.
It was difficult to find anything that
fit dark stalker's enormous size, but
they eventually settled on a piece that
was supposed to be a metal breastplate
for anemone, fitting around her entire
chest to protect her from attacks.
It clicked neatly around one of Dark
Stalker's wrists.
Mother is always giving me ridiculous
things like that, Anemone said.
As if I need armor to protect me when I
have magic like ours.
She has no idea what it's like to be
ananimous.
Dark soccer said sympathetically.
He passed anemone a necklace.
Maybe this one for you.
If you think you'd be happy wearing it
all the time.
Oh.
Sure, said Anemone, taking the heavy
silver band in her talons.
I mean, I never liked it before, but if
you think it would work, then I like it
too.
It's up to you, said Dark Stalker.
It should be something you love.
I love this, Anemone said emphatically.
She snapped it around her neck with a
sound like eggs cracking, turtle's
stomach twisted, as though it were full
of rotten shrimp.
Now, the enchantment.
Dark Stalker said.
He touched his wristband with one claw
gazing thoughtfully up at the vines
draped between the stalactites.
In a slightly deeper voice, he intoned.
I enchant this bracelet, to protect my
soul from the effects of animus magic
forever.
There was a pause.
Is that it?
Anemone asked.
Seriously?
It's that simple?
Surely not. thought Turtle.
It can't be.
I don't know.
Dog stalker twitched his wings back and
held out his arm to study the bracelet.
I guess we'll have to see if it works.
He squinted.
My visions of the future seem to indicate
that it does.
Yep, yep.
I'm still a pretty awesome dragon 50
years from now.
All right.
Said anemone with a giggle.
Well, 3 moons?
I can do that.
I could have done that months ago.
Why hasn't every animus done something
like this?
They haven't always known to worry about
these things.
Dark stalker observed.
Or perhaps they did have objects like
this, and we just don't know about them.
Hmm.
Anemone touched her necklace with one
claw, mirroring dark soccer's movement.
Wait, said Dark Stalker.
My soul is safe now.
Let me use my magic to enchant yours, so
you don't have to waste any more of your
soul.
No, turtle thought.
Don't let him.
Anemone, don't trust him.
Great idea.
Anemone said happily.
Should he stop this?
Could he stop this?
What can I do?
I have to do something, don't I?
Like what?
I need more time to think.
The turtle couldn't think of anything he
could do without dark stalk or noticing
and it was already too late.
I enchant this necklace.
To protect anemone's soul from the
effects of animus magic forever.
Said Dark Stalker, tapping the silver
collar lightly with his claws.
It sounded safe.
It sounded exactly like the spell on Dark
Stalker's own talisman, but Turtle knew
all too well that spells could be cast
without speaking.
Had Dark Stalker added anything to the
spell with his mind.
Oh anemone.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
This is so cool, said Anemone.
Now we can do anything we want.
That, said Dark Stalker with a grin.
Is the whole idea.
Chapter 6.
Dark Stalker spent the rest of the day in
the main entrance cave. reading through
scrolls, and talking to any students who
are brave enough to approach him.
By the middle of the day, it began to
feel quietly normal to have him there.
He didn't do anything sinister.
He didn't use any magic.
He acted like a friendly visitor who just
needed to use the library on his way
through the mountains.
Anemone sat beside him with her chin
lifted, looking as royal as she did when
she sat beside mother at council
meetings.
Every once in a while, Dark Stalker would
pass her a scroll and ask her to read it
out loud to him, or to check it for
references to Fathom, and she would do so
beaming.
The school gradually returned to its
usual activities.
From his spot, hidden behind the bronze
gong, Turtle saw mudwings passed through
on the way to the art room.
He saw sand wings carrying musical
instruments, he saw rain wings with
baskets heading out to pick berries.
There was no sign of the ice wings.
Turtle wondered if they were hiding
somewhere.
He also wondered why nobody came to make
anemone go to whichever class she was
supposed to be in.
Pike stalked through a few times, eyeing
Dark Stalker suspiciously, but didn't try
talking to him.
At one point, around midday, Turtle
watched Clay gather the sky wings to hear
Peril's story of the duel between Queen
Scarlet and Queen Ruby.
Soon they came back through the cave, all
of them with relieved expressions, knowing
that Scarlet was dead, and Ruby was
safely their queen for certain now.
One of them paused not far from Dark
Stalker, and gazed enviously at the
treasure anemone had swept into a messy
pile.
He was the one with a badly scarred face
from the gold winglet.
He had a black leather pouch around his
neck, like most of the students, but no
other accessories, nothing like anemones
confections of sparkles from the sea.
Turtle couldn't remember speaking to
him.
The Skywing always looked as if he was in
a murderous mood.
Hello Flame.
Dark Stalker said politely.
He put a rock down on the scroll he'd
been reading to hold his place.
Stay out of my head.
Flame snarled at him.
With pleasure, said dark stalker.
I know you were poking around in my mind
before.
Flame lashed his tail and glared up at
the night wing.
I felt it.
I hated it.
Yes.
Dark Stalker said thoughtfully.
Indeed.
It's quite dark in there.
What's that supposed to mean?
Flame demanded.
Like, evil dark?
Anemone asked curiously.
Or there's nothing going on inside dark.
Flame hissed at her.
And Dark Stalker gently stepped between
them.
You know, I have an idea, Flame, he
said.
I could fix your face.
This guy Wing Dragonette started back and
touched his venom slash snout, scowling
don't lie to me, he said.
I already asked an animist to do that, and
he said he wouldn't, or couldn't
slithering toadstool worm.
You mean stone mover.
Dog stalker said, with a surprised
expression.
I wonder why he said no.
It wouldn't be that hard.
Or take very much out of him.
Really?
Flame looked even more furious.
He moaned and griped, and acted like it
would kill him.
He said he couldn't cure all the wounded
dragons in Pyria, so why even start
festering rotted lungfish?
Oh, dear. said Dark Stalker, shaking his
head.
Well, I'm sure he has his reasons, but I
could certainly do it.
If you want.
Flame hesitated.
Turtle could see his talons trembling
slightly, although his face was fixed in
a state of permanent rage.
Finally, he said, Why would you do that
for me?
What do you want in return?
Nothing at all.
Dark Stalker caught a deep indigo flower
that was drifting down from one of the
banners overhead and cupped it in his
claws.
He took a step toward Flame, who held his
ground.
I am currently trying to prove to certain
dragons that I'm not the villain they
think I am.
I can be trusted.
I'm here to help others.
So why shouldn't you be one of the ones I
help?
No strings attached, Flame said.
Ha!
I don't buy it.
I have a lot to make up for, Dark Stalker
said.
What's that word?
Oh, I'm atoning.
I need Everyone to see that.
I don't need your pity, and I don't want
to be your experiment, Flame growled.
It's a simple good deed, Flame.
There's no need to be suspicious.
Dark Stalker stopped in front of him.
His head nearly brushing the fire globes
on the ceiling.
Flame stared up at him, as though he was
frozen in place, paralyzed by wanting
something, and not believing he could
truly have it.
I've seen in your mind how badly you need
this.
Just accept it.
Dark Stalker reached out and brushed the
flower across Flame's face, tracing the
scar from one end to the other.
I enchant this flower to heal flame, the
sky wing. without pain, erasing his scars
and returning his face to the way it was
before the accident with a sand wing.
He lifted the flower away, and flame
jerked back.
Turtle watched, awestruck, as flames
scales writhed and rippled over his snout
like snakes, suddenly rising up and
shaking off their skins, Flame let out a
yell, clapped his talons over his eyes
and wrapped his wings around his head.
In the ensuing silence, Dark Stalker
quietly plucked the pedals off the flower
and let them drift down to the stone
floor.
Finally, Flame folded back his wings and
lifted his face toward the light.
Turtles stifled a gasp.
He'd expected it to work, but it was
shocking to see the smooth, unblemished
ruby scales, and the perfect shape of
Flame's face.
The Skywing Dragonette looked years
younger, and infinitely more innocent.
Turtle wondered with a stab of shame
whether he had judged Flame by his
damaged looks, assuming he was a scarier
dragonette than he truly was.
Flames, claws touched his snout.
Brushing over the new scales with
disbelieving care, as though they were
made of the thinnest ice and might
shatter at any moment.
Wow, anemone blurted.
You look totally different.
Dark Stalker, that's amazing.
Flame glanced up at Dark Stalker, then
turned, and bolted from the cave.
Oh, right.
Don't bother saying thank you, Anemone
called after him.
Some dragons, she said to dark stalker
shaking her head.
You know, I offered to cure Starflight's
blindness once, but tsunami said no, my
soul was too valuable.
Whatever, whatever.
She touched her neck band.
But now I can, or you can.
One of us can.
Won't Starflight be excited?
I'm not sure.
Dark Stalker said kindly.
It's a generous idea, but in my visions
he's reluctant to accept a magic cure
from us.
Maybe if we give him a little time to get
used to the idea.
Reluctant?
Why?
Anemone demanded.
We can fix everybody now.
Dog Stalker didn't respond.
His eyes were on a tunnel across the cave
where, a moment later, moon emerged
leading the other 3 night wing students.
Well, this is exciting, said Dark Stalker
with a smile.
I thought a better introduction might be
in order, Moon said.
She glanced at the other night wings
anxiously.
All right, everyone, this is Dark
Stalker.
He promises he's not as bad as all the
stories say he is.
Dark Stalker, this is Mighty Claus, Mind
Reader, and Fearless.
I know Dark Stalker said.
I've been looking forward to meeting you
all face to face.
It seems like the Nightwing tribe has
changed a lot since I was around.
Fearless was the 1st to speak.
Turtle peeked out and saw her claws
nervously picking at the rock below her.
What was it like in your day?
she asked.
Amazing, said Dark Stalker.
We were, without question, the most
powerful and sophisticated tribe.
Our kingdom had a remarkable library, a
huge training arena where we hosted all
the tribes for tournaments, a museum, with
a most beautiful art empirea, and a new
music festival every full moon.
It was glorious.
It was?
said Mindreader wistfully.
I can't believe it's all gone.
Dark Stalker said, shaking his head.
He touched the scroll beside him, as
though all his memories had vanished into
it.
Do you know where we've been living all
these years?
Mighty Claus asked.
Turtle noticed that he was the only one
with a note of hostility in his voice.
I can see it, in your memories, said Dark
Stalker.
The island.
The volcano.
It looks terrible.
It was terrible.
Mighty Klaus said accusingly.
In a place of such darkness, and danger
Dark Stalker mused.
The night wings who are left must have
been very strong to survive.
The dragonettes hesitated, glancing at
one another.
The sound of the rain pouring down
outside filled in the silence.
It sounded like claws running overhead
like the waterfalls in the summer palace
like hurricanes closing in as the waters
rise.
I guess.
Mighty Claus said thoughtfully.
But we live in the rainforest now.
That's much better, mind reader
interjected.
Now we're not starving or sick anymore
and we can breathe.
I'm sure, said Dark Stalker.
Although, now you don't have a queen.
We do, said Moon, we have Queen Glory.
The other 3 nodded.
Mind reader first, Turtle noticed, and
the other 2 more slowly.
Dark Stalker's eyebrows twitched, but he
didn't say anything for a moment.
And I understand no one in the tribe has
powers anymore, he observed.
Were those really real?
Fearless asked.
Could Nightwings really do all those
things, once?
Some of them could, he said.
If they hurts to the right time.
We had mind reading and prophesy classes
for the gifted in my school.
Oh, wow.
Mind reader breathed.
Not just classes on pretending to read
minds and how to make up believable
prophecies.
Dark Stalker chuckled.
No, it was all real.
I wish I could really read minds, she
said sadly.
Do you have any jewelry on you?
Dark Stalker asked.
Um, this?
Mind reader held out her arm to display a
bracelet of green and silver glass beads
strung along a twisted black wire.
Turtle guessed she had made it here in
art class.
Heads up, Moon, Dark Stalker said, sliding
the bracelet off mind reader's arm.
Exciting things about to happen.
Is this a good idea?
Moon said anxiously.
We can't leave this poor dragonette with
a name that's a lie, can we?
He asked.
Dark Stalker held the bracelet between
his claws for a moment, with something
glimmering in his dark eyes.
Finally, he passed it back to
Mindreader.
Wish grunted, he said, smiling again.
What?
Oh, she gasped as the bracelet touched
her scales.
She looked up at him, eyes wide with
wonder.
I can, I can hear what everyone's
thinking.
I really can.
Is this real?
3 moons.
Let's see.
The sea wing princess is thinking I don't
deserve a gift like this.
Moon is worried about whether it'll be
too much for me, hearing everything all
at once.
Mighty Claus and Fearless are both super
jealous.
Ha!
This is amazing.
She did a little jump into the air
fluttering her wings.
Moon's right said Dark Stalker.
It's a lot to handle at first, but moon
can help you if you feel overwhelmed.
Moon can?
said Mighty Claus.
Why?
Dark Stalker.
Moon started.
Have a little faith in your fellow night
wings moon.
Dark Stalker said.
Don't you think it's fair for them to
know that you have mind reading and
prophecy powers?
What?
Fearless cried.
They all looked at Moon as though she had
suddenly sprouted 6 extra heads.
But I was going to tell them, Moon
protested.
I mean, eventually, soon, when I figured
out how.
Well, now we're even for you telling your
friends about Skyfire.
Dark Stalker said cheerfully.
Besides, I promise nobody's going to hate
you.
The way you were so worried everyone
would.
Right, my friends.
I don't hate her, mind reader said, with
a touch of smugness, admiring her
bracelet.
How could you keep something like that
secret?
Fearless demanded.
That's not fair. mighty Klaus cried.
She got to grow up in the rainforest, safe
and fed and happy, and she gets all our
lost powers.
Ooh.
He's thinking, why couldn't it be me?
Mind reader announced gleefully.
All right, genius, anyone can guess that
Fearless snapped at her.
Does your mother know?
She asked Moon.
I'm assuming yes, since lying apparently
runs in your family.
How could I tell anyone?
When I knew you'd react this way?
Moon confronted her.
Exactly the way I expected.
Hey now.
Dark Stalker said.
He reached out with one massive talent
and nudged Fearless back a few paces, away
from Moon.
That's right.
I forgot one little step.
Sorry, Moon.
He turned to Monte Claus and tapped the
miniature diamond stud embedded in the
dragonette's earlobe.
It was so small that for a long time
Turtle had thought it was a tiny silver
scale, but now he could see that it was
an earring.
Tell me, mighty Claus, if you could have
any power.
What would you choose?
Dark Stalker asked.
Dark stalker, Moon said warily.
Shouldn't you be thinking about your
soul?
All taken care of?
Dark Stalker said, waving one of his
wings at her.
Right.
Little princess.
That's right.
Anemone flared her wings and looked
imperious.
So you can quit acting like you know
everything, Moon.
Dark soccer and I are just fine.
Moon gave her a puzzled sideways look.
So, mighty Claus.
Darkstalker's eyes glittered at the young
night wing.
What do you think?
Any power at all.
I guess, prophecy, he said.
I mean, to be different from a mind
reader.
You're thinking too small.
Dark soccer grin with all his teeth.
Don't limit yourself to traditional night
wing powers.
What if you could do anything?
Any power you can imagine?
Oh, Dark Stalker.
Moon said, starting to pace up and down
the cave.
I'm really not sure about this.
Ooh, she's imagining all sorts of
terrible things.
Mind reader reported enthusiastically.
Shouldn't we check with Sonny or Tsunami
or Queen Glory at least?
Moon asked.
Do you think they'd really stop me from
improving these dragons' lives?
Dark Stalker asked.
Look how happy Mind Reader is now.
Yes.
But, Moon trailed off.
But you want all the power for yourself
is that it?
Mari Claus asked, lashing his tail.
You don't like the idea of other dragons
being special too.
Powers like these can be hard to live
with, Moon said fiercely.
I'm just worried for you all.
I'll take you always if you want to give
them up, Mighty Claus suggested.
Me too.
Anemone said.
Ooh, then I'd be just like Dark Stalker.
Moon is sensible to worry.
Dark Stalker said soothingly.
But luckily, I am here to make sure
everything turns out fine.
Mighty Claus, what have you decided?
And me, Fearless interjected.
Am I getting a power too?
Do you have anything to enchant?
Dark soccer asked, looking her up and
down.
I will.
Fearless world and ran out of the cave.
I have one idea.
Mighty Claus said hesitantly.
But it might be stupid.
It's not, said Dark Stalker.
I can see what you're thinking.
It's very creative.
What?
Anemone demanded.
What is it?
I don't get it, said mind reader.
He wants to draw things and then make
them real.
Like, if I draw a sword, then I could
touch it, and it would become a real
sword, Monte Claus said, glowing a little
with excitement.
And if I drew a pond, I could touch it
and it would become a real pond.
Or if I drew a banana, then I could touch
it, and...
And, um, have a real banana to eat.
Oh, that's what he really wants.
Mind reader giggled, and endless supply
of food.
Would have been pretty useful back on the
volcano.
Mighty Claus bristled.
You wouldn't be making fun of me then.
You'd be kissing my claws for a banana.
We don't live on the volcano anymore, mind
reader pointed out.
We live in basically the banana capital
of the universe.
We don't need a magic banana maker.
It's not just for bananas.
Money Klaus cried.
Well, I think it's extremely clever, Dark
Stalker said, and mind reader subsided at
once.
Let me think for a moment.
About how exactly to word the spell.
He tapped his chin pensively for a few
long, silent seconds, and then he touched
mighty Claw's earring again, whispering
under his breath.
There we go, he said.
Did it work?
Mighty Claus asked.
Run to the odd cave and see.
Dark Stalker suggested.
Bring me back a banana.
Mind reader called after him as Mighty
Claus darted away.
Dark stalker.
Why are you doing this?
Moon asked.
She stopped pacing and sat down, with her
tail around her talons.
Turtle wished he were brave enough to
stand next to her, taking strength from
her strength.
He wished she could tell him what to
think about any of this.
The more he watched Dark Stalker, the
more confused he felt.
Because this was a good thing Dark
Stalker was doing, wasn't it?
Giving other dragon's powers.
That's what you want to think.
His conscience whispered.
Our tribe needs help, Moon.
Dark soccer said earnestly.
They've fallen so far.
I want to restore them to the powerful
tribe I remember.
And if I can do that by sharing my gift
why shouldn't I?
Because Are you sure you won't turn
evil?
Moon asked.
And these are huge decisions.
Shouldn't you think about them a little
more?
I have been thinking about them.
Dark Stalker assured her.
I've been thinking nonstop since I woke
up.
And I've checked all the possible
futures.
This is the best path, believe me.
A happy nightwing tribe.
Tullins of power for everyone.
Talons of power?
Moon echoed, her eyes wide.
Like the prophecy, the whole beware
part?
I'm just joking, said Dark Stalker.
Try not to worry so much.
I'm back.
Fearless ran into the room, panting.
I'm here.
I have something.
She thrust out her arm.
A pair of silver and black wires had been
hastily twisted into a rough bracelet
barely visible on her wrist.
She smiled up at Dark Stalker, in a
frighteningly worshipful way.
Super strength, please, she said
breathlessly.
Dark Stalker smiled back at her.
Anything you wish.
He touched her wrist and muttered
something.
When he finished, she turned her talon
over, then spun around and slammed her
tail into a stalagmite.
It instantly crumbled into a cascade of
tiny rocks.
Fearless let out a shriek of delight.
Did you see that?
she cried.
Mind reader toyed with her own bracelet
frowning.
Well, she said, it's cool, I suppose, if
you like that kind of thing, I mean, a
bit obvious, but all right.
Dark Stalker suddenly sat up, lifting his
head, as though he could see monsters
crawling out of the stalactites, he
stared into space for a moment with
faraway eyes.
The other dragons all held their breath
and watched in silence.
Did you sense something?
He said finally, looking down at Moon?
She shook her head.
What was it?
A vision?
More of a premonition.
He said.
His expression was troubled.
And if this was an act, Turtle thought
then Dark Stalker was really good at it
even Turtle felt his anxiety jump a few
notches higher.
Someone's in danger.
Can you feel it?
Moon closed her eyes.
Mind reader saw her do it, and
immediately closed her eyes too, putting
on a deeply pensive look.
Hmm.
Yes, said Mind Reader, nodding.
The princess, who smells like fish, is
thinking maybe she should give herself
some cool powers like ours.
Ha ha, copycat.
Oh, and they're Sonny's mind, coming this
way with a squirrel for dog stalker
wondering what he's found out about clear
sight.
Turtle felt a flash of worry that she'd
hear his mind hiding nearby and give him
away.
But then he remembered the skyfire, which
shielded him from all mind readers.
He felt for his armband with a sigh of
relief.
Only 3 stones left.
The other 3 holes marked the stones he'd
given to winter, Kibley, and Kinkachu.
Would Moon want a stone for herself?
Now that there were 2 other mind readers
around.
Maybe not.
He wasn't sure she'd still be able to
read other minds if she was holding a
Skyfire rock.
It's Stone Mover.
Moon cried suddenly, her eyes flying
open.
She leaped to her feet, wings spread wide
and turned towards Sonny as she entered
the cave.
Sonny, your father, someone's trying to
kill him.
Chapter 7.
There was a sudden rush of wings, like a
1000000 seagulls taking flight at once.
Sonny, dark stalker, and moon dove out
into the storm.
Anemone pivoted in a circle, as though
startled that they'd left without her
then flew after them.
Mind reader and fearless exchanged a
glance, and finally followed as well.
Turtle hurried out from behind the gong
and stood in the cave entrance for a
moment, dithering.
It would be hard to sneak along behind
them, but then he wanted to know what was
happening.
On the other talon, it was raining quite
a lot.
But then again, Kibli had asked him to
keep an eye on Dart Stalker, so that was
really what he had to do, wasn't it?
He growled softly.
And then he was out in the rain, instantly
drenched, flying through flashes of
lightning.
He chased the dragons around the mountain
to the cave, Stone Mover had chosen to
live in for the rest of his life, like a
petrified hermit crab.
Turtle had never visited the old night
wing animus during his time at Jade
Mountain.
He had a weird, irrational fear that the
dragon would somehow recognize him as a
fellow animus and reveal his secret.
Although if he searched deeper, he'd also
have to admit that he was afraid of
seeing what an animus could become when
he used his magic too much.
He heard Dark Stalker roar, angry and
earth shaking, sending a slide of rocks
clattering down the mountainside.
Turtle wobbled down to the ledge outside
the cave and slid himself into the very
edge of the shadows inside.
He sucked in a sharp breath as he
suddenly realized how close he was to
Dark Stalker's scales, the enormous
dragon filled the mouth of the cave
leaning in toward the others.
His smooth ebony side rose and fell, only
a thin slice of air away from turtle's
nose.
If I touch him, will he notice me then?
Or will he wonder why he can touch
something that he cannot see?
Turtle held himself tensely frozen, wings
pinned to the wall behind him, like
stingrays caught on a sea wing's sharp
claws, from his position, he could just
see a sliver of the cave beyond, stone
movers, gray, fossilized arm, a tangle of
night wing tails, a pool of blood slowly
creeping across the stone floor.
Father, Sonny cried, was crying, had
cried several times over.
The word echoing around the cave.
Who did this?
Moon's voice, then a glimpse of her
teardrop scales as she turned to Dark
Stalker.
You must know.
He went into the tunnels, Dark Stalker
said, pointing, his wings shifting, warm
fire smelling breath past Turtle's face.
Otherwise, I'd chase him down myself.
I'll do it.
Anemone yelped from her spot at
Darkstalker's talons, she seized a loose
prey bone on the floor.
Lead me to Stone Waver's killer.
Anemone, no.
But Sonny was too late.
Anemone's pale blue tail flashed a trail
through the blood, and she was gone.
Why didn't you see this coming?
Moon asked Dark Stalker.
I thought you could see everything, all
the futures.
There are 1000000000s upon 1000000000s of
futures.
Dark Stalker answered.
I'm sorry.
Even I can't study all of them. especially
when something small can set off a sharp
turn.
Sonny, is he still alive?
It seems like I can still hear a glimmer
of life in his mind.
Oh, so can I, Moon gasped.
Um, yeah.
Me too.
Mind reader declared quickly.
Dark Stalker squeezed forward another few
steps, and as he ducked his head, Turtle
could see a slash of dark red beads
dripping across stone mover's neck.
If Stone Mover was still alive.
Turtles healing rock could save him.
This was a wound like Winters, on the
surface, where the enchantment turtle had
crafted so thoughtlessly could actually
help.
But to bring it out now would be
suicidal.
Not only would everyone discover that
Turtle was an animus, but Dark Stalker
would want to know where the rock came
from, who'd enchanted it and how he
didn't know about it.
No, there was no way to help.
Once again, Turtle had to sit on his
claws and do nothing.
He had to stay useless if he wanted to
stay safe.
He's alive, Dark Stalker said firmly.
I can't save him.
He reached up and snapped a stalactite
off the roof with casual, terrifying
strength.
But you shouldn't, should you?
Sonny asked.
He's my family too.
Dog stalker wrapped his front talons
around the spear of rock.
Enchant, this stalactite, to heal the
wounds of any dragon it touches.
He said, in a deep voice.
A little deeper than necessary, Turtle
thought.
A little theatrical, let's be honest.
But it seemed to have the intended effect
on the dragon's watching.
All their eyes followed Dark Stalker's
movements as he reached down and tapped
stone mover lightly on the chest.
A hushed moment passed, and then stone
mover let out a sigh.
The slash of red on his neck, knitted
together, and vanished.
He rolled his head back with a groan of
pain, opened his eyes, and saw Dark
Stalker.
Hello, Dark Soccer said.
You're all right now.
Ooh, are you?
Stone mover croaked in his dust covered
voice.
An ancestor of yours, said Dark Stalker
returned from the dead.
So we have that in common.
My name is Dog Stalker.
No, whispered Stone Mover. his eyes
widening.
Don't be scared.
Moon said quickly.
He's not here to hurt us.
He saved your life, Sonny added.
She rested one of her small talons on
stone mover's petrified shoulder, a tiny
island of gold among all the black scales
in the cave.
With magic, Stone Mover said, sounding
half panicked.
No, you can't.
It's wrong.
My clothes.
They're not mine.
His eyes rolled wildly toward his talons
and Turtle saw the stone cracking all
along his arms, crumbling back to release
the scales underneath.
What do you mean?
Sonny asked.
What's wrong?
These aren't my claws.
Stone mover shrieked.
What are they doing?
Stop them.
Somebody stop them.
Bewildered.
Sonny pounce on one of his front talons.
Dark stalker dropped the stalactite and
gently pinned the other.
Don't panic.
He said.
You've had a shock.
Someone tried to kill you.
But you're safe now.
Your petrified scales are healing, that's
all.
You're not used to being able to feel
your limbs anymore.
In a moment.
All the rock will be gone, and you'll be
back to normal.
Then not mine.
Stone Mover said again, in a low
desperate voice, tension radiated through
his muscles, down his arms to the claws
that twitched and twitched, breaking
free.
No.
No, I gave mine up.
My talons are gone.
These are monsters, crawling out of the
earth, and they will rend the sky and
crush the wings of small dragons, and I
can't let them.
I won't, I won't, I won't let them be
used again.
His voice arose and rose to an agonized
roar.
The head splitting sound, pounded images
of blood, and death, and slashing claws
through Turtle's brain.
Do you trust your talons?
Do you trust them, do you?
Stop him.
Moon shouted to Dark Stalker.
He's trying to use his magic to hurt
himself.
Mind reader had her talons over her ears
and was huddled in a ball on the cave
floor.
Dark stalker took stone mover's head in
his claws and forced the roaring dragon
to meet his gaze.
Calm down, he said. in a voice that shook
the mountain.
Stone mover's voice dropped away.
He stared back at Dark Stalker.
I'm healing you, Dark Stalker said.
That's all.
Don't, Stone Mover whispered.
It's not safe.
You don't have to punish yourself for
being ananimous.
Dark Stalker flicked his tail, frowning.
You're allowed to be whole, to be happy.
I agree with Darkstocker, Turtle
thought.
Is that a bad sign?
I don't want to spend my life in terror
of my powers.
I want to be happy too.
Does that mean I'm in danger of turning
out like Dark Stalker?
Would I rather end up like him?
Or stone mover.
He couldn't imagine willingly fossilizing
himself, but he looked down at his
clenched talons and wondered what he
would do to stop them from hurting
anyone.
Did Stone Mover have flashes of blood and
screaming in his head too, before he cast
his spell?
Stone Mover rolled his eyes toward his
tail, where more rock was crumbling
away.
I can't be free.
He said.
I don't know what I might do.
Cage me again.
Leave me in stone.
It's the only way to be safe.
He means it, Moon said to Dark Stalker.
She edged around the pool of blood to
catch some of the falling pebbles from
the old dragon's wings.
He's terrified of his power, of his own
claws, of any dark magic.
His mind is shredding itself to pieces.
Yeah, and it's giving me the worst
headache.
Mind reader complained.
All this fear.
Dark soccer said with a sigh.
I've seen it before, he brightened.
Maybe I can fix it.
The right spell could take away all his
worry.
No.
Sonny and Stone Mover said at the same
time, looking equally alarmed.
No spells on my brain.
Stone Mover said, his voice rising toward
panic again.
Why not?
Dark soccer asked, with genuine
bewilderment.
If it would make you happier.
He turned to Moon.
Isn't it all right to make other dragons
happier, if you can?
Not if they don't want you to, she said
gently.
But they should want me to, he said.
It makes no sense.
He lifted his wings in a shrug.
They nearly whacked Turtle in the nose.
Fine.
All right.
I'll leave him in his misery.
And put me back.
The way I was, Stone Mover asked. leaning
against the wall and closing his eyes.
Dragons who wallow in their own tragedy.
Dog stalker muttered, so pointless.
He scooped up a talon full of rocks and
crushed it in his claws, then blew the
stone dust all over stone movers' wings
tail, and arms.
A moment later, the cold gray of the cave
began creeping over Stone Movers' scales
again, embedding him into the walls and
floor once more.
There you go.
Dark Stalker said.
May you always be as thoroughly unhappy
as you want to be.
Thank you.
Stone Mover whispered, relief printed all
over his face.
Dark stalker wrinkled its snout at moon
and she shook her head at him.
Turtle wondered if they were
communicating telepathically.
Did Moon really like Dark Stalker?
If she did, did that mean Turtle was
wrong about him?
Healing flame?
Saving stone mover, protecting anemone's
soul, giving powers to the night wings.
Dog Stalker hadn't exactly spent his day
spreading evil and doom.
Am I worrying about nothing?
Sonny wrapped her arms around her
father's neck and hugged him.
Blood from the healed wound smeared her
scales, but she didn't seem to notice.
A few minutes passed in silence, and then
they all heard footsteps coming up
through the tunnels.
Sonny sat up and arranged her wings, as
though she was trying to match an image
of a queen in her head.
I found him, Anemone announced, coming
into the cave.
A dragon edged into the space behind
her.
The sharp edge of the broken prey bone
pressed into the crevice below his jaw
enchanted to threaten him forward.
It was flame, guilt and shame written all
over his new, perfect face.
Sunny stared down at him without
comprehension for a long moment, not
understanding who he was.
Lame, Dark Stalker said at last.
Why would you do this?
Especially when Dark Stalker just healed
your face, said Anemone, I thought you'd
be dancing and flying around.
It's not exactly normal to celebrate by
killing some random old dragon.
She noticed stone mover's eyes opened and
jumped back.
Yikes, and you didn't even do it right.
You guys, the fossil is still alive.
We know, Fearless said.
Dark stalker saved him.
Flame.
Why would you do something like this?
Sonny asked.
He lied to me, Flames said, through
clenched teeth.
He could have healed me, but he chose not
to.
Oh, wow, said mind reader, squinting at
flame.
Moon, are you hearing this too?
This dragon seriously hates everyone.
Stay out of my mind.
Flame shouted at her.
Mind reader jerked back with a yelp.
But you are healed, Sonny said to him
wonderingly.
So why would it matter who did it?
Enough to kill someone for it?
He lied to me, Flame growled. sinking
closer to the floor.
That's an interesting complaint coming
from a dragon with his own secrets, said
Dark Stalker.
He beckoned with one claw, and Flames
leather pouch ripped free and floated
into Dark Stalker's talons.
Give that back.
Flame reward.
But when he tried to leap forward, Anemone
stood in his way, glittering with self
righteousness.
The bone pressed itself harder into his
neck, conjuring a jeweled drop of blood
and flame stopped with a gasp of pain.
Wow, he is so angry, mind reader
reported.
Ooh.
He wants to horribly kill all of us.
Dark Stalker shook the pouch and caught 2
objects as they tumbled out.
Flame's library card and a blue sapphire
shaped like a long, elegant star.
The 3rd dream visitor, sunny gasped.
That's right, said Dark Stalker. holding
it up to catch the light.
This is what I've suspected, since I 1st
heard Moon's prophecy.
Flame is the darkness of dragons.
And he's the stalker of dreams.
Chapter 8.
Beware the darkness of dragons.
Beware the stalker of dreams.
A breath of cold air shivered along
turtles' wings.
Was dark stalker right?
Was one of the dangers of the prophecy
seething under their noses this whole
time?
I'm not any of that, Flame snarled.
What does that tripe even mean?
You must have stolen this from Starflight
on the Nightwing Island?
Sonny said, pointing to the dream
visitor?
But how did you hide it all this time?
While you were injured in everything?
I had help, spat flame.
Idiot help, but that's all I had to work
with.
He's thinking about to dragon with a
weird name.
Ogre, Okra, mused mind reader, who he
also hates, by the way.
Stop sticking your snout in my brain
flame hissed, or I'll slice it off.
I wish I could, flared mind reader.
You're a miserable dragon, and your
thoughts are like nasty boiling tar.
What are we going to do with you?
Sonny asked Flame.
I'll have to tell Queen Ruby what you
did.
But until she sends someone for you, it's
not like we have somewhere to lock you
up.
Really?
What kind of respectable school doesn't
have a dungeon?
Dark Stalker asked.
Fearless and mind reader turned toward
him with wide eyes, and he chuckled, I'm
just kidding.
Sonny, I can take care of this for you.
How, exactly?
She asked warily.
Dark Stalker took Flame's library card
and touched it to one of Flame's front
talons, instantly it flipped over and
outward, transforming into an iron band
that clamped around Flame's forearm, a
thick metal chain sprouted from the band
like a coiling snake.
It plunged into the rock, trapping flame
in place.
Flame roared his fury, but he couldn't
move, couldn't reach any of the throats
he was clawing for.
There.
Dark Stalker said.
He's not going anywhere now.
He backed out of the cave.
Turtle pressed himself tightly against
the wall, closing his eyes, as the
massive ebony scales rippled by.
Giant claws scraped the stone perilously
close to his own pitifully small webbed
talons.
Sunny circled flame.
Her expression uncertain, until she
noticed that she was leaving tracks of
stone mover's blood across the floor.
With a sigh, she bowed her head and
slipped away into the tunnels.
That was awesome.
Anemone danced out of the cave and spread
her wings.
Looking up at Dark Stalker, where he
stood in the rain.
If she noticed turtle as she went by him
she didn't acknowledge his presence.
Let's solve some more mysteries.
Catch some more bad guys, be even more
awesome.
You should have an early night.
Dark Stalker said to her.
He swept his wings toward mind reader and
fearless, who were huddled under the cave
overhang, looking severely displeased
about the weather.
You all should, because tomorrow, we're
going to the rainforest.
And it's a long flight.
Moon.
He called as she slipped out of the
cave.
Come flying with me.
She hesitated.
Kibley and I told Starflight we'd help
him clean up the library and look for
more scrolls for you.
Maybe later.
Of course, Dark Stalker said.
No problem.
He watched her fly away.
Raindrops slithering down his sides.
His expression reminded Turtle of someone
but he couldn't think who.
I'll go flying with you, Anemone
chirped.
I'm way more interesting than Moon, and
I'm not tired.
You will be tomorrow, Dark Stalker said
and we're not stopping on the way to the
rainforest.
Thank you, princess, but I'll be fine by
myself tonight.
He spread his wings, and Turtle realized
who Dark Stalker had reminded him of.
The soldiers in the garden of the wounded
the ones who couldn't swim anymore, who'd
lost a tail or a limb, or a wing, and
didn't quite know yet how to go on living
without them.
That was the expression he'd glimpsed
very briefly, on Dark Stalker's face.
The enormous night wing turned and flew
away, higher and higher into the gray
glowering clouds, until the storm seemed
to melt into his scales, and swallow him
whole.
Turtle thought about following him, but
his wings felt coated in thick sand.
He hadn't slept all night, and he'd spent
the entire day before, flying across the
continent as fast as he could.
His fear of dark stalker had kept him
awake for most of the day, but now his
eyes were desperate for sleep.
He hasn't done anything terrible yet.
He told himself, as he flew back to the
entrance hall.
And I have to sleep sometime.
He dragged his tail through the tunnels.
I can't watch him every 2nd of his life
forever.
He paused in the doorway to his own
sleeping cave.
It was so empty, like a giant hollowed
out oyster shell.
The walls rose around him, there, and
scraped of all life.
In the kingdom of the sea, the sons of
Queen Coral were almost always together.
They shared rooms, classes, prey.
They filled the palaces with their
wrestling matches and shouting games.
So when one of them did something wrong.
And if someone was paying attention to
them long enough to notice, their
punishment was almost always isolation.
Sometimes it was imposed from above, by
someone like their Uncle Shark, or Cousin
Moray.
Sometimes it came from within.
When the brothers banded together to
exile one of their own.
Turtle's punishment for failing his
father was chosen and carried out by his
own brothers.
The older ones caught wind of the news
that Gil was furious about something, and
they finally pried the whole story out of
octopus and cerulean.
Turtle was shut out completely for a
month.
Nobody spoke to him.
He was left to sleep in an empty room, and
his brothers all behaved as though he
didn't exist.
Turtle had felt his sense of dragonhood
drifting away, dissolving into the ocean
like a mist of ink.
If no one could see you.
Were you real?
If no one spoke to you, how long could
you go on existing before disappearing
completely?
Which was why he'd finally used his magic
on them.
An enchanted seagull egg cracked into
their fish stew one night, and
forgiveness was suddenly his.
But it left him with an unshakable sense
of doubt.
Would they ever have forgiven him on
their own?
Or would he have been alone forever?
He knew he hadn't earned it.
This beguiled friendliness, this false
tide of mercy that had washed away his
sins.
Empty caves always reminded him of that
feeling. 1st a loneliness, and then the
guilt.
He'd had trouble sleeping in his school
cave, ever since his clawmade umber had
run away with Sora.
Umber had all the warmth and energy that
Turtle didn't have, and as a mudwing, he
needed brothers and sisters around him
too.
From the 1st night, they had dragged
their reed mats together and slept back
to back, feeling as if the world was
really still there, as long as there were
other scales close by.
Umber had felt like a new brother right
away.
Turtle missed him.
He glanced along the hall, then slipped
quietly down to Kibley and Winter's
room.
It looked a lot bigger without Winter's
scavenger cage taking up half the space.
Winter was tinkering with a new wire
construction, muttering, while Kibley sat
curled on a ledge, surrounded by scrolls
a pensive look in his black eyes.
Hey, turtle said, poking his head
inside.
Can I sleep in here tonight?
Kibley snapped back to the world
immediately?
Of course.
He jumped off the ledge and hurried over
to Turtle.
Oh, hello, yes, there is another dragon
in here, Winter observed.
I wonder if he has an opinion about extra
snoring in his sleeping cave.
What's happened?
Kibli asked Turtle, ignoring his claw
mate.
What have you seen?
Not much, Turtle said.
Dark Stalker's been really quiet all
day.
He read a bunch of scrolls, fixed flames
face, made talismans to protect his soul
and anemones, and then gave powers to the
night wing students.
And then Flame tried to kill Stone Mover
and, Wait, whoa, said Kibley.
That doesn't sound like not much.
Start from the beginning.
So Turtle told him and Winter as much as
he could about Dark Stalker's activities
that day.
Both dragons looked horrified when they
heard what happened to Stone Mover, but
winter seemed even more horrified by the
news that Dark Stalker was handing out
superpowers to the night wings.
Winter threw his silver blue wings up in
the air.
We only just found out that those powers
were fake, and now they're real again?
You don't have to worry, though.
Turtle reminded him, you still have the
sky fire, so no one can read your mind.
I can be a little worried about super
strength, Winter growled.
And whatever that other one can do.
Make bananas, Kibley filled in.
Absolutely terrifying.
Run for your life.
Winter narrowed his eyes at his
clawmate.
So what is Dark Stalker up to?
Kibley said thoughtfully.
What does he want?
Seems obvious to those of us whose brains
work.
Winter snapped at him.
He wants to make friends and help
dragons.
That is what it looks like said Turtle.
It's really confusing.
He's only done good things all day.
As far as we can see, Kibley pointed
out.
We don't know what he might be doing in
secret, that being the entire point of
secrecy.
Why do you have to be so suspicious?
Winter flared.
Dark Stalker is the one who saved Stone
Mover.
He's a good dragon with a good heart.
Also that, said Kibley.
Does that sound like our winter at all?
Remember yesterday, when he was yelling
at Moon about how you could never trust
Dark Stalker?
Wouldn't he normally be more suspicious
than anyone else?
I've changed and grown, Winter
protested.
I'm a much more open-minded dragon since
my parents decided to sacrifice my life
in exchange for my brother's place on a
wall.
I'm sure you are a winter, but still
Kimberly spread his front talons.
Listen, I'm just picturing myself as a
dark stalker, right?
So I pop out of a mountain, and yikes
here's a fierce, smart, excessively shiny
ice wing print, with an ego the size of
an iceberg, and a 1000000 potential great
futures.
I'm pretty sure I'd think, hmm, that
dragon could be a serious threat.
And then I'd think, 1st thing I'd better
do is neutralize you.
I'm just wondering if that's what he
did.
Winter fluffed his wings, as though he
wasn't sure whether to be flattered or
offended.
Well, stop wondering.
I would know if I was under a spell.
Right.
Of course, said Kibley.
With your magic ice wing brain.
How exactly would you know, Lord Genius?
I don't have to stay and listen to this
Winter said, flouncing out of the cave.
Kibley poked his head out the door to
watch until winter was gone, then came
back inside and sat down in front of
Turtle with a rueful expression.
I have a really bad feeling that he's
gone to tell Dark Stalker about this
conversation.
He can't tell him about me, though, said
Turtle, or if he does, Dark Stalker won't
hear it.
My enchantment hides me completely from
him.
I hope, I hope, I hope, I hope.
If I did it right, which seems unlikely
knowing me.
That's clever, said Kibley.
How did you think of that?
I used this brainstorming method called
pure terror, turtle admitted.
It wasn't so much clever as deeply
cowardly.
How does your soul feel?
Like it's still there?
Turtle said with a shrug.
He wasn't going to talk about the flashes
of screaming chameleon in his head, or
the way his heart sped up when he thought
about how he'd do the same thing again to
anyone else who hurt Kinkachu.
Would you be willing to do a couple more
spells?
Kibley asked.
If I had any powers of my own, I wouldn't
ask.
Oh, said Turtle.
I mean, yes, I suppose so.
The problem is, I don't know what.
I've been thinking about it all day.
I should be able to do something useful
shouldn't I?
If I can just figure out the exact right
thing.
Peril wanted me to kill Dark Stalker.
But I don't think that's possible.
And I'm just, not the kind of dragon who
kills other dragons.
I don't want to be.
The flashes again.
The enchanted scroll case smashing into
chameleon's face, the blood flying, the
power tingling in turtle's claws, the
power to punish those who deserved
punishing, the power to cause violence
with a twitch of one talon.
No.
No, no, no, that's not me.
Plus, what if he actually is good?
He hurried on, pushing the images away.
Winter is not the only one who thinks
so.
Peril does, and I think Moon does too.
Then it would be really wrong to kill
him.
So then I wondered if I should do
something to protect anemone from him
right?
Just in case.
But I don't want to do anything he might
notice, you know?
That's the most important thing.
I don't want him to suspect, there's
another animus out here, just in case
he's evil.
I don't want him to have any clues that I
exist.
He shifted his tail, thinking of all the
heroes his mother had ever written about
and how none of them would have ever said
anything like that.
I understand, said Kibley.
He took a deep breath.
This is something small.
I was hoping you could tell me if there's
a spell on me.
On you?
Turtle said, startled.
Remember that little fight I just had
with the winter.
Kibley said wryly.
Applies to me too.
The thing that bothers me is, I like Dark
Stalker.
He's funny and charming, and he does seem
helpful.
Andy acts like I'm an important, valuable
dragon.
Why aren't I more suspicious?
I can think logically of all these doubts
and worries, but none of them seem to
change the way I feel, and that makes me
crazy, because I've always trusted my
mind to figure things out for me when my
gut is wrong.
All right, said Turtle.
But the spell might not be on you.
It might be on something else, like the
earring Dark Stalker is wearing, and it
might apply to everyone around him.
Kibli frowned.
I hadn't thought of that.
He tapped his claws.
Then what else can we do?
Could you?
He hesitated.
You probably wouldn't want to do this.
What?
Kibli traced to crack in the cave wall
with one of his claws.
Could.
Could you turn me into an animus dragon
too?
Turtle's stomach gave a guilty lurch.
I shouldn't, he said.
You wouldn't want that.
You think you do, but you really don't.
I'd be careful, Kibley insisted.
I'd protect my soul 1st thing, I
promise.
For my very 1st spell.
I'd enchant something to make sure my
soul was always good.
Or that I always made the kind and right
choice that helped the most dragons.
Doesn't that make sense?
He looked down at his claws.
That's what I would have done, with Dark
Stalker scroll too, in case you were
wondering.
Toto remembered the fight Winter and
Kibley had had over who could keep dark
stalkers scroll and use it for
themselves.
It had scared him, but not as much as
Dark Stalker did.
What would the world look like if either
Winter or Kibling now had all this power
instead?
I believe you, he said, but I still don't
think it's a good idea.
Making him an animus would put Kibli in
danger in too many ways.
Turtle would always feel responsible for
whatever happened to him.
Sure, that's all right.
Kibley said quickly.
Sorry I asked.
I'd probably feel weird about making more
animous dragons if I were one too.
It's not turtle started.
I mean, it's not you.
I'm not trying to.
Don't worry about it, Kibley said
fiddling with his earring.
Maybe something else would make more
sense anyway.
Can you make me immune to anima spells?
It was strange to be discussing his power
openly with another dragon.
Strange to be taking someone's advice, and
to know that the other dragon would never
be able to stop wanting things from him
even if it was a friend, like Kibley.
All anima spells.
Ask Turtle.
Are you sure?
I mean, some spells are good, aren't
they?
Like my healing rock, or the dream
visitors?
Being immune means those wouldn't work on
you anymore.
And if you're completely immune, then an
animus couldn't even change you back if
you changed your mind.
That's true, said Kibley.
What if you just made me immune to dark
stalker spells then?
Don't you think he'd notice?
Turtle fretted.
If he suddenly couldn't control you?
Or he tried to cast a spell and you
didn't react.
He'd get really suspicious, wouldn't he?
I'll take that risk, Kibble said.
He tapped his claws against the floor in
a nervous drumbeat rhythm.
As long as he can't use magic against
me.
I can handle anything else he does.
Oh, Turtle said, feeling like even more
of an inch worm.
I meant, yes, of course, suspicious of
you too, but then he'd know it's a spell
and that could lead him to me.
Which, I guess I'm not sure I can handle
anything else he does.
Kibli picked up a scroll that had rolled
across the cavern and tucked it back into
one of the racks by the door.
You are some kind of worrying expert
aren't you?
Yes, Turtle said, his wings drooping.
I'm sorry.
I like to think through everything as
much as possible before making any big
decisions.
That's all right, Kibli reassured him.
It's smart.
As long as you can also make decisions
even when there's not enough time to
think about them.
Turtle didn't like that idea.
It gave him a scrunching feeling in his
chest.
Listen, turtle, it's your magic.
You're the boss of whether you want to
use it.
But I look at winter and I think, that is
not the normal behavior of her majesty
Queen Glacier's nephew.
And then I think, what about me?
What if I'm acting like a hallucinating
sun baked lizard?
And I have no idea.
You seem normal to me, Turtle said.
Does that help?
Kibli shrugged and turned away, rolling
up another scroll.
I need to know my mind is my own.
That's all.
It's all I have.
No superpowers.
No fire scales, no royal family.
Just me and my brain, if it's working.
I am the lowest of cowards.
How can I say no to the one dragon who's
still willing to think twice about Dark
Stalker?
To my friend who needs protection.
I'll do it, Turtle said.
Of course I will.
Immune to dark stalker spells.
That's what you want?
Really?
Kibley said, his face alight.
Yes.
That would be amazing.
Here, enchant my earring.
He took it off and dropped the small gold
and amber earring into Turtle's palm.
Do you know what you're going to say?
Want me to write down some ideas?
He seized a scroll in a pot of ink before
Turtle could answer, and started
scribbling on a blank corner.
If this works, he went on, we could do a
spell like this for winter too, couldn't
we?
Sure.
Turtle said uncomfortably.
Here I go again, helping my friends, which
could mean getting noticed, which will
surely lead to getting caught and slowly
dismembered by a giant nightmare dragon
from the past.
There weren't any stories in the scrolls
like this.
He didn't know quite what role Kibley saw
Turtle playing.
Helpful Wizard.
Those often died by the end too, or maybe
in Kibley's story, Turtle was the
enchanted fish, who granted 3 wishes if
you caught him.
You've got 2 left, Kibley.
Turtle thought wryly.
Then I think I can turn your nose into a
sausage and escape back into the sea.
Wait.
Kibley said, lifting his ink stained claw
from the scroll.
Have you made something to protect your
soul yet?
Um...
No, Turtle said.
I mean, I think it's fine.
You should do that first, Kibley said.
He started absent-mindedly drawing a
series of concentric circles around the
words he'd written on the scroll.
Something like what dark stalker and
anemone have.
That's more important than this.
Let's do this first, Turtle said, reaching
for the scroll. since it's all ready to
go.
It could take me all night to decide how
to do the soul spell.
He tried to return Kibley's grin.
If you're sure, Kibley said, and you're
feeling totally nonviolent.
Turtle read the words carefully a few
times, then focused on the small amber
teardrop in his palm, glowing like
sunlight against the dark green.
Enchant this earring to make the wearer
immune to any spell, dark stalker has
cast, or will cast, whether past, present
or future.
Kibli inspected the earring like a poorly
drawn map, then picked it up between 2
claws to squint at it.
I thought it would get all sparkly or
something, he said.
See if it makes you feel any different.
Turtle suggested.
The sand wing slipped it back through the
hole in his ear and blinked a few times.
Huh, he said.
I think so.
You think so?
Turtle echoed, somewhat disappointed.
If he was going to use his magic, he
wanted it to make a big, obvious, cool
helpful difference.
Kibley started pacing, tipping his head
from side to side, as though he was
resettling everything inside his skull.
Let's see.
I still think dark soccer is funny and
charming, but I definitely feel more
anxious about that.
There was this calm trusting feeling I
had before, and that's vanished.
Could be a coincidence, Turtle observed.
Like, all psychological?
No.
Kibley stopped in front of him and met
Turtle's eyes.
I feel like my mind and my instincts are
linked up again, which is really
important to me.
Thank you.
Hmm, Turtle said.
This didn't seem like a particularly
useful use of his magic, honestly.
He guessed Kibley hadn't been under a
spell at all.
Dark soccer was charming and convincing
enough to win everyone over without
magic.
I can help you figure out your soul spell
Kibley offered.
I know how I'd phrase mine, if I could
protect my soul with magic.
You've thought about it that much?
asked Turtle.
When have you ever had to worry about
your soul?
Aren't you one of those naturally heroic
dragons?
Kibli let out a startled laugh.
No way, he said.
I grew up in the scorpion den, remember?
I was stealing before I could fly.
My mother was an assassin, who tried to
teach me garroting and poisons instead of
reading and writing.
I've done lots of bad things.
And the problem is, I know I do more if
it was for, for, um, Queen Thorn.
I guess I could make you a soul spell
too.
Turtle offered.
Trying to hide is reluctance.
What was wrong with him?
Dark Stalker was giving out powers all
over the place, helping other dragons he
barely knew.
Why couldn't Turtle be equally willing to
share with his closest friends?
Was it just that he was afraid of being
exposed?
Or was he worried about how the magic
might affect his friends?
Thanks.
Kibley said, pinning down the scroll he'd
been riding on.
But let's make sure yours is safe first.
Maybe that's it.
Turtle thought anxiously.
Maybe my soul isn't as fine as I think it
is.
Maybe using my magic has made me selfish
and a terrible friend.
Kibley blew a small flame on the corner
where he'd written the 1st spell.
As it burned away, he checked the other
side of the scroll and made a face.
I probably shouldn't have used my history
reading for this, he said.
Well, too late now.
It was really boring anyway.
All right.
One soul spell coming right.
A sudden thud from above shook the
caves.
Kibli and Turtle looked up.
Then at each other as more thuds followed
and then the scraping of scales and claws
against rock echoed down the tunnels.
What is?
Kibley started toward the door, but
before he could get there, Black scales
blotted out the fire globes, and dark
stalker was squeezing his head and
shoulders through the narrow space to
peer into Kibley's room.
Turtles scramble to the back wall as far
away as he could get.
Why is he here?
It took all his willpower not to close
his eyes and curl up completely.
He stood perfectly still, as dark
stalker's sharp gaze scoured the cave.
That looks uncomfortable.
Kibley said to Dark Stalker, in a
friendly voice, I can't believe you
squashed yourself into our tunnels.
Not a problem.
Dark Stalker said, a bit breathlessly.
I'm surprisingly squishy.
He grinned at Kibley, but there was
something a little forced about his
smile.
This is your cave.
I thought it might be anemones.
What were you just doing in here?
Looking at scrolls?
Kibley said, waving at the ripples of
paper that covered his sleeping ledge
trying to figure out if I should bother
studying, accidentally setting history on
fire.
The usual?
He waved at the thin trail of smoke that
was still rising from the scroll on the
floor.
Dark stalkers studied each outcropping
each shadow with such slicing intensity
that Turtle was sure he'd be seen, and
not just seen, but peeled and flayed from
horns to tail by those searching eyes.
Is something wrong?
Kibli asked.
Was anemone in here a moment ago.
Dark Stalker asked.
No, Kibley said cautiously, I haven't
seen her.
Oh, you sure?
Dark Stalker demanded.
Or maybe passing by.
She might have been talking to herself, or
doing something unusual.
A lightning bolt of fear scorched through
turtle's body.
The spell on Kibley's earring.
Dark stalker showing up only moments
later asking about anemone.
He was looking for the source of a
spell.
Somehow, he knew magic had happened here
and he came immediately to find out what
anemone was up to.
Dark stalkers given himself the power to
sense animus magic.
Chapter 9.
If Dark Stalker can tell when an animus
casts a spell, Turtle realized, his heart
floundering wildly around in his chest
then I can never use my magic again.
Turtle couldn't tell from Kibley's
expression, whether he'd figured it out
as well.
But then Kibley said, oh, anemone.
Yeah.
She might have gone by a little while
ago.
I'm not totally sure.
And Turtle knew that he must have made
the same connections.
Interesting.
Dark Stalker mused.
If you see her.
Please tell her I wish to speak with her
as soon as possible.
Sure. said Kibley.
You bet.
I'll do that.
Dog Stalker gave him another appraising
look.
Kibli, he said.
Please order that scroll to roll itself
up.
Kibley laughed.
Don't you think I've spent my whole life
hoping magic would suddenly pop out of my
claws, he said.
Hey, scroll.
Roll yourself up.
The scroll lay there, inert, and
uninteresting.
Khibli shrugged at Dark Stalker.
Disappointed again.
I think that's for the best, Dark Stalker
said, smiling at him a bit more
genuinely.
With your mind, you'd be a very
formidable animus.
He backed out of the cave.
See you in the morning.
You too.
Kibley answered.
Dark Stalker disappeared down the hall
with a sound of scraping scales jittering
through the walls behind him.
He knew.
Turtle whispered.
Not because Dark Stalker might hear him
but because his voice didn't quite seem
to be working the way it should.
He knows when someone is using animus
magic.
He must have enchanted something to warn
him.
Kibli waited until the vibrations of Dark
Stalker's passage had faded away.
Lucky you cast your hiding spell before
he did that.
Yes.
Turtle said fervently.
You're also lucky he didn't cast the
enchantment to tell him exactly what the
spell was.
Kibley mused.
That's what I would have done.
But he didn't act like he knew what we
did.
Turtle couldn't speak for a moment.
He was so appalled.
He'd come so close to getting caught.
In a way he hadn't even imagined worrying
about what other spells did Dark Stalker
have in place that might tangle him up?
Now I can't use my magic anymore.
He finally managed to say, or else he'll
figure out I'm out here, hiding from
him.
His spell seems to be location based
Kibley pointed out.
Maybe if you were standing near anemone
or stone mover when you cast it.
He'd think it came from one of them.
Maybe.
But then wouldn't he ask them what spell
they just cast?
And if they say they didn't use their
magic, what then?
Would he think they're lying?
I don't want him to think anemone is
secretly using her magic, maybe against
him.
He worried the edge of a wing between his
claws.
I don't want to get her in trouble.
I don't want him to blame her for what
I'm doing.
That's true, said Kibley.
Yeah, that could be bad.
Turtle groaned, lying down and covering
his head with his wings.
Look, I know it's terrible, but it's
smart too, said Kibley.
If you got trapped underground by an
animus spell.
Wouldn't you want to keep a pretty close
eye on any new spells after you got out?
He's not going to let himself be fooled
again.
I'm sorry you didn't get to cast a spell
to protect your soul, though.
I'm going home.
Turtle said, leaping up and whirling
toward the door.
I'm going back to the kingdom of the sea
to hide in the deep palace.
He can't follow me there.
Unless he can.
He could enchant something to let him
breathe underwater, or something to make
the entire ocean evaporate.
He could do anything.
Moons above stop panicking.
Kibli jumped in Turtle's way.
It's not the end of the world.
This doesn't prove he's evil.
All we know for sure is he's protecting
himself.
So we keep watching him, like you have
been.
I can't, Turtle said.
He's going to the rainforest tomorrow
with the other night wings.
All the night wings?
Kibley asked, including Moon?
I don't know.
Turtle answered.
I think so.
Kibli thought for a moment, drumming his
claws again.
I don't have a good excuse to go along
with them, he said.
It'll have to be you.
Me?
Turtles said, startled.
You mean follow him to the rainforest?
So we can see what he does next, Kibley
said.
I can watch things here.
You know, keep an eye out for any thunder
and ice coming to destroy the school.
Then we'll report back to each other and
see what we think.
If only we had a dream visitor too.
So we can send each other messages.
Maybe Sonny would let me use hers.
Oh, Turtle realized.
I'm not his enchanted fish.
He thinks we're on some kind of detective
team story, solving crimes together
investigating strange behavior.
Or maybe I'm his sidekick.
But the sidekick doesn't get sent on the
crazy, dangerous mission alone.
Does he?
He was dangerously tempted by this
vision.
In detective stories, it was all right
for one of the partners to be incompetent
and unreliable, because the other one
would make up for it.
In that kind of story, Turtle's character
wouldn't have to make all the decisions.
No one would be waiting for him to save
the day.
That was the kind of story he might
actually survive.
I might have something we could use.
He said hesitantly.
He checked and triple checked, that Dark
Stalker was long gone from the hallways
then led Kibley back to his own lonely
cave.
Tucked under his woven reed sleeping mat
was the small satchel of belongings he'd
brought to the school.
A significantly lighter burden than
anemones sparkle extravaganza.
Turtle tugged it out and shook the
contents onto the floor.
A broken piece of coral.
A pair of small cracked writing slates
with a slate pencil.
Three pieces of curved wood that slotted
together to form a weathered food stained
bowl.
Kibli regarded the tiny pile with an
extremely polite expression.
Well, he said, honestly, I've seen
weirder treasure in the Scorpion den.
Turtle checked the corridor again.
These are the things I've animus
touched.
He whispered.
Oh, Kibley said, his eyes alight.
What do they do?
Protect your loved ones from harm?
Smite your enemies, make everybody love
you?
Er.
No.
Turtle said awkwardly.
He touched the coral.
This one helps me find things I've lost.
He assembled the bowl and tipped it
toward Kibley.
This doubles the amount of food you put
in it.
I just drop it in and say, twice as much
please.
Then instead of 2 muscles, I'd have
four.
Or instead of a ladleful of clam soup, I
have twice that amount.
That kind of thing.
Kibley tipped his head to the side.
Aren't you a prince?
I thought that meant you'd have plenty of
food.
Well, yes, turtle admitted.
But I was still competing with all my
brothers for it, and I get hungry between
meals and wouldn't feel like hunting, you
know?
All right, said Kibli.
What about those?
The slates clattered like falling
seashells as Turtle picked them up and
passed one to Kibley.
With these, if you write a note on one
it'll appear on the other.
He took the pencil and wrote, hi, Kibley
on the smaller slate.
The message appeared simultaneously in
his looping, scraggly handwriting on the
other slate.
When Turtle erased his slate, the message
stayed in place on Kibley's.
Kibley turned his slate over in his
talons, as though he were hoping to
discover a better spell on the other
side.
Huh, he said.
So we can use these to communicate, I
think, Turtle said, I've never used it
across a really big distance before.
Oh, and it only works one way.
But at least I can send you panicked.
Help.
He's got messages.
It only works one way.
Kibli echoed.
His face seemed to be struggling with a
concept of a world in which amazing magic
could be given to a dragon like turtle
instead of him.
Well, said Turtle.
Yeah.
I mean, I never thought I'd use it with
anyone else.
Kibli, to his credit.
Managed to restrain his reaction to a
slow blink.
Then what in the world did you use this
for?
It's a little embarrassing.
Turtle admitted.
More embarrassing than a bowl that
doubles your royal meals, said Kibley's
expression.
I used to think I wanted to be a writer
Turtle said.
So sometimes, when I was out hunting or
training or whatever, I'd have a great
idea, or think of how I wanted to phrase
something, but I'd always forget it by
the time I got home.
With these, I could take notes on the
slate I carried with me, then erase it
quick before my brothers saw it, but the
notes would be there waiting on the other
slate once I got home.
I see.
Kibley said, finally looking
sympathetic.
I had siblings who picked on me too.
Oh, Ryder.
So fancy scales.
Oh, I gave that up a long time ago.
Turtle shook his head.
I wasn't any good anyway.
He nudged the other items.
I keep these kind of for sentimental
value.
I don't use them very much, since I don't
want anyone to notice me using them.
Sure, Kibley said.
He tipped his slate up to the light.
But this is a great idea.
I'll hang on to this one, and you can
send me notes on what Dark Stalker is
doing, or anytime you need me.
Or if moon needs me, or anyone.
I mean, hypothetically moon, but anyone.
I'll come flying.
All right.
Turtle nodded.
It made him a little nervous to let half
of one of his animus touched objects out
of his sight.
What if it fell into the wrong claws?
On the other talent, it was reassuring to
have someone he could call for help.
I guess I just agreed to follow Dark
Stalker to the rainforest.
He realized.
A clatter of talons came from the hallway
followed by a whooshing sound, a yelp of
fury, and the distinct smell of something
burning.
Think I can guess who that is.
Kibley said with a grin.
Turtle peeked out the door and found
peril, jumping around trying to stomp out
a small fire, except every time she
touched it, the flames got higher.
A few sleepy faces peered out from their
caves, and immediately withdrew when they
saw her.
Eck, she yelped.
Stop.
Bucket of gizzards.
Go out already.
Back, back, back.
Kibley said, hurrying over and flapping
her away with his wings.
I got it.
He pulled one of the message chalkboards
off the wall and smothered the fire, then
trampled out the last few glowing sparks
as they tried to scuttle away.
What kind of jerk leaves scrolls lying
around in the hallway where anyone could
set them on fire?
Peril demanded?
Someone is trying to pick a fight with
me.
Is that it?
Um.
That was my homework.
Mumbled a rain wing nervously from the
nearest doorway.
Oh, Peril said.
She drew her wings back in, eyeing the
hapless dragonette, who was hat for her
size, and a nervous fizzy green color.
Um, she shot a glance at Turtle of the
there's a right thing to say here, isn't
there?
Variety.
Well, next time, keep your mess in your
own cave, all right, she said.
With what Turtle knew was about as much
gentleness as she could muster.
So sorry, stammered the rain wing.
Turtle cleared his throat.
I'm sure peril is sorry too, he offered.
She tilted her head at him.
For burning up this dragon's homework
which he probably worked very hard on.
Turtle tipped his head at the
dragonette.
Uh, okay.
Sure.
Perl said, nodding vigorously.
I'm sorry your scroll got under my claws
and met a fiery end.
She said to the rain wing.
On the plus side.
At least it was a scroll and not say, your
tail.
He turned an even paler shade of green
and vanished into his cave.
Good idea, she called after him.
You shouldn't leave tail lying around the
hallways either.
That's our peril.
Turtles said to Kibley, spreading a
little terror before bedtime.
Was I?
She said.
Humph.
I thought that was a very nice apology
myself.
Turtle liked the dragon he was when he
was with Parel, although he hadn't quite
figured out how their stories fit
together.
He might be her sidekick, although she
wasn't exactly a normal hero, or he might
be her voice of reason, like the dragon
assigned to take care of a mad prophet or
something.
The closest parallel he could think of
though, was this scroll he'd once read
about a dragonette who'd been lost and
raised by a pack of orcas.
So when she returned to her tribe, she
had to be taught everything about
language and relationships and how to
interact with other dragons, and
occasionally she would have furious fits
and bite someone.
With peril, he sometimes felt like that
wild dragon's foster brother, a minor
character.
But one of the few willing to risk
hanging out with her.
He was pretty sure they were friends
though, which was crazy.
Never in a 1000000 years would he have
guessed that he might end up friends with
the sky wing queen's deadliest weapon.
She followed him and Kibley back into a
sleeping cave, where he hurriedly scooted
his sleeping mat to the far end of the
room, away from peril.
He could move it to Kibley and Winter's
cave later.
He packed the smaller slate, the slate
pencil, and the coral into his pouch to
take with him to the rainforest.
The pieces of the bowl were too big to
fit, so he repacked them in his satchel
and hid it under umbers sleeping mat.
How was your meeting with Clay?
Kibley asked Parel.
Fine, she blurted.
Fine, normal, great.
Weird.
Totally fine.
Why?
What did you hear?
Nothing at all. he is shorter.
Just wondering.
Right, she said.
He was very pleased to hear about Queen.
About Scarlet.
She paused, looking like she'd swallowed
an exploding cactus for a moment.
There was hugging.
She finally burst out.
I mean, he gave me a hug.
No big deal.
Normal stuff, I'm sure.
Dragons probably hug you guys all the
time.
Oh, peril.
Turtle kind of wished he could hug her, to
let her know he understood.
Clay likes you too.
Kibley said to Parel.
Really?
Peril glowed like molten glass.
He does?
How do you know?
I can tell.
He just doesn't quite know what to do
about it yet.
Kibley said.
Give him some time to figure it out.
Like...
Lots and lots and lots of time.
I have lots and lots of time.
Peril said, exhaling.
That's totally all right with me.
She beamed at Turtle.
Kibli thinks Clay likes me, she said, in
a loud whisper.
I heard.
Turtle smiled back at her.
I was a little worried he'd hate me after
I burned the magic scroll and released a
giant bad guy.
Peril admitted.
But I guess Dark Stalkers, not bad.
So everything's all right?
She squinted at the items turtle was
packing.
What are you doing?
I'm going to follow Dark Stalker to the
rainforest tomorrow, Turtle said.
Just to see what happens.
Oh, peril said, her wings drooping.
One of them nearly caught on one of the
scroll racks by the door, and Kibli
quietly dragged it out of her reach.
You're leaving?
Only for a little while, I hope, Turtles
said.
I wish you could come with me.
Peril held out her front talons.
I wish I could too.
But no fire scales in the rainforest.
By order of the queen.
She said haughtily.
I'll miss your boring face though.
She said to Turtle.
Not like a lot.
But I'll miss it a little bit.
You won't miss me at all, he said.
You'll have Clay to hang out with.
True. she said. true, true.
She tried to squash back her smile, but
it kept sneaking out.
I really do wish she could come with me.
Turtle thought.
Her unpredictable, hilarious company was
the only thing that had made him able to
leave Jade Mountain in the 1st place.
He'd been able to think of their
adventure as her quest to find Scarlet, no
pressure on him.
Nothing enormously major he could mess
up.
Nobody expecting anything of him.
Not like tomorrow, when he'd be following
Dark Stalker to the rainforest alone.
Without the option of using his magic
alone.
Powerless.
Useless.
This story couldn't possibly end well.
Part two.
Rise to power.
Chapter 10.
The rainforest was an ocean of leaves
below turtle, tossing and rippling in the
wind, like a dark green sea.
A spray of bright yellow birds flew out
of it, squawking and diving, and looping
back down again to sink beneath the
surface.
But the smell here was nothing like the
ocean.
Wild fruit and monkey droppings, heat and
rich dirt, and roots growing in thick
tangles in place of fish, salt, wide open
air.
I have no idea why you decided to come
Anemone said. sweeping up on turtles
left.
He started, then glanced around at Dark
Stalker, but the large dragon was far in
the lead, scanning the forest below.
Anemone had been so close to him all
morning, the turtle hadn't had a chance
to speak to her or try to convince her
not to come.
I could say the same about you, he
pointed out.
Shouldn't you be in school?
Mother wouldn't want you wandering around
Pyria like this.
I can learn far more from Dark Stalker
than from a crusty old shipwreck like
Webbs, anemone snorted, and mother
doesn't have me on a leash anymore.
I can go wherever I like.
Wasn't Pike worried about you leaving?
Turtle tried.
His pouch thumbed lightly against his
chest as he twisted in the air to keep
anemone in sight.
I'm surprised he didn't insist on coming
with you at least.
Oh, I didn't tell him, she said, tossing
her head.
He was sleeping outside my cave, which he
often does because he's such a weirdo, and
I snack right past him.
Not much of a guard, if that's what he
was trying to do.
Ha ha.
Poor Pike.
Waking up to find the princess had
disappeared on his watch, he'd feel like
such a failure.
Turtle knew what that was like.
But what's your excuse?
Anemone demanded.
I thought you were terrified of Dark
Stalker.
You said he doesn't like you, but he
never even looks at you.
I just... want to see what he does, said
Turtle.
His claws itched to reach for his pouch
to make sure the stick was still there
but he fought back the urge.
In case he does something super evil
anemone teased, pouncing at him.
Turtle flinched away.
You jellyfish.
He's going to rescue his tribe, that's
all.
Queen Glory already rescued his tribe.
Turtle pointed out.
They're not on the volcano anymore.
They're perfectly safe.
Right.
Safe to be the crushed seashells under
the talons of the rain wings.
Anemone rolled her eyes.
Think about it, big brother.
Imagine if mother died, and I was too
spineless to take the throne.
So all the sea wings decided to go live
in the mud kingdom and let Queen Moorhen
bosses around.
Is that any way for a self-respecting
tribe to live?
Turtle noticed Fearless, listening to
them with a scowl on her face, he decided
it might be a good idea to change the
subject.
Did you get in trouble with Dark Stalker
last night?
He asked.
I mean, I heard he was looking for you.
He needed to know what was going on in
Darkstalker's head.
Did he suspect there was another animus
around?
Oh, that was the most ridiculous thing
Anemone said with a laugh.
He asked me if I cast a spell without his
permission.
I said, oh, permission?
Is that how this is?
And he said, without my brilliant advice
then?
I said, I didn't think so, but sometimes
I've used my power accidentally without
noticing.
Like, you'd think an animus would learn
not to yell at our stuff, but sometimes I
forget and do it anyway.
I made a pearl necklace explode that way
once.
Anyway, no, of course I'm not in
trouble.
He knows I'm a princess and can do
whatever I want.
Oh, does he?
Turtle thought.
But he didn't have a chance to respond.
Up ahead.
Dark Stalker shot a burst of flame into
the sky, and beckoned to anemone and the
night wings.
They darted over to him as though he was
the sun, and they all wanted to fall into
it.
Time for our grand entrance.
Dark Stalker announced.
He dove into the canopy, and the others
followed, one by one, turtles sighed and
flapped along behind them.
He wondered what would happen if Anemone
figured out that Dark Stalker couldn't
see or hear Turtle.
She tended to accept that the world
revolved around her, so it would probably
be a while before she noticed.
And then, will I tell her the truth?
He dropped from the hot sun sky down and
down into dappled green light that
reminded him of the summer palace before
it was destroyed.
Long limbed creatures of fur flurried out
along the branches as he maneuvered
carefully between the thick vines and
grasping spider webs.
The trees were interwoven like living
nets, lying in wait for their prey.
Far below them on the rainforest floor
the entire night wing tribe was gathered
in a clearing, looking up.
All around them were grass huts and
ramshackle wooden structures, many of
them only half built.
The scent of crispy boar meat rose from a
fire pit that glowed in the center of the
village, carefully lined with rocks.
Queen Glory stood on a mahogany platform
facing the tribe.
She was the only rain wing present, or at
least visible, and her scales were set in
an intricate, overlapping leaf pattern of
bright green, gold, and black.
Beside her, as close as her shadow, was a
night wing with a worried expression
turtle guest that was death bringer, from
the stories he'd heard about the young
rain wing queen, and her loyal, self
appointed bodyguard.
Glory watched dark stalker descend
without a hint of emotion on her face, nor
even the slightest color change in her
scales.
Turtle wondered if she'd ever been afraid
of anything in her life.
He perched on a branch overhead, where
the tooth shaped leaves matched the dark
green of his gales below.
Dark stalker soared down to land next to
glory, instantly dwarfing her and
Deathbringer.
A muffled gasp rustled through the crowd
of night wings.
Death Bringer sidled a step closer to
glory, but the queen herself neither
flinched nor moved.
Anemone hovered for a moment at Dark
Stalker's shoulder, but there was no room
on the platform for anyone else.
Huffing grumbly, she landed on the ground
close by, then spent several minutes
pointedly scraping all the muddy leaves
out of her little patch of dirt.
Dog stalker, I presume?
said Glory.
She nodded to Moon and the other 3 night
wing dragonettes as they slipped into the
tribe.
Turtle saw each of them find their
parents.
He saw Moon's mother wrap her wings
around her daughter.
He saw a mind reader whispering excitedly
to a tall male night wing, holding out
her bracelet.
I see Sonny used the dream visitor to
tell you we were coming.
Dark Stalker said, even though I asked
her very nicely not to. interesting.
The tribe prefers not to be surprised
Glory said, indicating the sea of black
dragons below them.
But as you can see, despite your
prediction, no one has run away.
They chose to be brave, to stand together
and face you.
That wasn't entirely accurate.
Turtle had seen a few dragons bolt into
the forest as Dark Stalker flew down, but
he didn't blame them, considering Dark
Stalker had been the tribe's worst
nightmare for the last 2000 years.
He was amazed so many of them were able
to hold their ground.
He wondered what Queen Glory had said to
them to give them that strength.
Dark Stalker smiled his dazzling smile.
There's no need to be brave, he said.
I'm no monster.
The history you've been fed is all a pack
of lies.
He opened his talons palm up toward the
tribe, as if revealing all his secrets to
them.
They told you I was evil, that I was
about to do terrible things.
And that I was locked away to protect
you.
None of that is true.
My fellow night wings.
I had a majestic future plan for our
tribe.
Power, and security, and wealth, and
peace for every dragon.
No running, no hiding, no lying or
starving, or living in fear.
But there were dragons who didn't trust
my vision for us.
They feared what our tribe could become.
He swept one wing open in an arc, as
though he were flinging diamond dust over
the entire crowd.
Turtle wondered how much dark stalker had
rehearsed this speech, alone in the dark
deep under layers of rock.
I was betrayed, on the brink of changing
everything.
Dark Stalker took a breath, as if he
could feel daggers stabbing into his
back.
Dragons.
I thought I could trust, trapped me
underground, where I'd been asleep
against my will for the last 2000 years.
Meanwhile, our tribe fell apart.
Lost its power.
Its home.
Its position in Pyria.
And history scrolls were written about me
by deceitful dragons, who feared my
powers.
Am I evil?
No.
Murderous, not even remotely.
Dangerous, not my own tribe, or to my
friends.
His eyes went to moon, and a few other
night wings turned to look at her as
well.
Here's the real truth.
I love our tribe.
Dark Stalker looked alive in a way Turtle
hadn't seen yet.
He looked happy.
The night wings were once the most
powerful, most respected, and creative
tribe in Pyria.
And I can show you the way to become that
tribe again.
He paused, perhaps expecting applause, but
the only sound was the wind in the trees
and a jaguar roar in the distance.
These dragons have been working hard to
build their new home, Glory said, her
calm voice carrying across the clearing
they have security and peace here.
They are smart, fierce, determined, and
full of surprising ideas.
They don't need any help to become a
great tribe.
They already are one.
Now there was a reaction.
A wrestling as several night wings stood
up straighter, tipped their wings back
lifted their chins.
I'm sure they are, said Dark Stalker.
But I know what they could be.
I can see the shining future ahead, if
everyone follows me.
Follows you.
Death bringer jumped in.
Glory gave him a quelling look, but he
barreled on.
Follows you where?
Back to our old kingdom, of course, said
Dark Stalker.
He gazed down at glory, a slow smile
spreading across his face.
Queen glory, he said, and there was a
lilt to his voice that hinted at how
amusing he found that phrase.
I'm here to challenge you, for the throne
of the night wing tribe.
Chapter 11.
Turtle wasn't sure why he was so
shocked.
After all, wanting to become king of the
night wings, certainly fit in with
everything else Dark Stalker had done so
far, but it still hadn't occurred to
him.
No tribe had ever had a king in the
history of Pyria, as far as turtle knew.
He never could have imagined this scene
or how Queen Glory could suddenly look as
though she were made of spun glass.
If he could be king, then I could be a
king too.
Where did that thought come from?
Turtle would never want to be king in a
1000000 years, and he would never be able
to do what it took to become one.
Even after what I did to Chameleon.
He frowned down at his twitching talons.
That was not the real him.
These thoughts were not the real him
either.
Moon broke away from her mother and
started pushing forward through the
crowd.
You can't do that.
Death Bringer spat at Dark Stalker.
Glory didn't stop him.
She was staring at Dark Stalker as though
he'd upended 800000 words on her head, and
she was trying to put them in the right
order to make a scroll.
Why not?
Dark Stalker asked.
For one thing, you're male said
Deathbringer.
And for another, you're not royalty, so
you have no right to the throne.
In case you hadn't noticed, she's not
exactly of royal night wing blood either
Dark Socker said, flicking his tail at
glory.
And just because we've never had a king
before, doesn't mean we shouldn't have
one now.
Pyria has only had queens for the
entirety of dragon history. said
Deathbringer.
Male dragons cannot rule their tribes.
That just the way it is.
Things can change.
Dark Stalker said airily.
Where dragons, not ants.
We can do things differently if we choose
to.
Turtle had a flash of déjà vu and touched
his claws to his head.
Where had he heard that before?
From one of the teachers at Jade
Mountain?
Dark Stalker, Moon hissed from the front
of the crowd, and he looked down at her.
What are you doing?
You promised not to hurt my friends.
Feel free to check on your friends, said
Dark Stalker, in an unsettlingly gentle
voice.
I'm sure you'll find that they're all
safe, and perfectly unharmed.
But glory is my friend too, Moon said, her
voice wobbling.
I don't want you to kill her.
Was that real sympathy and dark stalker's
eyes?
Oh, moon, he said.
The truth is, you don't want me to kill
anybody.
And neither do I. But we are dragons.
There's a way these things have to be
done.
I cannot accept your challenge, Glory
said.
And Dark Stalker turned back to her
leaving Moon with her talons helplessly
outstretched.
The rain wings need me too.
If I fault you, I'd be putting their
tribe and throne at risk.
Maybe I could be king of both tribes, Dark
Stalker said.
Ha ha, just a joke.
I have no interest in ruling a bunch of
snoozy, colorful vegetarians.
Turtle wasn't sure if he was imagining it
but he thought a few of the night wings
actually looked a bit offended by that
comment.
There's another alternative.
Dark Stalker went on.
You could just give me the night wing
throne.
He shot a glance at Moon as if to say
look, I'm making an effort.
Now do you approve?
That would not be fair to the dragons
here who swore loyalty to me, said
Glory.
Well, said Dark Stalker.
Let's all remember that they had a
volcano pointed to their heads at the
time.
You're certainly more appealing than
death by lava.
But if there were a charming, handsome
superpowered night wing as an option
instead.
Queen Glory looked out if they gathered
night wings.
What are they thinking?
Turtle wondered.
Would they rather be ruled by a rain wing
or by a legendary monster?
He remembered the stories he'd read about
albatross.
The sea wing animus who massacred most of
his family.
If albatross somehow came back to life.
And he acted like a sane, friendly dragon
and turtle had to choose between him or
say, Queen Glacier to rule the kingdom of
the sea.
Who would he pick?
Oh, said Dark Stalker, nodding at glory.
Very interesting idea, Your Majesty.
Glory looked at him sharply.
Let the night wings choose for themselves
he said.
Indeed.
I could agree to that.
I haven't offered it to you yet, said
Glory.
In this time period.
It's considered bad manners to read
another dragon's thoughts.
My apologies.
But you had such a good idea.
A peaceful transition of power.
Maybe dragons have evolved in the last
2000 years after all.
What do you think?
Dark Stalker said to the assembled
Nightwings.
Shall we put it to a vote?
Like some enormous sprawling mess of a
council.
King dog stalker, or Queen Rain Wing.
No, Queen Glory said, stepping forward
into a bar of sunlight that lit up every
brilliant scale.
Not a vote.
I don't want my...
Any night wing, to be forced to live
somewhere or under someone they are
unhappy with.
She studied the ebony dragons below her.
Those who wish to stay in the rainforest
with me.
In the village, you've built with your
own talons are welcome here forever.
Those who would rather follow dark
stalker to the old kingdom, are free to
go.
Dark Stalker looked down at the crowd
too.
From a considerably greater distance, and
he did not look pleased with what he
saw.
Or what he was hearing in their minds
Turtle realized.
But you don't have to decide right now
Dark Stalker said, quickly, slippery
smooth.
You should get to know me first.
I presume Queen Glory won't mind if I
spend a day or 2 in the rainforest
reacquainting myself with my tribe.
Be our guest.
Glory rested her quiet gaze on him for a
moment.
Just a moment.
While something puzzled flickered behind
her eyes.
Then she turned to Deathbringer, and the
2 of them hopped down from the stage to
walk among the night wings.
A hubbub of voices rose, hushed and
panicked at the same time, who would stay
who would go?
What would become of them?
Dark stalker's eyes went to moon.
See, he said softly.
I knew I wouldn't really have to kill
glory, but I had to present myself as a
strong leader moon.
That's what dragons understand.
Moon gave him a wounded look, and turned
away, back toward her mother's wings.
Turtle watched Dark Stalker watching her
go.
I think I found one true thing about Dark
Stalker, he thought.
He actually cares about Moon.
But how does she feel?
She's the one who's been helping him so
far.
Will she follow him to the night
kingdom?
Or will she choose Queen Glory?
And if she does, how is he going to
react?
Queen Glory stayed in the Nightwing
Village until midafternoon, answering
questions, and talking with any dragon
who approached her.
Dark Stalker installed himself on a flat
boulder by the river and did the same
while Anemone splashed and swam in the
fish flickering water.
It all seemed very peaceful, entirely
open, nothing suspicious or underhanded.
Turtle wrote a quick note on his slate to
Kibley.
Dark stalker wants to be Nightwing King.
Nightwings deciding what they want.
Then he wiped it clean, and tried not to
fall asleep while Dark Stalker droned on
about parliamentary procedures in the
ancient night kingdom.
But then glory left, flying back to check
on her rain wings, Dark Stalker saw her
go.
He waited a few minutes, swirling his
tail in the river, as he listened to a
sly looking dragon named Obsidian
complain about rainforest insects.
Finally, Dark Stalker said, that does
sound dreadful.
You know, the night kingdom doesn't have
any mosquitoes.
He sat up and called, mind reader.
Touching his head as though summoning her
by telepathy as well.
A few moments later, the dragonette came
scampering through the village with an
older, significantly more reluctant
looking night wing, limping behind her.
Here, she said breathlessly, skidding to
a stop below Dark Stalker.
Come on, father, you have to meet him.
He's got amazing powers.
So I hear.
Mind reader's father said gruffly.
But don't you understand that he's
sharing them, she said.
If you could have any power in the world
what would you want, Father?
He snorted.
To be anonymous, of course.
Is there anything more powerful?
Mind reader turned to Dark Stalker with
shining eyes, but Dark Stalker was
shaking his head with a regretful
expression.
I'm sorry, he said.
That is the one gift, which is beyond my
abilities to grant.
An animus dragon cannot make other animus
dragons.
Huh, thought Turtle.
He knew that was a lie.
Does Dark Stalker know he's lying, or
does he believe that?
That's not the only thing father wants.
Mind reader said quickly.
I can hear it in his head.
He wants the ability to heal instantly
from any wound, not just new wounds, but
all the old aches and weak bones and
clouded lungs he got from living on the
volcano.
Oh, father, I'm sorry.
I didn't know you were always in pain
like that.
She twined her tail around his, and
Turtle found himself liking her for the
1st time.
You're not supposed to know these things
her father said with a wince.
I'm not sure it's going to be good for
you, little one, hearing everyone's
thoughts this way.
Dragons like to keep their secrets.
I know.
It's incredible how many secrets there
are, mind reader said, her eyes
widening.
If I were blackmailing sort of dragon, I
could get so much treasure, but I'm not
of course.
Of course I'm not.
And I wouldn't.
She let out a little laugh.
Enough about me, dark soccer.
I'm not sure about this, said her father
edging away as Dark Stalker reached
toward him.
I don't trust anyone to put a spell on
me.
So we'll use something temporary.
Dark Stalker said winningly.
He sliced a vine off the tree branch
overhead, and wove it into a simple loop
which he dropped over the other dragon's
neck.
I'll enchant this to heal you.
And when it rots away, come back, and let
me know if you liked it, and want
something more permanent.
He hooked one claw in the vine necklace
and muttered something under his breath.
Mind reader's father let out a startled
gasp.
He stretched his wings and tail.
He turned his head from side to side.
He looked 40 years younger just from the
way he was suddenly standing, and the way
his eyes were shining.
Oh, he said. 3 moons.
I couldn't even remember what it was like
to feel this way.
I'm here to help. said Dark Stalker, with
his charming grin.
Now, go tell all your friends.
Uh oh, thought Turtle.
Uh-oh was right.
The 1st trickle of curious night wings
became a waterfall.
Once words spread that Dark Stalker was
handing out superpowers.
The ability to catch any prey, done.
Flight speed faster than any sky wing, or
indeed any other dragon on Pyria.
Done.
Camouflage scales like the rain wings.
Dark stalker chuckled, and talked to that
dragon out of his choice.
Why would you want to blow the lines of
what you really are?
Be a nightwing, and proud of it.
If I give you advanced warrior skills
you'll never need to hide again anyway.
Advanced Warrior Skills.
Done.
The ability to go for days without sleep
done.
And then, Dark Stalker announced that
powering up 5 dragons per day was his
limit.
But this way you can think about it
overnight, he said.
What do you each really want?
What would be the best possible power for
you?
I promise you.
I'll share my gift with 5 more dragons
tomorrow.
On the way to the old knight kingdom.
Wow.
Turtle thought.
He's not messing around.
Follow me, and I'll make you special, or
stay here.
And remain your own ordinary self.
What dragon could resist an offer like
that?
What chance does glory have when that's
the alternative?
He pulled out his slate and thought for a
moment, then wrote to Kibley.
The night wings are getting a king.
Chapter 12.
Turtle could feel the tides shifting in
the village.
Dragons whispering about another side to
dark stalker, about how the history
scrolls could have been wrong, about how
night wings should stick with their own
and stop mingling with lazy vegetarians.
I should tell glory, shouldn't I?
She has no idea who I am.
But she'd want to know what Dark Stalker
is doing, wouldn't she?
He worried for a while, watching Dark
Stalker tell stories of the old days to a
rapt audience of dragons.
Finally, he scooted back along his branch
and set off in the direction Glory had
gone.
A short distance beyond the Nightwing
village, all the trees began to look the
same.
Not long after that, Turtle realized he
didn't exactly know where he was going.
He stopped, hovering in midair, and
glanced around at the dense, never ending
greenery, lost in the rainforest.
That sounded exactly like what would
happen to the turtle character in a
story.
While the heroic heroes battled onward
wondering vaguely where he'd gone.
Except in this case, there were no heroic
heroes battling, because they were all
too busy making friends with a potential
supervillain.
Turtle side.
So, I can't be lost in the rainforest, he
thought.
I can't be the inept best friend right
now.
I have to be someone else.
The messenger, perhaps, who warns the
heroes of the danger, and then fades back
into the background.
What would a successful, determined
messenger do about being lost in the
rainforest?
He found a very fat tree with comfortable
wide branches to sit on.
All around him, the bright red flowers
danced, the leaves twitched, the shadows
and sunlight darted and glimmered as wind
pushed the treetops around.
Hello, he said.
Any chance I'm being followed?
If he was?
No one answered.
He tried again.
I have an urgent message for Queen
Glory.
She'll want to hear it, I promise.
But I don't know how to find her.
More silence.
More trees flapping their leaves at him
dismissively.
So, that didn't work.
He wasn't quite lucky enough to have any
camouflaged rain wings spying on him
right now.
His immediate instinct was to use his
magic.
That would be the easiest solution.
That was always the easiest solution.
Whenever he felt a little sick, or too
tired for anatomy class, or needed help
finding something, he'd reach for a
magical solution.
As long as it was small enough for no one
to notice.
But he couldn't do that now, because Dark
Stalker would notice any spell, no matter
how small.
His talons went to his pouch.
Wait, maybe he already had what he
needed.
He slipped the pouch open with careful
claws, tipping it, so his animus touched
treasures clicked and tumbled together.
Near the bottom, wrapped in leaves to
protect it, was the piece of coral.
It was shaped like a small lacy red tree
with little bubbles all along its
branches.
Turtle remembered the night he'd
enchanted it.
The night he'd realized he was an
animus.
Queen Coral's sons were rarely invited to
royal functions, as there were simply too
many of them.
But when turtle, octopus, and cerulean
were all one year old, their father
managed to get them invited to their 1st
graham ball.
Turtles brothers were excited.
Turtle was mostly nervous.
Would he say the right things?
Would he remember all the rules about
when to eat, and more important, when not
to eat?
Gil had sent matching earrings for all
the princes to wear.
Each one a heavy gold ring with a pearl
hanging from it.
Octopus and cerulean clipped theirs on
easily, but turtle could not figure his
out.
He'd never worn an earring before.
His claws felt too big and awkward to
work the catch open far enough, and the
earrings kept slipping out of his grasp
and floating slowly down to the seaweed
carpeted floor of his room.
Octopus and cerulean laughed at him as he
scrabbled in the seaweed, which had
swallowed one of the earrings
completely.
It's not that hard, Octopus teased.
His phosphorescent scales flashing.
By all the whales' turtle, do you have
tentacles for talons?
They turn to swim out of the room.
See there, Cerolean called mockingly.
If you ever make it, octopus agreed, and
they cackled their way down the hall.
Grimly, Turtle glared at the remaining
earring, pinched between his claws.
Arr, earring, he snarled, shaking it.
Get on my ear right now, and stay there.
The earring moved, shimmying in turtle's
grasp.
Startled, he let go, and the earring
confidently made a beeline straight for
turtle's ear.
A moment later, he felt a nudging pinch
and when he looked in the mirror, there
it was, hanging from his ear exactly
where it was supposed to be.
Did I do that?
He felt terrified and elated at the same
time.
If he did that, there was only one
explanation.
He'd heard the stories about Albatross
the ancient animus sea wing, although
that particular story didn't end very
well.
There were fewer stories about other
animus sea wings, like Fathom, who were
much more cautious with their powers.
Despite the horror stories, a part of
Turtle had always wondered what it would
be like to be an animus, with all that
power in his claws.
He had to test it out, to find out if it
was real.
One of the walls of their room was made
of coral, and he'd noticed a small piece
that was nearly broken off.
He swam over and carefully snapped it
free, then clasped it between his
talons.
I enchant this piece of coral to help me
find whatever I'm looking for.
He peeked to the coral, but it looked
exactly the same.
Hmm.
My other earring, he flashed at it in
aquatic.
He caught himself wondering whether coral
could speak aquatic, just as the little
red tree twitched and twisted in his
claws.
It tugged him down to the seaweed carpet
where it poked through the flapping
overlapping strands until it bumped
against his missing earring.
That might have been the most glorious
moment of turtle's life.
It was certainly all downhill from there
if you asked him.
He was an animus.
His brothers couldn't laugh at him now.
His mother and father would have to pay
attention to him.
He'd be the star of the whole palace.
That was kind of a frightening thought
actually.
Everyone looking at him.
Everyone wanting him to perform, everyone
waiting for him to mess up.
But the truth was, only one thing stopped
him from swimming straight into the ball
and announcing his discovery to everyone
stories.
Turtle knew how stories worked.
He knew that a dragon with strange powers
could be a hero, or a villain.
And a lot depended on how everyone found
out what he or she could do.
The best heroes were the ones who took
everyone by surprise in their hour of
need, just when all hope was lost, the
unexpected hero would swoop in and save
the day.
And if Turtle revealed his power that way
when it was really needed, then no one
would be scared of him.
He'd clearly be a hero.
Drama, excitement, and the chance to do
something wonderful when no one saw it
coming.
That's what Turtle wanted in his story.
So he hit his power, waiting for the
perfect moment of revelation.
The tribes were all at war.
Surely it would come soon.
But then it came, when his father needed
him, and he didn't recognize it.
And then it was gone.
In the rainforest, far from home.
Turtles sighed and turned the coral over
in his claws.
The last time he'd used it was the day
Gil sent him searching for Snapper.
Turtle had had to be very surreptitious
since octopus and cerulean insisted on
following him around, and giggling over
how incompetent he was.
At 1st he thought he'd been very clever
to think of using the coral, but it
hadn't worked.
Something was wrong with it.
It kept trying to lead him out of the
deep palace, which was why he was
uselessly prowling the gardens when Gil
found him.
He should have enchanted something else
even with octopus and Zerulean watching.
He should have realized that finding
Snapper was the great thing he was meant
to do.
He should have revealed his secret right
then and saved the day.
In fact, he should have used his magic to
find the assassin who was killing off the
princesses.
It was embarrassing and awful, that he'd
never even thought of that until years
later, when tsunami showed up and figured
out who it was.
But after Turtle's failure, he didn't
know how to tell anyone he was an animus
he'd lost the plot of his story.
He kept imagining his father saying, But
if you had magic the whole time.
Why didn't you find Snapper?
Why didn't you save your sisters?
What kind of dragon has this power and
doesn't use it to help his family?
I'm more disappointed in you than ever.
And the longer he hit it, the worse it
got.
Why didn't he use his magic to rescue his
father from the sky wings?
Why didn't he use his magic to stop the
attack on the summer palace?
Why was he such a useless, wretched
excuse for a dragon?
Turtle realized he was gripping the
corals so tightly that it was leaving an
imprint in his palm.
He unclenched his fist and looked at it
He wasn't even sure why he'd kept the
thing after it failed him.
Maybe because it was the 1st real
enchantment he'd ever cast.
It reminded him of that brief moment when
he'd been so happy and excited about his
future.
Most likely, it wouldn't work now
either.
But he couldn't enchant anything new.
He didn't have many other options, and it
was worth a try.
Queen Glory, he whispered.
The coral twitched and hummed softly, then
tugged him northward.
He spread his wings and flew, paying
attention to the signals it gave, turning
him this way and that, and upward through
the forest toward the canopy.
I could have used this to help peril find
Scarlet, he realized, or to find my
friends in possibility.
Instead, he had left it behind at school
with his other animus touched objects, it
hadn't even occurred to him to try using
it.
He wouldn't have expected it to work, and
he wouldn't have wanted peril to notice
it.
But it certainly would have been useful.
He thought ruefully.
Add that to the list of ways I could have
helpfully used my magic and didn't.
Soon enough, there was glory.
There, in fact, was the entire rain wing
village tucked into the treetops.
As Turtle flew closer, he saw more and
more shapes emerge from the leaves
hammocks, and walkways, pavilions and
dwellings, silver furred sloths, and
beautiful dragons of all colors
everywhere.
Queen Glory was on one of the highest
pavilions, bathed in sunlight with her
wings spread wide.
She was asleep, but Deathbringer sat
watchfully beside her, scanning the
undergrowth for any threats.
Threats seemed hard to imagine here, in
this peaceful place, but turtle thought
of dark stalker and his 5 new
superpowered night wings, only a short
flight away, and he shivered.
The coral tugged him stubbornly toward
the platform.
Deathbringer saw him coming and sat up
with a sharply curious, but not
unfriendly expression.
Holt, he called.
When turtle was only a short distance
away.
What business do you have with the
queen?
The animus touched Coral did not like it
at all when Turtles stopped and hovered
in midair.
It jabbed painfully at his palm, trying
to move him forward.
A bit late.
Turtle remembered the coral's weird
habit.
It would not stop searching for the thing
he wanted to find until he actually
touched the object with the coral.
It wouldn't fly away on its own.
But every time he picked it up, it would
squirm and poke him until it reached its
goal.
This had been confirmed rather gruesomely
when it dragged him through the palace
the night after his failure, just so it
could bump itself against the side of
Snapper's corpse, in a way that turtle
thought was entirely too smug for a
malfunctioning scrap of coral.
Um, turtle said, clapping his other
talent around the one that held the
coral.
I've been watching Dark Stalker since you
left the Nightwing Village, and I thought
the Queen should know what he's been up
to.
What's a sea wing doing in the rainforest
in the 1st place?
Death Bringer asked doubtfully.
Are you here with dog stalker, like the
princess?
No, no.
Turtle said.
I mean, I'm just watching him.
Anemone is my sister, he fumbled, but
apparently that was enough of an
explanation for Deathbringer.
I see, he said.
Well, I'm reluctant to wake the queen
during her suntime.
Is it urgent?
Um said turtle.
Probably not.
If Dark Stalker wasn't going to enchant
any more dragons today, did it make any
difference?
Death bringer.
Queen Glory said with a sigh, opening her
eyes.
I'm not sure if you're familiar with a
concept of ears and how they work, but
most normal dragons would find it very
difficult to sleep through your allowed
interrogations.
I was giving you the opportunity to
pretend to sleep through them.
Death bringer objected.
You're usually much better at it.
I nearly gave myself away by laughing
when you said, halt, though, Glory said
stretching and sitting up.
I mean, who says halt, seriously.
I thought it sounded dignified and
commanding, said Deathbringer.
Indeed, or like a pretentious night wing
glory observed.
I am a pretentious night wing.
It's part of my appeal.
All right, hush, you, said Glory.
Patting Deathbringer's talons with her
tail.
Come here, Seawing, what's your name?
Turtle, your majesty, he said.
The coral was kind of going berserk as he
landed beside her, and she shot a curious
look at his squirming talons.
I'm tsunami's brother.
One of them.
I'm nobody really.
The messenger.
Here to tell someone who can actually
save the world.
I just thought you should know that Dark
Stalker has given a few night wings
special powers.
Special powers, Deathbringer echoed.
Like what?
Mind reading, turtle listed off, super
strength, fighting skills, the power to
catch any prey, instant healing, that
kind of thing.
Wow, said Glory.
It's going to be hard to compete with
that.
I wouldn't leave you, even for a
superpower, Deathbringer said loyally.
I think that is your superpower, Glory
said to him.
Extreme heroic idiocy.
She arranged her face to look serious
again and turned to turtle.
Well, if that means all the night wings
decide to go with dark stalker, I suppose
my job around here will get a lot
easier.
She looked wistfully out at the rest of
the village, where many of the rain wings
were asleep in their leaf hammocks and
sunlit nests.
That's true, said Deathbringer, much less
grumbling and complaining to deal with.
They were kind of growing on me, though
Glory admitted.
They're impressively resilient.
Not to mention, observed with scrolls and
learning and stuff, said Deathbringer, all
your favorite things.
I did think the night wings and the rain
wings could be good for each other.
Once they had some mutual respect and
trust in place.
Glory lifted her wings up and down in a
soft sigh.
Oh, well.
Wait, said Turtle, you're not going to do
anything to stop him?
We have an agreement.
Glory said, surprised.
Why would I stop him?
Um, maybe because he's turning his tribe
into kind of a super army.
Doesn't that worry either of you?
Huh, said Deathbringer.
I guess you could look at it that way.
Isn't it your job to look at it that
way?
Turtle thought?
Frustrated?
Maybe, if it was anyone else.
Quinn Gloria agreed, but I mean, Dark
Stalker is such a great dragon.
I just trust him.
Don't you?
I do, Deathbringer said, nodding.
I like him.
Turtle couldn't speak.
His head felt as if it was full of
squirming, flashing electric eels.
All his suspicions coalesced into one
diamond bright conviction.
This was not a normal reaction, not to
dark stalker, nor any dragon who came in
to steal the tribe you were ruling.
None of the dragons who'd spoken to Dark
Stalker were reacting to him in a normal
way.
Kibley was right after all.
He had been under a spell.
That calm, trusting feeling he'd had
about dark stalker, that was the work of
magic.
This was why everyone was behaving so
weird and unworried.
Dark Stalker had crafted some kind of
spell. something that affected every
dragon who met him.
It made dragons like him and trust him
and perhaps worse.
What if it made everyone obey him?
Or willing to sacrifice their lives for
him.
If Dark Stalker wanted to, he could turn
all the dragons of Pyria, one by one, into
his own personal puppets, and nobody
would be able to stop him, because nobody
would even know anything was wrong.
Chapter 13.
So, maybe now it's time to run and hide.
Turtle thought.
Back to the kingdom of the sea.
Back to the anonymity of his pack of
brothers.
Back to a world so distant that Dark
Stalker might never come there.
Back to the only place that might be safe
at least for a little while.
This was too big for him to handle.
He sort of had Kibley, but what if
something happened to Kibley, or Dark
Stalker figured out how to ensnare him
again?
Turtle could end up as the only dragon
Empyrea, who saw dark stalker the way he
really was.
And then what?
Spend the rest of his life as the
unbalanced, invisible dragon?
trying to convince his friends, they were
bewitched by a sinister magician.
The mad prophet of doom.
Not exactly the role I ever saw myself
in.
But the alternative was coward who sits
and waits for the inevitable apocalypse.
If he scurried off back to the ocean.
Would anyone ever notice what Dark
Stalker was doing?
Would anyone ever be able to stop him?
So if he couldn't run away, and he
couldn't change anyone's mind, and he
couldn't fight Dark Stalker himself, what
could he do?
I need help.
He touched the cord of his pouch, tied
around his neck.
Should he write to Kibley?
ask him to come here.
He could feel his worrying reflex kicking
into action.
His scales felt hot and clammy at the
same time.
Was he sure that Kibley was free of any
dark stalker spells?
What if dark stalker had enchanted his
spell to be irreversible, even by other
magic?
Or what if he'd enchanted Kibley to stay
at Jade Mountain, so seeing him in the
rainforest would make him suspicious.
Everything Kibley did might give Dark
Stalker a clue that his spell wasn't
working on him anymore.
Turtle's safety would be in danger, if
Kibley and Dark Stalker spent too much
time near each other.
I wish I could get his advice, though.
Turtle dropped his talons, frustrated.
Too bad the slates don't work both ways.
Thanks to me being a short-sighted idiot
again.
Who else could help him?
I need someone who hasn't met Dark
Stalker yet.
Someone who will believe me, someone who
can actually be the hero.
His mother?
Would Queen Coral believe him if he went
to her with this story?
Would she be able, or willing, to fight
dark stalker?
He couldn't really imagine her trusting
him that much.
And if she did, and brought the sea wings
out to fight dark stalker, wouldn't that
put turtle's entire tribe in danger?
So perhaps one of the other queens.
Glacier, Ruby, Morhen, or Thorn.
Would any of them listen to a sea wing?
And wouldn't they fall under Dark
Stalker's spell the moment they met him?
Not to mention, in order to convince them
his story was true, he'd have to tell
them everything.
As in, oh, yes.
And I'm an animist.
Everything.
He shuddered, and his hold on the coral
loosened, and it darted forward in a
flash and bopped Queen Glory on the side
of her tail.
She turned to stare at him.
What was that?
Nothing?
Nothing, he said.
My talon slipped.
Sorry.
She raised one eyebrow.
You're an odd dragon turtle.
That's what my friends tell me, he said
and his friends rose up in his mind, and
a possibility shot through him, shining
with hope.
Your majesty. he said.
May I ask, how is Kinkaju?
I don't know, Glory said.
Her wings drooping.
The healers can't understand why she
hasn't woken up yet.
They don't know what to do for her.
We all thought that once she was back in
the rainforest, around the smells and
sounds and some that she grew up with
she'd, Back in the rainforest, Turtle
interrupted, she's here.
Of course.
Queen Glory flicked her tail, knocking
loose a shower of yellow blossoms.
I wasn't going to leave her alone on the
other side of the continent.
The healers got back with her yesterday.
Can I see her?
Turtle asked.
His claws were tingling.
Kinkaju hadn't met Dark Stalker.
Kinkaju would believe him.
He could trust her with his secret.
And Kinkajou was much more cut out for
heroism than he was.
Glory gave him directions to the healer's
pavilion, not far away, tucked into a
little alcove of the rainforest that
seemed even more peaceful than the rest
of the village.
Turtle could smell healing herbs and
oranges as he flew to the opening.
Inside, sunlight poured through the rooms
from skylights that had been opened in
the roofs.
A pair of pale blue heelers were asleep
in one corner.
Another was neatly folding cobwebs and
moss into bundles on one of the shelves.
She looked up as Turtle came in, but
seemed only mildly surprised to see a sea
wing in her pavilion.
She swept one wing toward the bed where
Kinkachu slept, and Turtle nodded
unconsciously flashing his scales in
aquatic.
Yes, that's what I'm looking for.
Kinkachu lay in a sunbeam that outlined
every scale with gold.
She was still as white as an ice wing.
White being the color of pain or shock to
the rain wings.
But in this sun, it was the white of
opals, jeweled and glinting with hints of
hidden colors, pearl pinks, and sparks of
green.
It wasn't the color of her scales that
made her look so unlike Kinkachu.
It was her complete stillness.
Turtle had never seen Kinkaju sit still
for a moment.
Even in class.
Her wings always twitched, or her claws
fidgeted, or her face would make sideways
expressions at him or moon.
What did he say?
I knew that answer.
Is it time to eat yet?
Are you starving?
I'm starving.
Isn't school amazing?
Turtle sat down beside her bed and curled
his tail in.
Missing her in a way that filled him with
heavy seaweed from nose to tail.
He knew this was ridiculous.
He didn't even know her that well.
They'd had barely 4 days at Jade Mountain
before everything went wrong.
Before Kinkaju left to find Winter's
brother, defeat Scarlet, and save the
world from Moon's prophecy.
While Turtle chose to slink back to the
safety of the school instead.
That was exactly why he needed her.
Kinkaju, he whispered.
Can you hear me?
I need you to wake up.
Knowing Kinkaju.
He have expected her to open her eyes and
joke.
Oh, well, if you need me to, then sure.
I was just taking a really long nap, but
let's go fight some bad guys.
She didn't though.
He'd already tried this, back in
possibility, but now he fumbled his
healing river stone out of his pouch
again.
His stupid, short-sighted enchantment
that only healed surface wounds.
Still, he brushed it lightly along
Kinkajoo's bruised spine over the
bandages on her broken ribs and gently
around her fractured skull.
Impossibility.
They'd watched the bruises fade, and all
the scrapes and cuts disappear, but it
didn't work any deeper, and Kinkaju did
not wake up.
This time wasn't any different.
Kinkaju still lay quietly, quietly
breathing, eyes closed.
Turtle had wanted to enchant something
right then that could wake her, but he
was afraid that one of the possibility
doctors would notice, and Moon had been
worried for his soul.
She'd suggested waiting 2 more days, at
least, to see if Kinkaju woke up on her
own.
But then they'd flown off to find peril
which had led them to the scroll, and
then the release of Dark Stalker, and now
here they were.
And now he couldn't use magic to help
her.
He crushed a bright orange flower between
his claws, frustrated.
If only he'd been brave and stubborn
enough to heal her earlier.
But then, she would have meant dark
stalker, along with everyone else.
She'd be under his spell too.
Kinkaju, he said sternly.
Enough sleeping.
Time to get up and save the world.
No reaction.
You know you've always wanted to. he
wheedled.
Think how impressed Queen Glory will be.
All you have to do is wake up and figure
out how to stop the most powerful dragon
in the history of Pyria.
No problem, right?
No reaction from Kinkaju.
But he got a very odd look from the
healer at the other end of the pavilion.
All right, he couldn't talk her awake, and
he couldn't use his magic.
Wait.
He couldn't use his magic.
Turtle thought for a long time, his brow
froed into serious wrinkles.
Five iridescent purple butterflies
settled on his tail, and fluttered serene
butterfly thoughts at one another without
him even noticing they were there.
Finally, turtle blinked and sat up
scattering indigo wings in all
directions.
He had a plan.
Possibly a terrible plan, but the only
one he could think of.
He flew out of the pavilion and used his
coral again to navigate the rainforest
and find his way back to anemone.
The sea wing princess was swimming in a
pool several lengths upstream from dark
stalkers gathering.
Her pale shape flickered like a dolphin
below the water, in and out of the
shadows.
Turtle landed with a squelch in the mud
let the coolness sink into his claws, and
waited for her to surface.
Oh, hi, she said cheerfully. when she
finally saw him.
I was wondering where you went.
Dog soccer's stories are great, but I'm
kind of not so interested in ancient
nightwing history.
Blah, blah, 8000000 years ago, they had a
cool library, yawn.
I was like, so what were the sea wings up
to back then?
And he was all getting massacred.
So that was cheerful.
I would say come on in, but I should warn
you, there are all kinds of weird sticky
plants under the surface here.
Thanks anyway, Turtle said.
Hey, anemone, is it true you can do as
many spells as you want now?
Yep.
His sister ducked under the water and
surfaced again, shooting a spray of water
at a grumpy looking frog on the
riverbank.
Thanks to my cool enchanted silver
necklace.
She tapped the collar with one claw.
I'm going to cast so many spells.
It'll be like the sea is full of magic.
I could rebuild the Summer Palace, or
make us a new palace, maybe.
I can stop hurricanes.
I could make Uncle Sharks scales, turn
bright pink, and all his teeth fall out.
Ah.
I can enchant every pearl in the ocean to
come rolling up to our door.
Oh, Turtle said, bewildered by this rush
of ideas.
But the pearl divers like their jobs.
It's just an example, turtle, Anemone
said scornfully.
And just saying, when we get home, things
are going to be pretty different in the
kingdom of the sea.
You're not.
You're not going to try to take the
throne, are you?
Turtle asked.
He hadn't quite thought ahead to what
might happen.
If Anemone decided to use her magic
against their mother in a challenge
duel.
It didn't seem fair, although Queen Coral
had somehow defeated Orca, who had turned
out to be an animus too, but a secret
one.
Like me.
Not yet.
Anemone said with a laugh.
I want to have a lot more fun before I
get stuck in a boring old palace, making
decisions all day.
And I want to learn everything dark
stalker can teach me about being an
animist.
Isn't he cool?
Don't you feel like an idiot for being so
worried?
Right.
Turtle glance downstream, realizing that
Dark Stalker might come looking for
anemone any moment now.
So, since you're so super powerful now
could you do something for me?
An irritated look briefly flitted across
anemones face, and Turtle winced, knowing
exactly how she felt.
Other dragons wanting to use your magic
it was like they were asking to wear your
scales.
Like what?
Anemone asked.
It's Kinkaju, Turtle said.
I wouldn't ask for me, but she's really
hurt. and she won't wake up, and I'm
afraid only magic can save her.
Oh, Anemone said.
Her frown clearing like the tide pulling
away from the beach.
Aww.
You want me to save the cute little rain
wing you're in love with?
I'm not in love with her, Turtle
protested, but she's, you know, she's
awesome.
And I just wanted to get better.
I can totally do that.
Anemone said gleefully, splashing it out
of the pool toward him.
He bopped her lightly with a wriggling
coral as she went by, but she didn't
notice.
But I am going to tease you about it
forever.
You think she's cute.
You totally love her.
Anemone.
Turtle swatted at her with his tail, and
she danced away, giggling.
In the palace, Anemone had been a distant
figure. always attached to the queen by a
harness.
She was never allowed to wander freely, or
associate with her rough and tumble
brothers.
Turtle had only known her as the beloved
princess, who got all their mother's
love.
He'd seen her at royal gatherings, or at
Queen Coral's scroll readings, sitting
quietly beside her, soaking up all that
attention.
But then tsunami came and caught the
assassin, and a new princess finally
hatched, an anemone was released from the
harness at last.
She began visiting her brothers out of
curiosity, and Turtle watched her closely
wondering what her life was like as a
known animus.
She seemed funny and happy much of the
time, but there was a dark streak to some
of her jokes, along with an imperious
certainty that she deserved all of her
princess privileges.
It worried him, and it worried him more
the more he found he liked her.
All right, take me into your sleeping
beauty.
Anemone said dramatically.
Oh, brother, Turtle said, rolling his
eyes.
He tucked the coral back into its pouch
and lifted off into the trees, anemone
followed him, singing, Turlin Kinkaju
flying in the sky, getting all K-I-S-S
Y.
He clapped his talons over his ears and
kept them there the rest of the way to
the rain wing village.
Anemone fell silent as they crossed the
threshold into the healer's pavilion.
She gazed around at the other patients, a
rain wing with a head wound, and a night
wing with a jagged tear in one of his
wings.
Both of them were unconscious, probably
tranquilized.
Turtle wondered if their injuries made
anemone think of all the wounded sea
wings, who'd survived the war and the
bombing of the summer palace.
Maybe instead of collecting pearls, and
turning their unfriendly uncle's shades
of fuchsia, Anemone might think about
healing some of her fellow dragons
instead.
Not that I'm one to judge.
How many dragons have I ever helped with
my magic?
Turtles stopped next to Kinkaju.
An anemone went around her other side
studying the pale little rain wing.
Kinkachoo was older than anemone, but
they were not very different in size.
Anemone lifted one of Kinkaju's drooping
talons.
Wow, she said softly.
She does look terrible.
I'm sorry for teasing you, turtle.
Oh, good, he said.
I mean, I'm going to keep doing it, she
added, but not until she's well again.
Okay, let me think for a minute.
Anemone scrunged up her snout.
Oops.
I'm supposed to tell dark stalker if I
decided to do any more spells.
He doesn't really want me trying new
things on my own yet.
Seriously?
said Turtle.
Haven't you been doing spells on your own
pretty much your whole life?
That's true, said anemone.
And I mean, what does he care if I heal
some random rain wing, right?
Exactly, said Turtle.
He held his breath.
I'll tell him about it when we get back
Anemone said, flicking one of her wings
and startling a cluster of dragonflies in
the leaf roof.
What are you going to enchant?
Turtle asked, exhaling with relief.
Anemone glanced around dubiously at the
flowery vines.
The leaves, the wooden bowls of herbs, all
the biodegradable rainforest things that
wouldn't last very long.
Her eyes fell on the black leather pouch
that was tied to Kinkaju's ankle.
Maybe something in here?
she said, poking it open.
Wait.
Turtle started to say, but already
Kinkachu's library card was tumbling into
Anemone's palm, along with one of the
Skyfire rocks from Turtle's armband, a
gift to protect her thoughts from Moon, or
any mind reader, although Anemone had no
way of knowing that.
His sister peered at the rock for a
moment, then looked up at him with wide
eyes, apparently noticing the holes in
his armband for the 1st time.
You gave her one of your rocks from the
sky.
She crowed.
You love her so much.
Can we please get on with this, he
demanded.
It was going to be a hilarious day
whenever she discovered that he'd also
given matching rocks to Winter and
Kibley.
Well, this should work, she said.
Curling her claws around the star
speckled rock, she closed her eyes.
This is it, turtle.
One chance.
Perfect timing, right?
Now.
I enchant this rock to heal Kinkaju of
all her injuries, so she can wake up, as
happy and healthy as she's ever been, said
Anemone.
And at the same moment, Turtle thought
with all his might, Enchant this Skyfire
to make Kinkaju immune to any spell, Dark
Stalker has ever or will ever cast, and
enchant it, to make her completely
insignificant in his eyes, not worth
thinking about.
Not visible in his futures, not in any
way a threat to him.
He wasn't sure how many times over you
could enchant an object, or if one animus
touch might cancel out another.
So he added hurriedly, and enchanted to
heal all her injuries as well.
This was the key.
Casting his spell in the same moment as
anemones.
He didn't know the details of Dark
Stalker's warning system, but he hoped
one spell would obscure the other, like
Kibley thought.
He'd considered the phrasing of his spell
as carefully as he could, borrowing
Kibley's words and adding more of his
own.
He hoped Dark Stalker would forgive
Anemone for using her spell to help
Kinkaju.
That was why he couldn't hide Kinkachu
the way he'd hidden himself.
And he hoped Dark Stalker wouldn't think
too hard about what else might have
happened here.
Anemone opened her eyes and gave Turtle a
sly smile.
And while we're at it, she said, her
voice playful.
I also enchant this rock to make kinkajoo
love turtle just as much as he loves
her.
Chapter 14.
What?
Turtle cried, horror struck.
Anemone?
You can't do that.
I so absolutely can. she said
triumphantly, already sliding the Skyfire
back into Kinkaju's pouch.
My magic can do anything.
But that's awful.
You can't enchant someone's feelings
Anemone, please take that spell off.
I don't think I can, Anemone said with a
shrug.
Squids and sea monsters, you should be
thanking me.
I just did such an awesome, nice thing
for you.
She reached over Kinkaju and patted one
of his talons, grinning.
I'm the best sister ever.
But I don't want her to like me because
of a spell.
Turtle felt as if he was caught in one of
the rainforest's enormous spider laden
cobwebs.
He couldn't undo the enchantment himself
if that was even possible, or else Dark
Stalker would notice.
But he couldn't take the Skyfire away
from Kinkaju either.
She needed it to be safe from Dark
Stalker.
You'll thank me later.
Anemone said confidently.
When you're married and have lots of
little pink dragonettes with webbed
talons.
Turtle buried his face and his claws, poor
kinkaju.
This was so wrong, so wrong.
Who's getting married?
said a soft, hoarse voice.
He looked up and saw colors rising slowly
into the scales, all across Kinkaju's
back, like the time he'd spilled 5
different ink bottles over his blank
scroll, back when he still dreamed of
being a rider, sunrises drifted into her
wings, pale peaches, and yellows
strengthening into glorious bands of
orange and gold.
Her green eyes were open, and her head
was turned, pillowed on her arms.
She was looking at him.
Hey, turtle, she said sleepily.
We missed you on our heroic quest.
I missed you too, he said, a lump rising
in his throat.
At least, I think it was a heroic quest
she said.
I'm a little bit fuzzy on whether we
actually succeeded.
You did, he said.
You saved Winter's brother, and stopped
Queen Scarlet.
I did?
she said.
Really?
Like how?
In my sleep?
Am I so amazing that I can save the world
and nap at the same time?
She laughed, and her gaze drifted up to
the ceiling.
She sat up, startled.
Whoa.
This place looks exactly like the
rainforest.
It is the rainforest, Turtle said.
You're home.
There's a lot to explain.
Hi, Anemone said.
Elbowing turtle out of the way.
I'm Princess Anemone.
I don't think we officially met at
school.
I'm the one who totally just saved your
life.
She fluffed her wings and stretched her
neck a little longer.
Oh, wow.
Thank you.
Kinkaju said earnestly.
Um, saved my life from what?
You got clobbered by a bad guy, Anemone
said.
You've been unconscious for like days.
You might never have woken up except that
Turtle begged me to heal you.
She poked Turtles backside meaningfully
with her tail.
What bad guy?
Kinkachu cried.
Did we clobber her back?
Three moons?
Did I miss all the excitement again?
She flared her wings, then did a double
take at one of them and jumped.
Hey, my venom splash scars are gone.
Total, remember, the triangle of black
spots that had dotted Kinkaju's wing.
He shifted uncomfortably on its talons.
I guess Anemone's spell healed those
along with your other injuries, he said.
Spell?
Kinkaju yelped.
You healed me with magic?
That is amazing.
I know, it really is, said anemone
preening.
I did like those scars, though, Kinkachu
said, a little wistfully.
They made me seem all battle hardened and
tough.
Turtle bit back a laugh.
As much as he adored her, it would never
in a 1000000 years, have occurred to him
to use those adjectives to describe
Kinkaju.
Oh, well, she said with a shrug.
Thanks again, Anemone.
Ooh, I'd love to be an animus.
Is it fun?
It is now, Anemone said.
Now that I'm the one in charge of my
spells, and nobody's telling me what to
do all the time.
There was a crash outside, like a tree
falling not too far away.
Anemone's face brightened, and she darted
to the doorway.
Don't be scared.
Turtle said to Kingachu, quickly, in a
low voice, a very big, scary looking
dragon is about to show up, but he can't
hurt you, and he can't see me or hear
me.
So don't be confused by that.
I'll explain everything when he's gone.
Kinkachu's eyes were shining with
excitement.
I feel like I fell asleep in one
adventure and woke up in a totally
different one.
What is happening?
This is amazing.
Anemone?
Rumbled Dark Stalker's voice outside the
pavilion.
Have you been doing more magic?
Just a little healing spell?
Anemone said cheerfully.
Kingatu, come here.
I don't know if you should be walking yet
Turtle said, but Kinkaju was already
bouncing off the bed.
Woo!
she said, wobbling on her talons for a
moment.
Guess I haven't stood up in a few days.
Here we go.
She flared her wings for balance and
hopped over to the opening.
Where anemone was holding the flower
curtain aside.
Kingachu stuck her head outside.
Yikes, she yelped.
Who are you?
You are so big.
Oh, said Dark Stalker.
His voice immediately softening.
Moon's friend.
That's all right.
I was planning to heal her myself, in
fact, but anemone.
Please remember to run your spells by me
first.
The 3 healers had all disappeared
somewhere, perhaps scattering at the side
of Dark Stalker, Turtle crept to the
window and peeked out.
The great night wing had landed on a
pavilion outside, and all around him were
flurries of leaves that weren't leaves
and branches that weren't branches, as
alarmed rain wings tried to hide and spy
and sidle away at the same time.
I don't like being bossed around, Anemone
said, lifting her chin.
I know what I'm doing.
Of course you do, he said.
But a 2nd eye on your spells can be
helpful.
I wish I'd had someone to give me advice
about my scroll for instance.
So I could enchant it to be used only by
me, or to return to me if it was stolen.
Wouldn't that have been smart?
I can give you advice like that, because
I've already made my mistakes.
Oh, Anemone said, considering, sure, that
makes sense.
Turtle breathed a sigh of relief.
Dark Stalker wasn't angry, and he didn't
seem to have noticed Turtle's spell
underneath anemones.
Apart from the horrible fact that Kinkaju
was now bewitched into loving him, the
plan had worked.
Your Majesty, Dark Stalker called.
Turtles saw Glory and Deathbringer
gliding through the treetops toward
them.
They landed on a branch nearby, and
Gloria studied Dark Stalker
thoughtfully.
How did you find our village?
she asked.
I followed the sounds of rain wings
thinking, he said. tapping his head.
Or at least what passes for thinking in a
rain wing these days.
This tribe has really gone soft.
Hey, Hinkachu objected.
We defeated your stupid tribe, didn't
we?
Dog Stalker didn't bother to respond.
He didn't even bother to look at her.
I came to deliver a warning.
Your majesty.
He glanced around at the whispering
trees.
There are 5 dragons on their way here to
kill you.
They will most likely attack tonight, and
unless I stop them, they will succeed.
The trees gasped.
I'll stop them, Deathbringer said, lashing
his tail.
I've stopped assassins before.
I have bad news for you, said Dark
Stalker.
I'm the one who can see the future.
I've seen the part where you get stabbed
by a sandwing tail.
Sandwings, Glory asked.
Why would Sandwings want to attack me?
They're working with a pair of night
wings, you misplaced?
Dark Stalker said.
Does that ring a bell?
Glory exchanged a glance with
Deathbringer, and Turtle remembered the
missing prisoners he'd heard about while
eavesdropping, the ones who'd escaped
from the Sandwing stronghold.
You know what you need?
Dark Stalker went on.
A nice strong prison of your own.
Wouldn't that solve a lot of problems?
Rain wings are not really a prison kind
of tribe.
Glory started to say, the dark stalker
was already snapping a branch off one of
the trees overhead.
Brunch, he commanded.
Grow into a fine, strong, indestructible
prison, with room for at least 10
prisoners that no dragon could ever break
out of.
He flung the branch down toward the
ground, and as it fell, it began to grow
snapping outward and up, smashing through
everything it hit as it plummeted.
When it finally crashed to Earth, far
below them, it was a massive, dense cube
of some unfamiliar material with no
windows.
The last few blocks slammed into place
and then it fell silent, apparently
finished.
The rain wings all stared down at it.
Turtle could see Kinkajoo leaning over
the edge of the walkway outside the
healer's hut, her face a picture of
outrage.
The prison was gray and solid, large and
forbidding.
It hulked on the rainforest floor, like a
sinister cloud that had been dragged to
earth and chained down.
Everything about it exuded wrongness.
Perfect. said Dark Stalker.
A ring of metal keys had appeared in his
talons, and he tossed them to Queen
Glory.
You're welcome.
Glory caught the keys and held them at
arm's length, like a talon full of
slugs.
I don't see any windows on that thing, she
said.
It would be cruel to put any rain wings
in there, shut off from the sun, and 10
seems like far more prisoners than we'll
ever have.
Dark Stalker shrugged.
You never know, he said, but use it
however you like.
At least you can get mastermind out of
the quicksand now.
Or give him to me.
And I'll take him far away.
It's up to you.
Gloria lifted her chin.
He still has to answer for his crimes
against rain wings.
Oh, yes. said Dark Stalker.
Does this tribe have a terribly complex
justice system?
Or what's taking so long?
It's A work in progress, Glory said.
Let's visit your new prison, which should
be a safe place to wait for the
assassins.
Dark Stalker suggested, spreading his
wings, and meanwhile, I can tell you all
about the courts and trials, and laws we
had in the old night kingdom.
It was a fascinating process, really
beginning and ending with a Queen's
judgment, of course.
He spiraled down to the rainforest floor
his voice fading as he dropped.
Queen Glory, death bringer and anemone
all flew after him.
Turtle took a step back into the
pavilion.
His heart was beating anxiously.
What if his spell didn't work, and
Kinkaju was as bewitched by dark stalker
as anyone else.
Or what if Dark Stalker wasn't using a
spell after all, and everyone else
genuinely liked him, and Turtle was just
wrong.
Kinkaju ducked back inside, catching a
delicate lavender orchid on one of her
frills, and sauntered over to him.
So that dragon's totally evil, she said.
You think so?
You really do?
said Turtle.
He felt as though he could collapse right
here and nap for 3 days.
He wasn't imagining things, and he wasn't
alone anymore.
He's acting like the boss of anemone.
He's making creepy, unnecessary, un rain
wingy things with his magic, and he's
clearly trying to manipulate everyone
with stuff like, oh, save you from
assassins.
And, oh, I was going to heal her myself
actually.
The good news is Queen Glory and
Deathbringer will see right through him.
They're probably planning some clever way
to drive him out of the rainforest right
now.
Um, said Turtle.
Unfortunately, they're not.
They like him, or they think they do.
See, I think he's using his magic on
everyone.
I don't know the details of the spell, but
it seems like everyone who meets him or
talks to him, ends up thinking he's
perfectly nice, harmless, and
trustworthy.
Everyone?
said Kinkaju.
Even winter, said Turtle.
Winter worst of all.
Holy coconuts.
Kingaju scratched her nose, turning a
thoughtful shade of deep blue.
I'm really surprised.
That night wing seems like the kind of
dragon who believes he's super charming
like he wouldn't need magic to win
dragons over.
Maybe, said Turtle.
But it's failed him once before, so I
think he wants the extra security of the
magic.
He explained Dark Stalker's history to
Kinkachu, at least as much as he knew of
it.
That led him to Dark Stalker's animus
scroll.
So then he had to explain what had
happened with Apparel and Scarlet, and
then as much as he knew of the story with
Hailstorm, it was getting dark by the
time he finished.
Bah!
Kinkachu grumbled, flicking her wings as
orange starbursts went off across her
scales.
I really did miss everything.
That's so unfair.
Well, you're not missing this crisis.
Turtle pointed out.
You and I are the only dragons here who
are safe from Dark Stalker.
Which means he took a deep breath.
You're the only one who can stop him.
You mean, we're the only ones who can
stop him, right?
Kinkaju said.
I was sort of hoping you would do it
Turtle admitted.
Turtle?
She nudged him, so he teetered sideways.
I totally would, but I'd rather do it
with you.
Saving the world is more fun, plus also
less terrifying with friends.
She gave him a sweet smile that made him
extremely nervous about what Anemone's
love spell might be doing to her brain.
I am not a heroic dragon.
Turtle protested.
I don't have good ideas.
I'm lazy, and I hide when bad things
happen.
Waking me up was a good idea, Kinkaju
said brightly, and look, you're not
hiding.
You're right here, where the bad things
are, and you left Jade Mountain to find
me and Moon and the others.
That's not lazy or hiding either.
I was following peril, Turtle pointed
out.
If I'm anything in the story, I may be
the hapless sidekick.
Awesome.
Kingachu leaped to her feet, beaming, I've
always wanted a hapless sidekick.
Okay, I don't know what hapless means, but
it sounds like happy, so I bet it's
awesome.
Let's go take him down.
She made a beeline for the door.
Wait, now?
Turtles said.
What's the plan?
Is there a plan?
You know the hapless sidekick is the one
who dies, right?
Not in our story?
Kinkaju called.
Kinkaju, where are you going?
Turtle shouted, as she barged through the
hanging orchids into the desk.
I'm going to go study him, Kinkaju
explained, as he emerged behind her, as
though this were all perfectly obvious, so
we can figure out what he's enchanted to
hypnotize everybody, and then we're going
to steal it or break it, and then
everyone will be all, ah, there's a
monster dragon trying to manipulate us.
And they'll rise up and stop him.
Done.
The day is saved.
Turtle was beginning to wonder.
Whether his problem-solving approach and
kinkajoos might be completely
incompatible. don't think it'll be that
easy.
He said, rubbing his forehead.
Why not?
You said he can't hurt me.
Kinkatu pointed out.
Wait, why can't he hurt me?
Because of the spell I put on you, said
Turtle.
Kinkaju stared at him.
Oh right, he said.
There's one more thing I should probably
have mentioned.
She bundled him back inside the healer's
pavilion.
You're an animus?
She hissed softly.
Kind of a secret one.
He said with a shrug, like, please don't
tell anybody.
I went through this already with peril
and moon and winter and Kibli.
Three moons!
Kingachu cried.
Why am I always the last to know
everything?
Well, no, he said.
That would make you 5th.
The 5th to know.
Out of all the dragons Empirea, or sixth
I suppose, if you count me.
Kinkachu considered that for a moment
with her snout scrunged up.
Cool, she said finally.
All right, that's not too bad.
But next time you have a major enormous
secret, tell me first, okay?
Okay, he said.
Maybe I should mention that I've cast a
spell to hide myself from Dark Stalker?
He pulled out his stick and explained
what it did, and how he couldn't cast any
more spells because Dark Stalker would
sense them, except for the one he'd
managed to hide under anemones.
So you see, he finished, I'm not actually
here in the middle of all the bad things
because I'm really actually hiding.
I'm hiding all the time.
Ooh, Kinkachu said, her eyes shining
totally invisible to dark stalker.
That is an excellent spell.
Another great idea, see?
We'll be an awesome team.
You can be the idea dragon, and I can be
the wham bam, shove a pineapple up as
snout dragon.
No, no, that won't work.
I think his snout is enchanted.
Turtle pointed out.
To be invulnerable to pineapples?
Kinkaju asked, and burst into giggles.
Oh dear.
An image of tiny rainbow colored kinkaju
lobbing fruit and dark stalker popped
into turtle's head.
Maybe he hadn't entirely thought through
his choice of hero.
Don't worry so much, Kinkachu said
brushing his wing with hers.
Your forehead will get stuck that way.
My plan will totally work, I swear.
Or if it doesn't, we'll come up with a
new amazing plan.
Ooh, I bet this is exactly how glory felt
when she was about to save the world.
She bounded off to the doorway again.
And Turtle found himself thinking that he
couldn't imagine Queen Glory bounding, or
in fact, getting this excited about
anything.
Outside, the sky was fading into purple
dark, shadows hurrying into all the gaps
between the trees.
Turtle felt the brush of soft fur as a
sloth clambered by right over his head.
He could hear snoring coming from a few
hammocks already, and the air hummed with
a hungry buzz of dusk happy insects.
Far below them, a ring of fire smoldered
on the forest floor, encircling the
shadowy figures of dark stalker, Queen
Glory, and the others.
Kingajou let out a small growl when she
saw it.
Queen Glory doesn't usually allow that
much fire in our forest, she whispered.
There are strict rules for the night
wings about how and when, and how
carefully to use it.
She's definitely fallen for that baboon
butts act.
Spell.
Turtle reminded her, it's a spell.
Let's get closer.
Can get you wafted down toward the
gathered dragons as softly as a falling
leaf, navigating the interlocking
branches with ease.
Turtle realized that rain wings must have
some ability to see in the dark, just as
sea wings did.
He followed her.
Less gracefully and with a bit more noise
but he knew dark stalker couldn't hear
him.
They settled near the prison, outside the
fiery circle, but close enough to hear
the dragons inside it.
Damp leaves flapped in their faces, and
things scuttled away beneath their
claws.
Kinkajoo shuffled in closer to Turtle.
He could feel her wings brushing his, her
scales cool and camouflaged to a dark
black blue.
Was she really in love with him now?
She was acting exactly the same as she
always had.
But maybe that's the way she was with
everyone, no matter how she felt about
them.
Or maybe she already felt this way about
you.
Way back at school.
Turtles shook off that highly unlikely
thought.
He was not a dragon anyone would notice
or fall for, especially when he was
standing next to funny Kibley, or
handsome Winter, or kindhearted umber.
He felt a pang at the thought of his
clawmate.
If this is ever over, maybe I could use
my magic to find umber and make sure he's
all right.
Did you hear something?
Glory asked, turning to look out at the
dark in the direction of turtle and
kinkaju.
Just an orangutan, said Dark Stalker with
a flick of his tail.
I'll be able to hear the killer's minds
approaching.
I heard a noise, said Deathbringer
sounding disgruntled.
But of course, I can't see anything
because there's a fire in the way.
Trust me.
This will keep your queen safe, said Dark
Stalker.
They'll have to run through the fire to
get to her, which they are not brave
enough to do, or fly over it, which will
let us hear them coming.
Although I'll hear them coming my way
first.
Of course.
He lifted his head and stared piercingly
into the dark.
He looks like he's posing for a
portrait.
Kinkagu whispered to Turtle.
Pompous Snerdegaard, the magnificent
awaits his allegiance of doomed enemies.
Turtles smothered a laugh.
He realized that his wings were less
tense than they'd been in days and at
this, perhaps, was the best part of
sharing his burden with someone else.
He hadn't thought of chameleon, or seen
any flashes of blood in his mind, since
Kinkaju woke up.
His constant pulsing anxiety had ebbed
just a little, and cracks of hope were
sliding in.
Shh, he said anyway.
He could still hear you.
But he won't care, she answered.
I'm less than nobody to him.
She paused.
Yeek.
I don't know if I like the sound of
that.
Being less than nobody?
Being unimportant to the future?
I want to be somebody.
Somebody drag its notice and remember.
Nope, turtle thought.
Nope, nope, nope.
I gave up on that idea a long time ago.
If no one notices you, you can't let
anyone down.
Kinkachu was watching him expectantly.
Oh, he said, um, you're somebody to me.
She clasped her front talons over her
snout to hide her giggles.
Right line, she said, but you need to
work on your timing and believability.
You are, he protested.
I was thinking about something else.
Oh, now I feel very fascinating, she
joked.
I'm not sure you're taking this seriously
enough, he said sternly.
Here they come.
Dark Stalker rumbled suddenly, in a voice
like the 1st breath of a snowstorm.
I will take care of them, Your Majesty.
He stepped over the fire with his
towering legs.
The flames lapped at his scales, but left
no marks.
Turtles shivered.
The powerful night wing stalked away into
the night, the ground trembling with
every footstep.
Ha!
Anemone said merrily, from her spot in
the center of the circle, as far away
from the flames as she could get.
I feel sorry for those assassins.
I went on to run into him in a dark
forest.
In a startlingly brief amount of time
Dark Stalker came back, accompanied by
the noise of clanking chains.
As he approached the fire, Turtle
realized that he was dragging 4 dragons
behind him, all of them linked by chains
around their necks and angles.
One of them was a young female nightwing
and she was spitting mad.
Let us go.
She hissed Dark Stalker.
Who do you think you are?
Are you a nightwing or not?
Whose side are you on?
Chains.
Glory murmured.
We don't usually do chains in the
rainforest.
They're very effective though.
Deathbringer pointed out.
I much prefer seeing your enemies this
way.
Queen Glory, Dark Stalker said.
Here are the dragons who are planning to
kill you.
He stopped, and blew out most of the fire
in one long breath, leaving only a small
section of flames.
Turtle blinked away the dancing orange
spots in his vision as his eyes adjusted
back to the dark.
Would you like me to dispose of them?
Dark Stalker's voice asked, deep and
eerie in the shadows overhead.
Oh, wonderful. said the female prisoner
bitterly.
Fat lot of use you were.
She hissed to the 2 sand wing captives.
The last was another night wing, a
solidly built male, who shuffled toward
her and reached his tail to rest gently
on hers.
Wait, said Glory, I want to talk to
them.
Your fierce teeth, aren't you?
And this must be strong wings.
The female only glared back, but the male
nodded.
Listen, said Glory.
What you did cannot easily be forgiven.
You kidnapped Sonny, and you planned to
betray us to burn in the hope that my
friends and I would die, including your
own brother.
Turtle blinked at Kinkaju, then back at
the other dragons.
Brother?
Was this hissing ball of fury related to
Starflight?
No, fierce teeth snapped.
I would have kept him out of it.
Glory regarded her for a moment, as
though she wasn't sure what to believe.
Well, that's something, at least, she
said.
What was your plan here tonight?
To take the throne for a true night wing
so our tribe can have its pride back.
Fierce teeth tried to lift her shoulders
under the weight of the chains.
Oh, already taken care of, said dark
stalker.
He gave a little tug on the chain he held
and strong wings stumbled forward into an
accidental bow.
I'm going to rule the night wings now.
The ones who choose to go with him.
Glory interjected.
You can't, fierce teeth said.
You're male.
And where did you come from?
You weren't with us on the volcano, that's
for sure.
What gives you the right to rule us?
Size.
Power.
Timing, charm.
And a whole bunch of dragons who think
it's a great idea, said Dark Stalker, with
a grin.
My name is Dog Stalker.
Strong wings let out a whimper and
covered his head with his wings.
We're going to die, he said in a muffled
voice.
It was all true.
It was.
I knew it.
He's come back to kill us all.
But fierce teeth held her ground, staring
up at Dark Stalker.
Really?
She said.
From the ghost stories.
You.
In the scales, he said.
Right, she scoffed.
That's a pretty clever trick.
Show up.
Pretend to be everyone's worst nightmare
and scare them into giving you the
crown.
Well, it's not going to work on me, you
scaly worm.
I'm not even a little bit of right of
you.
Dark Stalker chuckled, rustling the
leaves in the trees.
Beast teeth, strong wings whispered.
Stop, it's him.
Don't make him mad.
It is Dark Stalker, Anemone said loudly
from behind Glory and Deathbringer, and
he could crush you with one flick of his
claw.
Maybe he should.
Given what you were planning to do to the
queen.
Deathbringer added.
If you're so powerful, then you can
handle a challenge.
Fierce teeth said to Dark Stalker
ignoring the others.
I want the night wing throne.
I think I should get to be queen.
I'm female, and I know my tribe.
I'd be better at it than some lying
stranger.
Hey, Turtle whispered to Kinkaju.
Maybe I'm wrong about dark stalker
spell.
She doesn't seem affected by it at all.
Actually, I think this is how she talks
to dragons she likes.
Kinkachu said ruefully.
Brave little fierce teeth, said Dark
Stalker.
Don't call me little, she interrupted
him.
Just because you're overgrown, doesn't
mean you can patronize me.
I was going to say.
I like your spirit.
Dark Stalker started.
Can you make that a bit more
condescending?
Fierce teeth snapped back.
He paused, and Turtle got the distinct
impression that he was trying not to
laugh.
All right.
He said at length.
You're not a dragon who likes
compliments.
I see.
So I'll be blunt.
I don't want to begin my reign as king of
the night wings by killing one of my
subjects.
Especially one who could be such valuable
asset in rebuilding our tribe.
He turned to glory.
Given the utter failure of all her
schemes so far, and her relationship to
Starflight, my proposal is this.
Grant her your mercy and give her to me.
Tomorrow, I'll take her to the Night
Kingdom with me, where she'll have no
reason to bother you anymore.
She can be my problem instead.
I will be your problem.
Fierce teeth growled.
No one gives me to anybody.
I'll go to the Night Kingdom only if I
want to.
She paused.
Narrowed her eyes suspiciously and added
What night kingdom?
Where?
The old one, said Dark Stalker, where the
tribe should have been for the last 2000
years.
You'll love it.
We'll find you something important to
do.
Hang on said Deathbringer.
She tries to assassinate glory, and her
punishment. if she gets to be a part of
your court ruling the night wings.
Makes sense to me, said Glory
thoughtfully.
She wouldn't be a threat to me anymore.
Once she has what she wants, right, fierce
teeth, and then I don't have to have
Starflight's entire family behind bars.
She took a step closer to fierce teeth.
Would you leave my rainforest, my friends
and my tribe alone if we give you this
2nd chance?
Fierce teeth glared sideways at Dark
Stalker.
Are you lying?
she demanded.
Would I really be in charge of
something?
All you want is a little power, and a lot
of respect, Dog Stalker observed.
I can give you those.
And strong wings, she interjected.
He stays with me.
Dark stalker gave strong wings an
unimpressed look and shrugged.
If you insist.
Fierce teeth tapped her claws on the
ground thoughtfully.
Strong wings still had his head covered
looking very much like a dragon who
regretted all his live choices so far.
Think about it overnight.
Dark Stalker suggested, in our lovely new
accommodations, for troublemakers.
He swept one wing toward the prison, where
turtle was sure, even a few minutes would
convince any dragon to accept alternate
offers.
Hey, what about us?
grunted one of the sand wings.
Queen Thorn gets to decide your fate.
Glory said, drawing herself up regally.
In the meanwhile, you're going in there
too.
She tossed the keys to Dark Stalker.
Dark Stalker twitched the chain, and
Strong Wings stumbled back to his feet
wings drooping as they marched inside.
All 4 prisoners disappeared, into the
forbidding gray block behind Dark
Stalker.
Glory shuddered.
That was awful, she said.
I always thought I'd like dispensing
justice more than that.
I wouldn't call that justice.
Death bringer grumbled.
We're looking for what brings peace to
our rainforest, Glory pointed out.
And for whatever gives dragons a chance
to be their best selves.
She hesitated. glancing around at anemone
who had curled up drowsily under a
mammoth fern.
Something does feel weird, though.
She added, in a lower voice, like, I'm
not entirely sure I trust my decisions
right now.
She's feeling what Kibli felt.
Turtle gassed.
Torn between dark stalker's spell and
what her own intelligence is telling
her.
Dark Stalker emerged from the prison
closing the heavy metal door with a grim
clunk behind him.
Turtle noticed that he didn't return the
keys to glory, but neither did she ask
for them.
Now that's taken care of, he said.
And your life has been saved and
everything.
I'll return to my tribe and get some
sleep.
We have a long flight ahead in the
morning.
Thank you, Glory said.
A little reluctantly, Turtle thought, or
maybe he just hoped so.
Cheer up, Your Majesty, Dark Stalker said
cheerfully.
We stopped some bad guys tonight.
Isn't that fantastic?
Just think, what kind of teamwork?
Our tribes might have ahead of us.
Wait, said Death Bringer, tilting his
head.
Didn't you say there were 5 dragons
coming to attack glory tonight?
Why were there only 4 prisoners?
Was that a moment of hesitation from Dark
Stalker?
I didn't want to alarm you.
He said slowly.
There was a 3rd sandwing.
But he fought back, and I was forced to
kill him.
If that's true, he did it very quickly.
Turtle thought, and silently.
Oh said Deathbringer.
Well, good.
That's unfortunate, said Glory at the
same time.
We should find out his name from the
other two.
I'm sure Queen Thorn will want that
information.
Indeed.
Very wise, said Dark Stalker, nodding, and
I'll take care of the body for you.
Don't worry.
Can't get you jabbed turtle in the side
and he nearly jumped out of his scales.
Lying, she whispered, pointing one clawed
dark stalker, lying, lying, super liar.
He agreed with her, but he couldn't see
the point of this lie.
What was Dark Stalker hiding now?
Very well.
We'll see you in the morning, said Glory
spreading her wings.
She and Deathbringer flew off to the
treetops, leaving Dark Stalker and
Anemone alone in the dying glow of the
embers.
Dark Stalker looked down at the sleeping
sea wing princess.
Something glinted in his eyes, something
that made turtle want to throw hiding
spells all over his sister, no matter the
risk.
He crouched closer to the damp earth
wishing he were smarter, braver, bolder.
Really any other kind of dragon than the
kind he was.
Not much longer, princess.
Dark Stalker whispered.
Soon.
It'll be your turn to change the world.
Chapter 15.
Turtle and Kinkaju spent the night in the
healing pavilion, where the healers were
pinkly at Twitter with Delight when they
discovered Kinkaju was awake.
While they checked her for any remaining
injuries, and freaked out when they found
none, Turtle wrote another note to
Kibley.
Kinkaju is awake and fine.
Please tell Tamarin.
Dark stalker taking the tribe to the old
knife kingdom in the morning.
He thought for a moment, then added
Everyone definitely under his spell
except Kinkachoo.
He hoped that was enough information as
he erased it, although he wasn't sure
what good it did for Kibli to know all
that.
Before he fell asleep, Turtle made
Kinkaju promised not to go deal with dark
stalker without him.
However, she might interpret that
phrase.
No sneaking, stealing, attacking
thwacking, or pineapples.
He begged He also asked her not to tell
Queen Glory anything.
I have to let her know I'm all right.
Kinkaju insisted.
That's fine, he said, but don't say
anything about me, or our suspicions
about Dark Stalker, or how much you know
about it, or what we might do next.
Jumping poison frogs, Kingaju said
looking exasperated.
Why not?
Because he can read Glory's mind.
Turtle pointed out, and we don't want him
to hear anything that might make him
nervous or suspicious.
After much arguing, she agreed, and
Turtle fell asleep, feeling maybe a tiny
iota less nervous than before.
At daybreak, Kingachu woke him, and they
flew to the night wing village.
As they soared through the trees, Kinkachu
tossed mangoes and bananas to turtle
chattering busily.
I visited my close personal friend, Queen
Glory last night, she said, just to let
her know I'm totally fine now.
She was so mad and so happy and so mad at
the same time.
I got a seriously serious lecture about
staying away from dangerous dragons from
now on, la, la, la, irony, but she'll
forgive me when we save the world, right?
Right?
Turtle?
Oh yes, sure, he said, through a mouthful
of banana.
He hadn't realized this was a
conversation he'd have to take an active
pardon.
I told her I want to go back to Jade
Mountain, said Kinkaju, which is true.
I do want to go back there.
I'm just going to take a quick detour to
the new Knight Kingdom on the way and not
mention that part to her until later, like
way much later.
Like, maybe when we were 100.
Do we have to go to the Night Kingdom?
Turtle asked.
Maybe there is another way to stop Dark
Stalker.
From here?
No, I figured it out, Kinkachu said.
I was thinking about it last night.
This is all about Moon's prophecy.
It's right there in the words.
He's the thing that shakes the earth and
scorches the ground.
Right?
So we have to save Jade Mountain by
finding the lost city of night.
And that's where Dark Stalker is going.
So we just follow him there and boom
catastrophe averted.
Everybody safe.
Why are you rubbing your forehead again?
No reason, said Turtle.
He'd read enough scrolls to know that no
heroic quest was ever that easy, but he'd
also spent enough time with Kinkaju to
realize that it wouldn't do any good to
tell her that.
Dark Stalker had been busy in the night.
When they arrived at the village, they
discovered that he'd already packed, or
made someone pack, several nets full of
food from the rainforest.
He stood on glory's platform, counting
the supplies gathered below him as night
wings gradually filled the clearing and
whispering clumps of twos and threes.
I wonder how many of them are going with
him, Kinkaju said, swooping down to land
at the back of the crowd.
Turtle touched down beside her, folding
in his wings and ducking his head, to
avoid the funny looks he was getting from
the rest of the night wings.
I bet most of them, he said.
Wouldn't you follow a king who could give
you superpowers?
No way, Kinkachu said, with fierce
loyalty.
Queen Glory is perfect.
I want her to be my queen forever and
always.
Moon, she shrieked suddenly, spotting her
claw mate as Moon passed by with her
mother.
Moon jumped nearly the height of a small
tree and turned around.
Her face lit up like a 1000 dragons
shouting an aquatic at once.
Kinkajou?
She cried.
They barreled into each other, wings
overlapping in a ferocious hug, voices
overlapping as they both tried to talk at
once.
You're awake.
Moon yelped through tears.
You're all right.
I've been so worried.
You did everything cool without me
Kinkaju said at the same time.
I can't believe all the amazing things
you've been doing without me.
I was going to come check on you today
Moon said.
Wiping her eyes.
After dog stalker leaves, I would have
come yesterday, but I've been busy trying
to convince as many night wings as I can
to stay here in the rainforest.
She sighed.
I'm not exactly the best spokes dragon
now.
Nobody particularly liked me before, and
they don't like me much better, now that
I've returned with mind reading powers
and the dark stalker.
I like you enough to make up for 10,000
grumpy dragons.
Kinkachu promised.
Moon smiled at her shyly, like that was
still hard for her to believe.
What did you tell them?
Turtle asked.
I thought you liked Dark Stalker.
I do, Moon said.
He's been great so far.
But Queen Glory is the best thing to
happen to this tribe in 2000 years.
She's fair and generous, and she's given
them a safe place to live.
Nightwings have always been afraid of
living somewhere the ice wings could find
them, in case the old war flares up.
The Queen Glory made sure there was a
truce with Queen Glacier 1st thing, to
keep the tribe safe.
She shook her head.
I think Queen Glory has proven herself to
be a just and kind queen.
We don't know anything about dark stalker
or what kind of king he would be.
I feel like this is all happening too
fast.
Turtle noticed that several night wings
had edged closer, pretending not to
listen, but clearly listening to Moon.
And plus, also, Kingaju chimed in, don't
forget the part where he's totally evil.
Moon raised her eyebrows.
He's not evil, she said, not like Scarlet
was.
If he were evil, wouldn't I have seen it
in his thoughts?
You've seen the thoughts he wanted you to
see, said Kinkaju.
Right?
He can totally shield the rest of them
can't he?
The evil thoughts?
Moon lifted her head to look over the
crowd at Dark Stalker.
He had his head bowed, and was absent
mindedly shredding a mauve flower that
had grown up at the edge of the stage.
Maybe, she said.
But I think he's really trying to help
even if I wouldn't do it the way he's
doing it, I think he just wants his try
back, the way it was before.
Kinkaju opened her mouth, and Turtles
stood on her foot to hush her up.
If moon were under a spell, telling her
about it wouldn't do any good, it was
encouraging, though, that she could
choose glory over dark stalker, despite
whatever spells he was using on her.
Was Dark Stalker upset when you told
him?
He asked.
He said he understands, she said, and
that he expects me to change my mind.
Ha!
Not likely.
Kinkatoo gave Moon another hug.
So, what are you going to do now?
Go back to school?
Moon said with a sigh.
It feels a little weird with everything
happening.
But that's what Queen Glory wants me to
do.
And that's where Kibli and Winter are, and
you guys will be there too, right?
Sure.
Eventually.
But don't you want to see the old knight
kingdom first?
Kinkachu asked.
Maybe just a quick visit before we go
back to Jade Mountain?
Why would we do that?
Moon asked.
No reason.
Kinkatu glanced around and whispered
loudly, except maybe a prophecy reason?
Moon flicked a fat green beetle off her
tail and tipped her head at Kinkaju.
I kind of do want to see it, she said.
I mean, I have been thinking about the
prophecy, but I don't understand how
going there will stop anything from
happening.
You never know until you try, Kinkaju
said brightly.
That's settled then.
We'll all go to the Night Kingdom, not
with Dark Stalker, though.
Definitely not with him.
More like, right behind him.
Yes?
Yes.
Settled.
Woo!
I thought it was going to be much weirder
to try explaining why I was in the Night
Kingdom, but if I'm there with you, my
gifted and awesome clawmate, then it
makes total sense.
I'm not sure.
Moon began, but the crowd suddenly parted
and Dark Stalker came striding through
straight toward their little group.
Turtle felt himself shrinking as the
Nightwing loomed over them.
Kinkaju, on the other talon, seemed to be
trying to make herself look bigger.
She spread her wings and puffed up her
chest, and fixed dark stalker with her
fiercest stare.
Moon, Dark Stalker said quietly.
Lost chance.
Come with us.
He hesitated, dipped his head toward her
met her eyes.
Please.
Dark stalker, Moon said.
You are my friend.
You are, but glory is my queen.
Then come as my friend.
He said.
I could use a friend there.
And I know you will, soon, anyway.
I've had visions of us flying around the
night kingdom together.
Maybe soon, Moon said, but not this way.
She gestured at the dragons around them.
I have to make my loyalty clear.
All right, he said.
All right, it's up to you.
But come soon.
I'll be there, waiting for you.
He leaned down and bummed noses with her
then turned and strode briskly back to
the platform.
Standing behind him, revealed by his exit
was anemone.
She lifted her snout haughtily at Moon.
You don't deserve his friendship.
You're not loyal at all.
I say never come to the knight kingdom.
He'll be better off without you.
She stuck out her tongue and stomped
away.
Sorry about my sister.
Turtles said sheepishly.
She doesn't like competing for
attention.
She's not used to it.
She can have all his attention if you ask
me, Kinkachu said.
Turtle looked sideways at Moon.
Her face was somber, but resolved.
If Moon were under Dark Stalker's control
then Dark Stalker wouldn't have had to
plead with her to come with him.
She wouldn't have been able to say no.
Had she escaped his spell somehow?
Or did it work differently on her?
Or was this all a part of a larger plan
of dark stalkers?
Hello?
My fellow night wings.
Dark stalker boomed out over the crowd.
Is everyone here?
Are you ready to follow me to the
greatest place in the world?
He beckoned to a black dragon in the
front row.
She leaped up onto the platform, and
Turtle realized that it was fierce
teeth.
Whoa, he whispered to Kinkaju.
She's out of the jail already.
Do you think glory knows?
Kingaju hissed softly.
Fierce teeth positioned herself at Dark
Stalker's side, nudging anemone off to a
corner of the platform, which earned her
a glare from the sea wing princess.
My new lieutenant.
Fierce teeth will be organizing
volunteers to carry our supplies.
We'll have a feast when we get there.
Wait until you see our kingdom.
A murmur of excitement eddied around the
tribe.
Dark Stalker swept his wings wide to
encompass the entire crowd.
Our wonderful kingdom is not too far
away.
Our glorious future is on the horizon.
Come with me, night wings.
He rose into the air, just as Glory and
Death Bringer appeared from the trees.
They swooped down to the platform, and
looked up at him as he hovered above
them.
Time for all true night wings to go, Your
Majesty.
Dog Stalker said to Glory.
Thank you for watching over them for me
until I could get here.
I wish you luck with your own tribe.
He ascended into the sky, with powerful
wing beats that shook the treetops, and
dragons began to follow him.
One by one, night wings lifted off, until
the sky was full of beating black wings
lashing tails, and flashing silver
scales.
The sound of the tribe in flight rolled
like a thunderstorm across the
rainforest.
Turtle watched them in despair.
He couldn't believe so many dragons had
fallen for dark stalker already.
Barely 3 days free.
Dark Stalker now had an army at his claw
tips, and an entire kingdom to serve
him.
He became more unstoppable with every
passing moment.
There's nothing we can do, he whispered.
He's too powerful.
But not all powerful, Kinkaju whispered
back, nudging him.
Look.
She pointed to the night wings who were
still on the ground.
Moon and Deathbringer, of course, but
also at least 50 others, including, to
Turtle's surprise, Mighty Claus and his
mother.
I guess some of them actually like us
Kinkaju said proudly.
The smart ones can see how awesome it is
here.
Or they're just terrified of Dark Stalker
Turtle suggested.
Kingaju whacked him with her tail.
Still, compared to the mass exodus
overhead, what remained was nothing that
could be called a tribe.
The few night wings left, shuffled closer
together, glancing around, as though the
forest had suddenly grown bigger and
darker.
They looked like refugees from a
disaster.
Which they are.
Turtle realized, from the disaster of the
volcano first, and now, from the disaster
of a king stealing their tribe.
Maybe we should go back to Jade Mountain
after all.
Turtle said, a sense of hopelessness
creeping over him.
It's probably one of the safer places to
be with tsunami and clay there.
Until it falls beneath thunder and ice
Kinkaju protested.
Because we were too boring to save the
world?
No way, not me.
You go if you want to.
Moon and I can do everything.
Um, I think a bit more definition of
everything might be in order.
Moon said, sounding a little alarmed.
No, Turtle said glumly.
I'm staying with you.
I promised.
Nice to see that you're completely
thrilled about that, Kinkaju said with a
laugh.
Don't worry.
I'm sure it won't take long.
We'll be back at school learning math in
no time.
How does she do that?
Turtle wondered.
How can she look at the same exact thing
I'm looking at, but think, oh, here's a
problem I can solve.
Instead of everything is hopeless.
They waited until later in the morning to
leave.
Moon and Kinkaju said their goodbyes to
glory, and mighty Claus told them he'd
meet them back at school in a few days.
Fearless and mind reader and their
families had gone with Dark Stalker, and
Glory wasn't sure whether they'd be
returning to Jade Mountain.
Turtle wrote another note to Kibley.
Kingaju Moon and I are following Dark
Stalker to Night Kingdom, hopefully back
at school soon.
That was some advanced wishful thinking
there.
But maybe, if he wrote it down, it would
end up coming true.
He brushed his talons over the slate
remembering how he used to write down
everything, every passing idea or
observation, as though they were pools of
genius he had to capture before they
evaporated.
He liked the feeling of the slate pencil
in his claws again.
Maybe if I survive all of this, I could
try writing again.
It wasn't hard to follow Dark Stalker and
the Night Wings.
Even with half a morning's lead.
The tribe in flight was like a dark cloud
in the sky ahead of them.
At one point, as they flew through the
mountains, Turtle looked down and spotted
what appeared to be a small abandoned
scavenger encampment.
He imagined being one of those little
creatures, looking up to see literally
100s of dragons suddenly thundering by
overhead.
If he were one of them, he'd find a rock
to hide under and stay there for the next
month.
Dark Stalker led them south of Jade
Mountain, over the delta where the
winding Tail River spilled into the
Southern Sea and westward along the
coast.
Below them, waves pounded against a rocky
shoreline, and the ocean was dark gray
with hints of brilliant green where the
sun slipped through.
Turtle couldn't help thinking how easy it
would be to dive into those waves.
He could disappear into the watery depths
and leave all these dangers behind.
But he looked over at Kinkaju's gray blue
sky scales, and determined expression, and
he knew he couldn't leave her.
Dark stalker flew without stopping.
And so the tribe did too.
Although as the day wore on, they became
more spread out across the sky, with the
weakest flyers dropping farther and
farther behind.
The landscape along the coast shifted
from mountains to scrub covered hills, and
then desert as they reached the southern
edge of the kingdom of sand.
The wind up this high was chilly, but the
sun beat down mercilessly on their
scales.
Turtle tried to remember the map of Pyre
in his head, so he could figure out where
they were going.
There wasn't anything in this direction
except more sand, as far as he knew, and
then the Western Ocean.
Another island?
The sun was slipping down the sky ahead
of them, shining right into turtles' eyes
when Dark Stalker suddenly dove toward
the land, like a flock of hungry crows
the night wings swept after him.
Turtle sensed moon hesitating beside
him.
I don't want to join them.
She explained, when she caught him
looking at her.
I don't want them to think I've chosen
Dark Stalker.
This is just a visit.
I don't want to hang out with those
dragons either, Kinkaju said firmly, or
listen to another endless windbag
speech.
Let's find a spot to sleep where they
can't see us.
But where are they going?
Turtle asked, screening his eyes and
squinting west.
Why stop now?
How much farther can it be?
I have no idea, Moon answered.
They both hovered in the air for a moment
watching the faraway cloud of night wings
settle across the dunes and pebbled beach
like a black carpet flung over the
ground.
Kinkachu found a small cave facing the
ocean, that the 3 of them could just
barely squeeze into, and Moon caught them
a few crabs to eat.
It was a relief to stop and rest his
wings.
Turtle immediately brought out his
healing stone to erase the ache in his
shoulders, but it also made Turtle
anxious that he couldn't see Dark Stalker
and he had no idea what the ancient
animus would do next.
What if he wasn't really leading the
night wings to their old kingdom?
What if he was planning to smash the
entire tribe into a cliff?
That delightfully morbid image wouldn't
leave Turtle's brain as he tried to lie
down and sleep.
Moonlight poured into their cave from the
night sky, and from the silver
reflections in the sea below.
Kinkaju and Moon already had their eyes
closed, their tails intertwined.
He wondered if he'd imagined it, that
Kinkachu had maneuvered to be the one
sleeping next to him.
Her scales were warm, as though she'd
been collecting sunshine in them all
day.
And in her sleep, they'd turned indigo
and gold, with flecks of citrus green.
Carefully, reluctantly, he eased himself
away from Kinkajou's side and slid out of
the cave onto the beach.
Sand crumbled around his webbed talons
and sharp edges of broken seashells poked
his tail.
The waves looked as though they were
trying to reach out and drag him in.
His, his, Safe, shh, Hi.
He turned his head north, toward the
night wing encampment, and watched.
He did know how long he sat there, staring
at that small patch of stars, but
sometime later, he saw a vast shadow blot
them out, then soar away west.
Dark stalkers going somewhere, by himself
in the middle of the night, which means I
have to follow him.
Part three.
The Lost City of Night.
Chapter 16.
Turtle glanced up the beach at the cave
where his friends slept, but this was
just a spying mission.
He was the only one dark stalker couldn't
see, whereas, if dark stalker caught moon
and kinkaju trailing after him in the
middle of the night, there would be some
explaining to do, insignificance spell or
no insignificance spell.
He rose into the air and followed Dark
Stalker, feeling as if his heart and
stomach had traded places.
Don't be a coward, he scolded himself.
This is nothing. eavesdropping with a
cloak of invisibility, sneaking around
which is the one thing you're good at.
He thought of peril's fierce lack of
stealth, the way she always made the most
noise, or picked a fight, or accidentally
blew something up.
He missed her.
He wondered what she was doing now.
Their adventure together, setting out to
stop Scarlet, and find the rest of Jade
Winglet, had felt a lot safer and more
fun than this.
Maybe because he'd known her fire scales
could protect him, or because his magic
had still been a secret from everyone
back then.
The 3 moons lit up a ridge of jagged
mountains stabbing into the clouds ahead
of them.
For a moment, Turtle was disoriented, and
he turned to look back over his
shoulder.
But no, there were the claws of the
clouds mountains behind him.
The ones up ahead, rose out of the desert
like a wall made of shark's teeth, ending
at sheer cliffs along the ocean.
Oh, turtle thought, remembering the map
of Pyria.
There was a small peninsula that jutted
out at the southwest corner of the
kingdom of sand.
If the continent was a dragon, and that
peninsula was a talon reaching out, these
mountains were sort of like turtle's
armband.
And nobody has crossed them in 100s of
years.
Turtle wondered.
They were quite forbidding.
He wasn't sure he particularly wanted to
cross them himself.
But that was clearly where dark stalker
was going.
At one point, as they flew over land that
began sloping up into hills.
Turtle felt a sudden, buzzing shock, like
he'd been accidentally grabbed by a baby
electric eel.
What was that?
There was no way to know.
And it was over in a moment.
Turtle glanced uneasily down at the
ground below him, and hoped he was
imagining the pale flash of what looked
like bones sticking out of the earth.
Up ahead, dark stalker tipped his wings
to soar high over the peaks, and turtle
followed, gasping in the thin air.
And there was the night kingdom.
Spread out below them, outlined by
moonlight, were the ruins of an ancient
city that sprawled across the peninsula.
Much of it was hidden within canyons and
cliff faces, but at the foot of the
mountain, partially built into it, stood
a palace, or what was left of a palace.
In front of it was an overgrown square
paved in marble, and studded with bits of
toppled columns, a kind of platform had
collapsed in the center of it, and was
nearly submerged in a wild tangle of
vines.
All around the square were more ruins.
Once elegant buildings whose roofs had
caved in, statues missing heads, talons
tails, or all three.
Sculptural details worn away by weather.
Dark stalker's wing beats faltered, as he
took in the devastation below him.
He slowed to a stop, hovering outside the
palace, staring down at the square.
Bats flitted in and out of the windows
behind him, like dark thoughts scattering
into the air.
He feels like he was just here, turtle
guessed.
It's like, if I returned to the kingdom
of the sea tomorrow, and found that
everything I knew my whole life has been
destroyed, apparently overnight, and my
tribe was scattered, weakened with no
queen.
And everyone I ever loved was dead.
The giant knight wing put out one talon
and touched the overgrown wall of the
palace.
Abruptly he turned, and flew toward one
of the other stately buildings that
flanked the square.
Turtle spread his wings to follow, and
felt a sudden strange chill along his
spine, as though someone was watching
him.
He twisted in the air, searching the
palace windows.
Every shadow was full of eyes.
Every stirring of air, the quiet breath
of a hidden dragon.
Was someone still living here?
Had some night wings never left?
All those 100s of years ago?
But no one emerged, and no sound came
from within the palace walls.
Maybe he was imagining things.
This place was creepy enough to make
anyone's scales crawl.
Turtle flue after dark stalker as fast as
he could.
At 1st he couldn't figure out what this
new building was.
It had at least 3 entrances, on different
levels, although one was blocked by fall
and rubble.
Turtle also counted 5 towers, 3 of them
half tumbled away, and a trickle that
looked as though it might once have been
a waterfall.
Dark Stalker flew to the uppermost
entrance and paced inside, ducking his
head slightly to avoid cracking it on the
high ceiling.
And here, in the spiral hallways, there
were clues, large rooms lined with tables
broken slates on the floor, displays of
awkward, crumbling clay statues that
looked as though they'd been molded by
dragonettes.
Because they were.
Turtle realized.
This is a school.
Why would Dark Stalker come to a ruined
night wing school in the middle of the
night?
If he was searching for something of
power, wouldn't it be at the palace?
Or if he was looking for something of his
own, something he missed, wouldn't it be
wherever he used to live?
Turtle realized that he had no idea how
old Dark Stalker had been when Clearsight
put the sleeping spell on him.
He'd always imagined an older dragon
close to the age of the queen he was
trying to replace.
Dark stalker stopped at a turn in the
corridor, brushed aside cobwebs and dust
and uncovered a painting.
It was hard to make out the subject under
the accumulated dirt of centuries, but
Turtle thought it might have been a
portrait of someone.
Dark stalker traced to the outer edge of
it with his claws for a moment, and then
he put one talon on the center of the
canvas.
Senturies of dust swirled away in a
sudden blast, making turtles' eyes
water.
He clapped his talons over a snout to
stop himself from sneezing.
When he looked up again, blinking away
tears, he saw that dark stalker had used
his magic to restore the painting.
Now it looked the way it must have looked
in his time, brand new.
The colors and lines still sharp.
It was a portrait of a female night wing
seated with her wings folded back, gazing
out at the viewer.
Behind her, a web of fiery lines
crisscrossed the sky, like a pattern in
the stars, with smaller falling stars in
between the lines.
For the most part, it was not a great
portrait.
The proportions were all wrong
particularly in the undersized talons and
oversized head.
But there was something in her eyes that
made you look twice.
Something that made you think this dragon
truly loved the painter.
Could that be Clearsight?
Turtle wondered.
Dark Stalker stared at her for a long
moment before pulling himself away and
continuing on.
Turtle followed him through the spiraling
labyrinth of the school, until finally
they emerged in a central courtyard.
Classrooms looked out on the courtyard on
all sides, and it wasn't hard to imagine
being a student here, eating lunch under
the trees, or practicing your flying.
Turtle had to navigate the tangles of
vines, shrubs, and tall grass carefully
to avoid getting stuck.
The dark stalker's huge talons, crushed
all the undergrowth in his path, as he
strode to a spot under a towering pine
tree.
Here he stopped.
He bowed his head.
His wings slowly drifted down to droop
beside him.
Long heartbeats passed.
What is he thinking about?
Turtle wondered.
And why here?
He inched closer, although it made his
scales run cold, to step through dark
stalker's shadow.
It was an eerie, unsettling kind of
spying, to stand right in front of a
dragon, and know he couldn't see you?
Also that if he did, you'd be dead.
A silver scale shone on Dark Stalker's
face, then slipped down his snout to
splash on the ground.
Oh, Turtle realized, with an awful twist
in his heart.
He's crying.
He did not know how to feel about that.
Sympathy for dark stalker?
He couldn't afford that.
Could he?
Not if he wanted to stay strong enough to
stop him.
But this is the real dark stalker.
He's not performing for anyone right
now.
He's just really sad.
Turtle glanced around, wishing he knew
what to do.
Here, perhaps, was a dragon who could be
reasoned with.
Here was a dragon who might tell the
truth, if he had the right audience to
say it to.
That idea, combined with the eerie
experience outside the palace, led Turtle
to a crazy thought.
There was another kind of story Turtle
used to read when he was younger, ghost
stories.
Spirits of the Dead, coming back to haunt
those who wronged them, lost loves
lingering around the ones who held their
heart and life.
Did dark stalker believe in ghosts?
Turtle backed cautiously away, scanning
the ground for something he might be able
to use.
Dark Stalker couldn't see him or hear him
as he moved around, but he'd be able to
see something turtle left behind.
The moonlight glinted off something small
and shiny, tucked in the hollow of a
nearby tree.
Turtle reached in, digging through the
moss, and found a stash of beautiful
marbles and different colors, blues and
greens, and silvery blacks.
He glanced back at Dark Stalker and chose
a white marble with a sea blue heart.
It looked like a tiny moon, and he
thought it would be the most visible in
the dark grass.
Is this stupid?
Is this the stupidest thing I've ever
done?
He hesitated.
But all he wanted to do was see how Dark
Stalker reacted, if at all.
He'd still be as hidden as ever.
He'd be careful.
Dark Stalker might just think he hadn't
noticed it before.
He crept forward on trembling talons
until he was almost under dark stalker's
nose.
He waited until the huge night wing wiped
his eyes and glanced up at the sky in a
flash.
Turtle set the marble down an inch from
those massive claws and back away.
Nothing happened for a moment.
Dark Stalker was still looking at the
moons, but then he lowered his head again
with a sigh, which caught in his throat
when he saw the marble.
He snatched it up in his claws and stared
around the garden.
His gaze passed right through turtle
making turtle feel like a skewered moth.
Clear sight.
Dark stalker whispered.
He cleared his throat and tried again, a
little stronger.
Clear sight.
The wind murmured through the shadows
scattering pine needles across dark
stalkers' wings, and breathing evergreen
air in turtle's direction.
Clear sight, Dark Stalker said, stepping
out into the moonlight.
If you're here, speak to me.
Please.
Please speak to me.
He waited, with an expression of such
hope that Turtle was filled with guilt.
Then listen, Dark Stalker said after a
while.
I won't hurt you.
I would never hurt you.
I forgive you.
I know you were scared.
I saw everything you were afraid of, in
that last moment when you, when you put
the bracelet on me.
He hesitated, and his voice cracked as he
added, I'm sorry, I put that spell on
you.
He closed his eyes and rubbed his
forehead with his talons.
What spell?
Turtle wondered.
What kind of dragon puts a spell on
someone he loves?
Then he remembered the love spell on
Kinkaju, and wanted to claw his own face
off.
If you come back to me.
Dark Stalker said, sadly, softly to the
shadows.
I promise.
I'll never enchant your mind again.
I promise I'll listen to you this time.
We can choose the best future together.
He let out a small laugh.
I could use your help with what you've
left me, a ruined city.
A week and broken tribe.
You'd be their queen clear sight.
Doesn't that sound all right now?
When you can have the crown without
anyone having to die.
It was just waiting for us clear sight.
He started to pace.
You should have to help fix this.
Do you see what you did when you betrayed
me?
It's all gone.
Our tribe's power, our kingdom.
Our beautiful future.
You did this to our whole tribe, not just
to me.
Dark Stalker's breath was ragged.
His jaw clenched, and his claws ripped at
the plants and grass, killing everything
in his wake.
Clear sight, he said.
I I keep looking at all my new possible
futures.
Millions of possibilities.
But they're all empty.
They're empty without you.
I have no one clear sight.
All I can see around me.
As far as the future unrolls, are slaves
and soldiers.
Turtles shivered involuntarily.
Slaves and soldiers.
Is that how he sees his own tribe?
Dark Stalker paused again for a long
moment, and then said, so quietly that
Turtle almost couldn't hear him.
I know you can't be out there.
You're not in any of my futures.
But please, clear sight.
Please come back.
And tell me there's still hope for us.
The next pause lasted forever, and
another 10 forever.
Turtle's talons were starting to fall
asleep, but he didn't dare move while
Dark Stalker was still listening so
intently.
Finally, Dark Stalker lifted the marble
up to glare at it, then clenched his fist
shut around it.
I'm a sentimental idiot.
You're not here, he muttered.
You could have been.
If you'd waited another day or two.
I would have made you immortal
Clearsight.
We could have been together forever.
He turned a pace back and forth under the
spreading pine branches.
He is immortal then.
Turtle had suspected it, but now he knew
for sure.
Invulnerable scales, immortal life.
The 1st spells that any young animus
would think of.
But no one would actually do them.
Between the cost to your soul and the
unforeseen risks, at least, that's what I
always thought.
So what did you do instead?
Dark Stalker hissed softly.
Did you go back to Fathom?
Did you 2 laugh at the wonderful trick
you played on me?
Did you let him cast spells for you?
He clawed at his neck as though something
sticky was clinging to it.
That sneaking serpent of a sea wing, all
high and mighty about protecting his soul
and keeping his oath, until it comes to
betraying his best friend.
Then it's sure, why not?
It's full speed ahead to sleeping spells
and conniving and lies.
He stopped, his sides heaving.
No.
He said.
You loved me.
I know that was true.
Fathom talked you into doing this to me.
He's the traitor.
He's the one I'll never forgive.
Dark Stalker hurled the marble at the
nearest tree with such force that the
trunk split down the middle.
Turtle had to scramble out of the way of
falling branches, and when he was able to
look up again, Dark Stalker had vanished
into the night sky.
Chapter 17.
Moon was awake when Turtle got back.
She was sitting on the beach, staring out
to sea. tracing shapes in the sand
without looking at what her claws were
doing, a thin thread of light on the
horizon, hinted at the sunrise about to
come, but the cold air smelled like
rain.
Why aren't you sleeping?
Turtle asked, landing beside her.
She gave him a rueful look.
I never sleep well at night.
In the rainforest, I mostly slept during
the day, and I haven't quite adjusted to
a normal dragon schedule.
She hesitated.
Although, Dark Stalker says, I'm the one
who's normal, and it's the other night
wings who need to fix themselves to
match.
Her tail flicked sand across the patterns
she'd drawn.
And I had a nightmare.
The nightmare, the one I always have.
About Jade Mountain falling.
Moon nodded.
Fire and death, and screaming, and death
it's not awesome.
You can't see anything about how to stop
it?
Turtle asked.
Any clues?
Like something we might find in the Lost
City of Night?
Moon suggested with a sigh.
Not so far.
Where have you been?
Turtle discovered that he didn't want to
tell her about what he'd seen, especially
about dark stalkers crushing sadness.
She already sympathized with him too
much.
She didn't need more reasons to want to
give Dark Stalker a hug.
She needed to see him as bad and
dangerous, so that she'd help Kinkaju
when the time came for whatever heroics
were necessary.
Just scouting out the night wings, he
said evasively, checking on anemone.
This was partly true.
As he flew over them, he had peered down
at the night wings, their black scales
blanketing the dunes, and the beach where
they slept.
He'd spotted anemone down by the ocean
sleeping as close to the sound and scent
of the waves as you could get.
You're a good brother, Moon said.
No, I'm not, he protested, and she looked
startled at his vehemence.
Don't say that.
I'm a terrible brother.
Great heavens, turtle, Moon said
blinking.
That's not true at all.
You're following her to the end of the
continent, aren't you?
To make sure she's all right?
I'm following Dark Stalker.
I know anemone's not all right.
And that's my fault, and there's nothing
I can do about it.
Trust me, he said.
I'm the worst brother a dragon could
possibly have.
Moon studied him for a long moment, with
a faint frown on her face.
I had a vision about you once, she said.
About me?
Turtle snorted.
Was I hiding at the bottom of the ocean?
Because that's what I see in most of my
possible futures.
Now.
I'm not sure whether to tell you about it
she said.
It was a little scary.
Turtle dug one of his talons into the
beach, and let the sand fill in over it
until it disappeared.
With dark stalker around, probably
everyone had a scary future ahead.
I think you should tell me, he said.
You were on a beach, she said, her voice
getting softer, nearly swallowed by the
rush of the waves, and you were attacking
anemone.
Turtles stared at her.
Why would I do that?
I don't know.
She said.
You had her pinned down.
That's all I saw.
Why are you just telling me now?
he asked.
One of the crescent moons was reflected
in her eyes.
I didn't want to scare you.
I was worried it might happen because you
use your magic too much, and lose your
soul.
Turtle's claws twitched, as though they
were reaching for someone's throat.
He tried to imagine them sinking into
anemones scales, drawing his sister's
blood.
The screaming battered night wing flashed
through his mind again, along with a
whisper, you have violence in you.
But that was different.
I would never hurt my own sister.
His claws curled inward, as though they
disagreed with him.
It might not come true, Moon said.
Dark Stalker says, our visions are only
the most probable futures, but things can
always go in a different direction.
Turtle jumped to his feet.
Clenching and unclenching his talons.
I'm sure it won't happen.
I'm a bad brother, but not that
terrible.
He didn't want to think about this
anymore.
He didn't need one more thing to worry
about.
Movement on the horizon caught his
attention, and he looked up to see black
wings ascending into the sky.
They're moving.
I'll get Kinkachu.
Turtle ran up the beach and poked his
nose into the cave, nudging Kinkaju in
the side.
No.
Kinkaju mumbled from under her wings.
Time to go, Kinkaju, he said.
Go away.
Bromiliad.
Kinkaju grumped in her sleep.
You smell like fish and I don't want to
train today.
Turtle felt a stab of affection for her
for this grouchy, sleepy side of her he
hadn't seen before.
She was so real, and so kind, and so
present.
She was the opposite of a terrifying
vision of his future.
It's me, turtle.
He said, brushing one of his wings over
hers.
Come on, Kinkachu, wake up.
Turtle.
Kinkachu sighed dreamily, and clouds of
light pink started drifting through her
scales.
Turtle pulled his wing back, feeling
sick.
So Anemone's spell really was working.
He knew this wasn't how Kinkaju actually
felt about him.
She'd be so furious and embarrassed when
she found out it was all magic.
But I can't tell her.
What if it makes her so angry?
She takes off the Skyfire.
And then Dark Stalker notices her, and
terrible things happen.
Is this why I attack anemone on some
future beach?
Because I'm angry with her about the
spell on Kinkaju?
We have to go, he said gruffly, and
whacked her with his tail.
Who's that?
she yelped, leaping to her feet and
turning red with stripes of pale green.
You want my venom?
I'll show you vent.
Oh, hi turtle.
She shook herself from head to tail.
Whoa.
That was a weird dream.
My old teacher turned into the night wing
who used to study us.
She shook herself again, harder.
Two of my least favorite dragons.
Yeesh.
Anyone would think I'm worried about
something.
The night wings are moving, Turtles
said.
We should get going too.
Oh, sure.
Kinkachu rubbed her face and then
stretched, shifting her scales through a
dazzling cascade of colors from purple to
aquamarine to saffron where they
settled.
Turtle, you're looking at me as though
I've been stabbed by a stalactite, but
haven't noticed yet.
Sorry, he said, backing out of the cave
quickly.
They watched the night wings gather in
the sky like storm clouds until the tribe
finally wheeled away west, and then
Turtle, Moon, and Kinkaju lifted off and
followed them.
The landscape looked much the same in the
light as it had the night before, and
Turtle felt the same strange zap of
energy as they flew over that spot in the
hills.
Did you?
he asked his friends, just as Kinkaju
yelped, ow, what was that?
I don't know, Moon said, glancing down.
She fell silent, and Turtle wondered if
she had seen the shapes of bones below
them too.
They waited until all the night wings had
vanished over the peaks before flying
after them.
But as they came up and over the last
mountain, they found a dragon waiting for
them in the sky.
Dark stalker.
Moon.
He cried, with genuine delight.
I thought my visions were messing with me
but you did come after all.
He did a joyful flip in the air, spreading
his wings toward the city.
Isn't this amazing?
Look at our beautiful kingdom.
Oh, wow, Moon said faintly.
In the gray sunlight, Turtle could see
that the city was even larger and more
ornate than he'd realized the night
before, but he could also see more
clearly how broken it was, and how time
had eaten away at it.
The rest of the tribe had swooped down
into the ruins, diving through the
canyons, exploring their new home.
That's the great diamond down there.
Dark Stalker said eagerly to Moon
pointing at the overgrown square.
On one side is the museum.
Over there is the school, and that
building is the library.
The library moon.
I can't wait to show it to you.
It makes starflights, it'll cave at Jade
Mountain, look like a toad's den, although
it's not in the greatest shape now.
But surely some of our scrolls must have
survived.
He poked Moon with his tail, grinning.
I was hoping my visions were right, and
you'd come.
This is great.
I'm not staying, Moon said quickly.
I'm going back to Jade Mountain.
I just wanted to see it.
Me too.
Kinkaju volunteered.
Popping up behind Moon and waving at Dark
Stalker.
I'm here to see it too.
Moon's best friend, remember?
Yes, right.
Dark Stalker said dismissively.
Well, sure, Moon.
If you want to go back to Jade Mountain
that's fine.
But you might find that our school is
much better and more perfect for you.
After all, it's where I went to school.
We had classes in all kinds of things.
They'll never get to a jade mountain.
I just have to rebuild it a little.
Clean it up.
Find some decent teachers.
He frowned down at the scattered night
wings below him.
I suppose I could enchant some of them
into becoming good teachers.
He said thoughtfully.
But would your school be only for night
wings?
Moon asked.
Or would you invite students from other
tribes, like Sonny did at Jade Mountain?
Sunny is very sweet.
Dark Stalker said.
But you saw how that turned out.
It doesn't work to throw tribes together
and just hope they'll get along, because
they won't.
They can't.
Dragons don't work that way.
No matter what tribe they're from.
I get along with dragons from other
tribes, Kinkatu objected.
Moon is my best friend.
Our winglet is awesome.
I kind of like meeting the other tribes
Moon said to Dark Stalker.
They're not all like Icicle or Flame, or
poor Sora.
Well, Dark Stalker said, flicking his
tail.
Maybe one day you can organize an
exchange program.
But for now, we need to focus on
educating our own dragonettes.
We have a tribe to rebuild.
There's so much they need to learn.
Perhaps once we've solved all the
problems within our tribe.
We can start thinking about reaching out
to other tribes.
Anyway, let me give you a tour of the
palace.
He tugged on one of Moon's wings and
flashed away.
Moon gave Turtle and Kinkachu an
apologetic look, and went after him.
They followed a few wing beats behind.
He pays me no attention at all, Kinkaju
grumbled.
It's like I'm not even there.
That's good, Kikachu.
Turtle reminded her, you don't want him
to pay attention to you.
I know, she said with a sigh, but I don't
like feeling as though I've disappeared.
Like I'm not important enough to even
look at.
You're very important, Turtle said
reassuringly.
You're the hero of the story, remember?
You have to fulfill Moon's prophecy.
That's right.
She said, brightening.
We're here, in the lost city of night.
She glanced around as though she expected
a parade of cheering dragons to pop out
of the mountain.
We did it.
So, did it work?
Is the world saved?
She poked his shoulder experimentally.
Does the world feel saved to you?
Not even remotely?
Turtle admitted, watching dark soccer and
moon land on one of the balconies of the
palace.
That's the right attitude, Kinkaju said.
They swept down to land on the same
balcony, carefully avoiding the parts of
the balustrade that had caved in.
Inside, Dark Stalker was walking around
what appeared to be a giant bedroom, 8
times the size of any sleeping cave
turtle had ever been in.
These were the queen's room.
Dark Stalker said to Moon.
They're mine now, of course.
It looks like she took most of her
treasure with her when she left.
He blew some dust off an enormous mirror
and frowned at it.
It all used to be so clean and perfect.
There were grand parties every other
night, and things you would actually like
too, Moon.
Salons and scientific lectures, and
readings.
His voice trailed off as he wandered into
one of the side rooms of the suite, where
he started overturning empty chests and
opening all the cabinets, moon
disappeared after him.
Dark Stalker.
Anemone appeared in the doorway to the
hall, her talons covered in white stone
dust.
I couldn't find the rooms you were
talking about.
Oh, the doors look the same.
She spotted turtle, and her mouth dropped
open.
What are you doing here?
She hissed.
I thought you were going back to school.
Stop following me.
He's not following you, Kinkaju said
haughtily.
He's with me.
Oh.
Anemone's snout crinkled into a wickedly
sly grin.
Ah, that's wonderful.
That's so, so cute.
You guys are so cute together.
She lowered her voice, although not far
enough, and whispered to Turtle, you're
welcome.
Moon heard this as she came back into the
room.
She gave him and anemone a surprised
look.
Turtle hoped the floor was about to
collapse and take him with it.
Wait, you're here too?
Anemone said to Moon, lashing her tail.
Do you just keep changing your mind about
who you're loyal to?
He doesn't need you, you know.
He has me.
We are not staying long, Moon said
uncomfortably.
What is it, anemone?
Dark Stalker asked, slithering back into
the main room.
Turtle wondered if he was imagining the
hint of weary impatience in dark
stalker's voice.
You said there was a perfect suite for me
remember?
Anemone said, in her wheedling whining
princess voice, but I couldn't figure out
your directions, and I can't find it.
Oh, dear.
I'm so sorry for straining your tiny sea
wing brain.
He said.
Anemone didn't even look offended.
The insult seemed to sail right past
her.
Come on, I'll just show you.
She jumped out of his way as he thumped
past, and Turtle noticed that the doors
in this palace were so big.
Dark Stalker didn't even have to duck as
he went through.
They all trailed after Dark Stalker
through the long black marble halls of
the palace, many of which opened onto
courtyards, or balconies, or grand halls
far below them.
Turtle had always thought the deep palace
of the sea wings was the most luxurious
imposing castle in all of Pyria, but he
guessed that at least 5 of them would fit
inside this place.
Anemone might have been thinking the same
thing, because she said jealously, you
know, our palace has a lot more artwork
and treasure, lots of jewels everywhere.
Dark soccer paused and ran one claw
through the dust on one of the walls.
There used to be artwork and treasure
here too, he said thoughtfully.
I'm surprised the queen was able to take
so much of it with her.
He paused.
Unless she didn't.
His eyebrows drew down menacingly.
Unless another tribe came in here later
and looted the palace.
He whirled toward Moon.
Which try would you say is the
wealthiest?
The wealthiest?
Moon said.
I don't know.
I mean, how would anyone know that?
Which tribe has the most treasure?
he asked edgily.
What would you guess?
I don't need exact numbers.
In all those scrolls of yours, which
queens buy the most extravagant things
which castles are the most full of
jewels.
He shot anemone, a suspicious look.
Um, all of them?
Except the rain wings.
Moon said awkwardly, but maybe the sky
wings have a lot because of scarlet, and
the sand wing treasury was supposed to be
one of the greatest in the world before
the war, and the whole lie about the
scavengers stealing all of it.
Sandwings.
Dark Stalker hissed.
They barely hide any treasure in my
time.
It must have been them.
He wrapped the wall with one claw and
turned away again.
All right.
Anemone, come along.
Princess anemone. she said, tossing her
head.
Dark Stalker sped up, whisked around a
corner, and threw open a huge set of
black doors.
Here you go, he said, with a strange
gleam in his eyes.
The perfect suite for you.
Decorated with a sea wing in mind, 2000
years ago.
In fact, your own ancestors stayed in
these very rooms.
Fathom?
Turtle blurted.
Anemone looked curiously from him to Dark
Stalker, expecting an answer.
Kinkaju jumped in quickly.
Was that Fathom?
she asked.
Yes.
Dog stalker said.
He glanced at Moon and steeled his face
as though hiding his true feelings from
her.
He stepped through into the main bedroom
his black eyes studying every inch of the
space.
This is where our queen put him.
When she brought him over from the
kingdom of the sea, to educate me about
the perils of animus magic.
Oh, Anemone stepped around him and
sneezed.
Huh.
This is it?
It's not what I pictured.
She peered into a dry, cracked pool in
the floor.
Her tail bombed one of the tattered, moth
eaten cushions, sending up a halo of dust
and she sneezed again.
So, use your magic to clean it up, Dark
Stalker said impatiently.
Or better yet, learn how to use a mop and
your own claws.
Where does Moon get to stay?
Anemone demanded.
Wherever she likes, Dog Stalker
answered.
If she decides to stay, that is.
He turned to Moon with a smile, let's go
see how the gardens have turned out.
He bounded out the door again, but Moon
lingered for a moment after he left.
I think the room is really nice, Anemone
she said.
It has a balcony and everything.
You would think it's nice, said Anemone.
You grew up in a gross muddy fern gully
in a rainforest.
I am a princess.
I have always lived in a palace, and I've
never had to clean my own room.
The idea.
I've never had to clean my room either.
Kinkaju volunteered.
I mean, I don't have a room, but I have a
hammock.
Sometimes I shake it really hard to get
all the leaves and bugs out.
Does that count?
Moon.
Dark Stalker called.
Anemone stamped her foot.
Why doesn't he want to show me the
gardens?
She scowled at Moon?
The minute you show up, suddenly you're
the only dragon he wants to talk to.
I don't see what's so special about you.
Nothing at all.
Moon said.
I'm just the 1st dragon he met when he
woke up.
I'd better go.
She took a step backward.
No, Anemone barked.
If you're so wonderful and amazing.
Why don't you clean my room?
She grabbed a talon full of loose pebbles
from the floor.
Turn into a bucket of water and a mop, she
ordered, and instantly a long mop and a
pail of water appeared in her claws.
She held up the mop and pointed at Moon.
Now go hit that dragon really hard until
she starts using you to clean this place
and don't let her stop until I say it's
done.
Chapter 18.
What?
Kinkachu yelped.
Anemone!
Turtle cried.
The mop sailed across the room and
wrapped moon sharply on the snout as she
tried to back away.
Ow, moon cried, fending it off.
Stop.
The mob evaded her talons and whapped her
again.
Tears of pain sprang into Moon's eyes, and
she grabbed the handle, wrestling it down
to the floor.
What are you doing?
She shouted at anemone.
I'm not going to let you hurt me.
Neither am I. Kinkachu yelled.
She dashed over and threw herself on the
mop, helping moon pin it to the ground.
Anemone, Turtle said helplessly.
Stop this.
But his sister was busy scooping up
another talon full of pebbles.
Turn into opals and sapphires, she
ordered them, and go distract Dark
Stalker, so he doesn't come looking for
her.
She opened her claws, and a glittering
constellation of blue and iridescent gems
shot out the door, tumbling over one
another in the air.
There anemone said, satisfied.
Now he won't come rescue you.
And hey, he did say I should use my magic
to clean up, just stop fighting and do
it.
She made a sweeping gesture with one
talon, and the mob's long handle shot
upright, cracking kinkaju in the jaw.
Yowch!
Kinkaju roared.
Turtle jumped forward, but he didn't know
what to do.
Should he cast a spell?
Would it be hidden by Anemone's other
magic in here?
What could he do?
Enchant the mop?
Or enchant anemone?
But then she'd know he was an animus.
This seemed like perhaps not the best
time to reveal that.
Still, he had to do something to help
Kinkaju and Moon.
What would the hapless sidekick do in
this situation?
A heartfelt speech.
There was always a right thing to say
wasn't there?
Even the sidekick sometimes got a decent
useful speech, he could talk her down.
She was his sister after all.
Anemone.
Think about what you're doing, he started
his voice cracking.
Blah, blah, blah.
Anemone said, flapping her claws at him.
Quit your jellyfishing turtle.
I'll let your girlfriend and her annoying
friend go in a minute.
I just don't get what Dark Stalker sees
in Moon, do you?
She's nobody special.
Not like me.
A slow smile spread across her face.
Maybe I just need to make him realize
that.
Anemone swept over to the dry fountain
and fished something out of it, some kind
of small device that looked like a
telescope and an hourglass stuck
together.
What in the moons is this?
Anemone turned it over in her claws for a
moment, shrugged, and tossed it aside.
She plucked a piece of broken tile out of
the pool.
Turn into an earring, she commanded the
tile.
Something really sparkly and cool that
dark stalker would like.
A twisty silver snake with ruby eyes
appeared in her talon.
Perfect.
Now, earring, as soon as Dark Stalker
puts you on, I want you to make him stop
caring about Moon at all.
She'll be just another random dragon
bothering him, and I'll be the only
dragon he finds interesting.
You can't do that to him, Turtle said.
Can you?
Would a spell like that even work on Dark
Stalker?
If it did, maybe it would be a good
thing.
Maybe it would help Turtle get Moon away
from Dark Stalker's influence.
Maybe it would keep her safer from him
than she would otherwise be.
I should enchant that earring too, he
realized suddenly.
But with what spell?
What's the right spell to put on Dark
Stalker if I had the chance?
Another sleeping spell?
Or something to make other dragons see
him the way he really was, a spell to
make him reveal all his secret plans, or
a spell that could kill him.
Could I really do that?
Is that what he deserves?
His brain offered up a flash of a lonely
dark stalker in the school gardens last
night, missing his lost love, and then
another flash of blood staining his own
claws.
Am I a dragon who could kill someone?
Anyone?
Even him?
If I did, would that tip my soul into
darkness?
Is that the choice I make that leads to
me attacking my sister on a beach?
You, you jackdaw!
Kinkatu yelled at anemone, coiling her
tail around the mop and leaning on it
with all her weight, you overripe melon.
Next to her, moon was struggling
silently.
You're being absolutely horrible.
Kingaju yelled.
Oh, turtle, is this her losing her soul?
Is she turning evil?
Is it?
Turtle thought with horror.
He'd stopped worrying about that after
she put on the silver necklace, but if it
didn't work.
Or if the spell on it wasn't quite what
she thought it was.
Ha!
Anemone cried.
I'm not evil.
My soul is protected, remember?
I've seen evil.
This isn't evil at all.
This is just a princess dealing with one
of her pesky problems.
She held up the earring and dangled it in
Moon's direction.
What else should I do with my magic, do
you think?
Ooh, I can make him give me the queen's
rooms.
Or I could make him build me my own
palace right next to this one.
She breathed out a contented sigh and
touched her necklace.
Life is so much easier now that I can do
anything I want.
I wouldn't be so sure of that.
Moon said, looking over Anemone's
shoulder.
Anemone.
Dark Stalker's menacing voice rumbled
like an earthquake rising through
turtle's claws.
Explain yourself.
The enormous Nightwing stepped through
the door and made a gesture toward Moon.
The mob clattered to the ground, harmless
once more.
Kinkachu put one wing around Moon.
Anemone swung around to Dark Stalker with
a sweet, practiced smile on her face.
There you are.
Oh, this is nothing.
Don't worry.
I was trying to clean up, and the mop
went a bit haywire, and these 2 decided
to tackle it, so weird.
But look, I found this really cool
earring in one of the side tables.
Isn't it perfect for you?
Liar!
Kinkaju yelled.
The Dark Stalker ignored her.
He stepped forward to loom over anemone
and she backed into a wall, babbling.
I mean, the king of the night wing should
really wear the best jewelry, don't you
think?
I don't accept gifts, from animus dragons
he growled, especially from deceitful
conniving sea wings.
What kind of idiot do you think I am, that
I would fall for a trick like that?
It's not a trick.
Anemone protested.
It's just a pretty earring.
Squid guts.
You don't have to be so paranoid.
She laughed nervously.
Spare me your lies.
Dark Stalker spat.
I heard everything.
He uncurled his talon, scattering the
dust of gemstones at her feet.
You thought these baubles would distract
me so you could hurt Moon.
He snatched the earring out of her
claws.
You plan to manipulate my emotions, to
cast a spell on me.
Just a little one, Anemone stammered.
I just want you to be my mentor and only
pay attention to me, that's all.
Don't be angry at her dark stalker, Moon
said.
Her sides heaving as she caught her
breath.
She's young.
It was just a mistake, and I'm fine.
I will not have dragons stolen from me.
Dark Stalker snarled.
Not ever again.
He reached one talent toward moon and
Kinkachu, and made an odd circling motion
with his claws.
Instantly moon stopped moving, as though
she'd been frozen, staring forward
blankly with unblinking eyes.
Kingachu let out a small gasp and reached
toward her friend.
Oh, no, Turtle thought frantically, that
spell is supposed to be on Kinkachu too.
Dark Stalker is going to notice that his
magic doesn't work on her.
Dark stalker frowned at Kinkaju, then
down at his talon.
Turtle hissed, catching Kinkaju's
attention, and pretended to freeze in
place.
Light dawned in her eyes.
When Dark Stalker reached toward her
again, she immediately froze where she
was, mimicking Moon's blank stare.
Good.
Turtle thought, although his heart was
still pounding.
Now hold that.
Don't give yourself away.
Luckily, Dark Stalker turned his back on
Kinkaju almost immediately, focusing his
attention on anemone.
It's time for you to go, princess.
He growled.
What do you mean, go?
Anemone cried.
Go where?
She glanced anxiously at Moon and
Kinkaju.
What did you do to them?
They don't need to hear this part.
Dark Stalker said softly.
It's time for you to go back to the
kingdom of the sea.
What is he doing?
Turtle thought in a panic.
Is he putting a spell on my sister?
But I don't want to.
Anemone stamped her foot.
I hate it there.
I want to stay with you and learn about
being an animus.
You know all you need to know.
Dark Stalker said.
His voice seemed to be getting colder and
darker.
Like water from the deepest ocean depths
curling slowly into turtles' ears.
You know what albatross did.
You know how easily you could be queen.
You know that nobody can stand in your
way.
If you decide to go take the sea wing
throne, right now, is...
Is that what you want me to do?
Anemone asked.
I don't care what you do, said Dark
Stalker.
I was beginning to think you could be a
worthy student.
And perhaps I should keep you around
after all.
I thought you might, be someone who could
work alongside me.
He glanced at Moon, then fixed his cold
black eyes on anemone.
But I was an idiot.
To let any affection for you creep in.
You are truly Fathom's descendant.
You're just as bad as he is, and I don't
want you anywhere near me.
I can't help ping Fathom's descendant
anemone cried.
I'm sorry, all right?
I won't try to cast any more spells on
you, I promise.
It wouldn't have worked anyway.
Dark Stalker said, flicking the earring
at her.
It bounced off her forehead and skidded
across the floor.
None of your spells will ever work on
me.
I protected myself from your magic.
Now get out.
Go kill your mother if you want.
Feel free to kill any other dragons who
stand in your way.
He made the circling motion with his
claws again.
Moon took a breath in, glancing around as
though mildly puzzled, and Kingachu
imitated her a moment later.
You won't be able to hurt Moon anymore
Dark Stalker said, sweeping one wing
toward the doorway, so don't even try.
This isn't fair, Anemone yelled.
It's not fair.
She bolted toward the balcony instead.
Then turned back, framed by the gray
light outside.
I'll show you how special and important I
am.
You'll see.
She flung herself into the air.
Anemone.
Turtle's chest ached, as though all his
guilt had become bolders piled on his
heart.
This is my fault.
I can't believe she did that.
Kinkachu said.
Moon, are you all right?
Did she cast any spells on you?
Dark Stalker asked gently.
Not on me.
No.
Moon said, in a shaky voice.
I don't think so.
Just on the mop and the earring.
Three moons.
I didn't realize how upset she was with
me.
Did you see that in her mind?
She asked Dark Stalker.
A little.
But I didn't think it would escalate so
quickly either, he said.
Are you having a vision?
Moon touched her temples.
I have a vision headache, but nothing
clears coming through.
Or maybe you have a headache because you
just got whacked in the head with a mop
handle.
Kinkaju suggested it sensibly.
No, it's, I think it's some danger in the
kingdom of the sea, Moon said.
Her worried eyes met turtles.
Cold terror ran through him.
Was anemone really going back home, right
now, to kill mother and steal the
throne?
She wouldn't do that.
He thought.
And at the same moment, this new anemone
might.
This anemone who wants everything, who
believes it should be hers, this anemone
who uses her magic for selfish reasons
who wants to impress dark stalker, this
anemone, who acts as though her soul is
damaged after all.
The enchantment Dark Stalker did on her
necklace.
What if it was a lie?
What if it didn't protect her soul?
What if she'd been losing it bit by bit
with each spell she cast?
Including the one I asked her to cast on
Kinkachu?
Turtle thought with a wince.
If that was true, the same thing could be
happening to anemone that happened to
albatross, their murderous ancestor all
those centuries ago, and she could be
flying home to follow in his footsteps
right now.
Chapter 19.
I have to go after her, Turtle said, my
tribe, my family.
Kingaju took a step toward him.
The dark stalker was already folding his
wings around her and moon.
Now, let's go see the gardens. he said
and put all this unpleasantness behind
us.
But what if anemone does something
terrible, Moon said to him, shouldn't we
follow her?
He looked down at her with sad eyes.
In all the futures, I see.
Following her only makes it worse.
You and I are the last dragons she wants
to see right now.
But there's a good chance, she'll get
tired after half a day of flying.
Stop at Jade Mountain and stay there, safe
and harmless.
I think that's the most likely future.
Turtles pounding heart disagreed.
What if everything Dark Stalker said to
her was a spell, and I didn't recognize
it.
What if Darkstalker has enchanted anemone
to kill mother?
To punish us all, for being Fathom's
descendants.
If that's true, there's no way I can stop
her.
There's almost certainly no way I can
stop her anyhow.
But I'm the only one who can even try.
Stay with him, Turtle said to Kinkachu
although his voice was shaking.
You have to watch him.
I'll go after anemone.
By yourself?
His mind screamed.
Do you want everyone to die?
He didn't have time to write to Kibley
and Kibley wouldn't be able to help him
anyway.
Neither Kibley nor Kinkaju could follow
him into the ocean.
If that was really where anemone was
headed, only Sea Wings could go as far
underwater as the Deep Palace.
He stepped onto the balcony and glanced
back.
Another part of him was screaming, don't
leave Kinkaju here.
It's not safe.
What if he notices there's a spell on
her?
What if she's not the same when I get
back?
The 3 dragons were heading out through
the main doors of the room.
At the same moment, Kinkachu turned to
look back at him.
She gave him a reassuring smile and
flared her wings, letting them turn pink
along the edges.
Then she followed Moon out the door, and
was gone.
And Turtle was aloft, flying, flying
higher, beating his wings as hard and
fast as he'd ever flown before.
Could he catch anemone?
If he did, could he stop her from
whatever she was planning?
She was smaller than him, but fast, and
she might use her magic to make herself
faster.
Below him, the night wing city fell away
and the mountains whipped past, craggy
and jagged, like a dragon's spine, peaks
reaching out like claws to snag his
wings.
The air currents were strange in these
mountains, falling away in odd places, and
he had to concentrate more than usual to
stay aloft.
Why couldn't he see her in the sky up
ahead?
Because she was too small?
Because she blended in with a pale gray
blue clouds?
Where was she?
He burst out of the mountains and veered
east, following the same route they'd
taken that morning.
His wings were tiring already at this
pace.
There was no way he could keep it up all
the way back to the kingdom of the sea.
The sea.
Turtle looked down at the dark waves
pounding the beach below him.
Maybe he could swim part of the way
home.
Maybe that's what anemone was doing.
He tucked himself into a dive, plunging
into the water, and nearly caving in his
skull on an underwater boulder.
Careful, careful, be more careful.
Mustn't die before I get there.
Although I might die when I get there.
He found a rip current moving swiftly
east and slipped into it, spreading his
wings to catch as much of its speed as
possible.
Would anemone actually kill me?
Her own brother.
Killing Queen Coral was one thing.
That was the only way for the next queen
to take the throne, so every princess
grew up without possibility in her mind.
With the rest of the family?
If she attacked them, that would have to
mean she'd lost her soul, or she was
under dark stalker's control.
My family.
Turtle thought, powering himself forward
with talons and tail, my mother.
Coral had never loved him or been at all
interested in him, but he still loved
her.
The idea of her, and the stories she
wrote.
My brothers.
The whole restless wrestling, teasing
pack of them.
Ants, and uncles, and cousins, my
littlest sister, tiny Aucklet.
He couldn't imagine anyone hurting a
dragonette so small.
Don't do this, anemone.
Should he use his magic?
Now?
Should he try to stop her?
Dark stalker might think he was sensing
anemones magic, but what if he realized
it wasn't?
What if it made him suspicious?
Drum beats of panic were thudding around
and around in Turtle's head.
He knew this feeling.
He hated this feeling.
The pressure pounded in rhythm with his
wing strokes.
Everything is resting on me, on me, on me
and I will fail again, again, again.
Searching and searching for Snapper
knowing his father was waiting, knowing
his father was counting on him, knowing
he couldn't do it, knowing now what his
father's disappointed face looked like
and how all that disappointment would
crush turtle into a nobody.
This was exactly the same.
Except the disappointed faces would be
moons, and Kinkajoos, and Kibleys, and
the dragons who died because of him would
be his entire family.
Maybe more.
Maybe everyone, if anemone couldn't be
stopped.
The current veered north, and he went
with it, realizing he couldn't see land
off to his left anymore.
I want to run away.
I want to hide forever.
But he had no choice.
Anemone was his responsibility.
Anemone was his biggest mistake.
Once a year, in the kingdom of the sea.
Every 2 year old dragon in the tribe is
brought together for a particular
ceremony, at least, it is called a
ceremony, the talons of power ceremony.
But really, it is a test.
And smart dragonettes who've been
listening closely, know that's what it
is.
Smart dragonettes also know exactly what
the ceremony is looking for.
When he was 2 years old, a week before
the ceremony, Prince Turtle went out and
caught 2 large fish and a talon full of
shrimp.
He flew them to a rocky ledge on a
deserted island, and left them to rot in
the sun.
Five days later, he returned and ate them
holding his nose, and forcing them down
his throat.
The night before the ceremony, Prince
Turtle was dramatically violently ill in
the dining room of the Deep Palace.
It was pretty horrifying.
No one wanted to go anywhere near the
vomiting prints.
He was sent to recover on a small island
far away from civilized society, which
meant, of course, that he missed the
talons of power ceremony that year.
Queen Coral wasn't concerned.
He was just one of her many little
princes, and if he really had any magic
in his claws, which was, statistically
very unlikely.
Someone would figure it out sooner or
later.
She decreed that he could be included in
the ceremony the following year when he
was three.
But the year Turtle turned 3 was the year
his father went missing.
Captured by the Sky Wings, according to
Coral's spies, Queen Coral had spent
every moment of that year guarding her
new egg, so that a princess could finally
hatch unharmed.
She got her wish, a living daughter, but
she lost her husband.
The talons of power ceremony was canceled
that year.
So Prince Turtle was four.
By the time the next talons of power
ceremony rolled around.
No one had said anything to him about it
in over a year.
He believed they'd forgotten about
testing him, because why bother?
If he were an animus dragon, someone
would have noticed by then.
At least, that's what everyone thought.
On the day of the ceremony.
Turtle was on his way out of the Summer
Palace, with a pearl gathering party, when
a dark green dragon blocked his path.
Prince Turtle, the dragon said, in an
oily voice.
Whirlpool.
Turtle answered evenly, hiding his
dislike.
Queen Carl adored this particular advisor
and Turtle couldn't figure out why, except
perhaps that Whirlpool was an expert at
fawning over everything Coral did.
Have you forgotten what today is?
Whirlpool asked.
Your presence is required at the talons
of power ceremony.
Turtle's heart thudded hard against the
walls of his chest.
Me?
he said.
Isn't it pretty clear by now that I'm not
an animus?
Still, said Whirlpool.
Every sea wing must undergo the test
especially those in the royal family.
If animus power should happen to
resurface now, when it is so direly
needed.
We cannot let it slip past our noses, can
we?
Does he know?
Turtle wondered.
But Whirlpool always sounded like a know
it all, even, maybe especially, when he
knew nothing.
All right, he said with a shrug.
Seems like a waste of time is all.
I thought the Queen really wanted these
pearls for Anemone's new necklace.
The test will be over by midday.
Plenty of time for pearl gathering after
that, Whirlpool said.
Ushering turtle into the tunnel that led
out of the pavilion.
Turtle swam along beside him, his mind
paddling frantically.
There had to be some way out of this.
He couldn't take that test.
He couldn't let them find out what he
was.
If his mother found out.
What would she make him do?
Turtle had read every scroll he could
find on animus magic.
There weren't many.
And most of the ones that existed were
about albatross, his ancestor from
centuries ago.
Albatross, the one who built the summer
palace with his power.
Albatross, who went mad, and massacred
half his family before he was stopped.
Turtle had often tried to imagine what it
would be like if everyone knew he was an
animus.
Would they be terrified of him?
Would they always be wondering if he'd
suddenly snap and start killing dragons?
Or would they think he could be a useful
tool in the great war that was raging
across the sea?
What if Queen Coral forced him to use his
magic against her enemies?
What if she wanted him to do something he
didn't want to do?
What if he tried to do it and failed?
And dragons died because of him?
One thing was for sure.
Everyone would know who he was.
Everyone would always be looking at him.
He'd never be able to hide or blend in.
He would always have eyes on him, waiting
and judging, and expecting.
That scared him a lot more than the idea
of losing his soul.
He wasn't terribly worried about that.
His soul felt fine.
He certainly didn't feel like killing
anyone, ever.
He wasn't even sure he believed the
theory that animus dragons lost their
souls when they used their magic too
much.
Maybe Albatross had been naturally crazy
and homicidal all along, but nobody
noticed.
Still, better safe than sorry.
Better a quiet nobody than a big deal
center of attention dragon than everyone
thought would do great things.
I'll have to fool the test, Turtle
realized.
He was 4 now.
Surely he was smart enough to do that.
Whirlpool led him a long way to an island
where Turtle had never been before.
As they approached, he saw other dragons
swimming toward it.
Parents with their 2 and 3 year olds, or
members of Queen Coral's council who had
come to watch.
He wasn't sure why.
There hadn't been an animus dragon found
in the tribe in centuries, as far as he
knew.
Surely it would be a very boring
ceremony.
The dragonettes were gathered on a beach
on the eastern side of the island.
As Turtle waded up onto the sand, he
realized with surprise that there were
dragon made structures around him, the
remains of an old pier jutted into the
water.
Most of the wooden walkway had rotted
away, but a few of the pylons still stood
and it clearly led out to where a
pavilion had once balanced over the sea.
Farther up the beach, overgrown by jungle
vines, ruins rose out of the greenery
walls, a tower, here and there a dragon
statue.
What is this place?
Turtle asked Whirlpool.
Oh, don't you know?
Whirlpool said, in his insufferably
superior way, what do your tutors spend
their time on, I wonder?
Use your brain, little prince.
Don't you remember anything about an
ancient sea wing palace abandoned nearly
2000 years ago?
Turtle looked around again.
Resisting the urge to smack whirlpool in
the snout with his tail. 2000 years ago.
That was around the time of the
massacre.
The island palace, he breathed.
It's the island.
Oh, said Whirlpool, realizing what Turtle
had said.
Yes, that's correct.
With a faint air of disappointment.
He oozed off toward the top of the beach
where Turtle's Uncle Shark was pacing and
glowering at everyone.
This was where the massacre had taken
place.
Turtle felt an eerie chill flood through
his scales.
Nine dragons had died here.
The victims of albatross's magic, most of
them members of the royal family, his
ancestors.
If anywhere in the kingdom was haunted
this would be the place.
He imagined restless ghosts, stepping
through puddles of blood on the verandas
reaching with translucent talons toward
the living.
Hey, Octopus said, breaking turtles
trance, what's she doing here?
Queen Coral came swooping down from the
sky?
The turtle knew that she wasn't the she
his brother meant.
Octopus was talking about their sister
little princess anemone, the dragonette
clinging to Coral's neck, a harness bound
the 2 of them together.
Turtle had never seen them without it.
She goes everywhere, mother goes.
Cerulean whispered, you know that.
They're here to watch the ceremony, like
everyone else.
But he was wrong about that.
Coral landed on the sand, shook her wings
and looked around triumphantly at the
assembled council members.
I want anemone to be tested with the
other dragonettes today, she announced.
Anemone?
protested Turtle's cousin Moray, who was
old and on the council, she's not even
one year old yet, Queen Coral smiled
fondly at her daughter.
Yes, but she's very precocious, and I
have a feeling about her.
I just know how the story should go.
Princess Anemone slid off the queen's
back, in a move that was almost graceful
except she got tangled up in the harness
and ended up flopping onto her side in
the sand, growling softly, she struggled
to her feet, and wrestled the harness
back out of her way.
Next to Turtle, a three-year-old
dragonette twitched forward. as if he
wanted to go help her, but he wasn't sure
he was allowed to, his scales were
grayish blue, and there was a nick on one
of his ears, which Turtle recognized.
That was Pike, who had a reputation for
fighting too hard in training classes, and
hurting himself by accident.
All right.
Here we go.
Whirlpool said smacking his front talons
together wetly.
A coconut for each dragonette, please.
A few older dragons moved between the
dragonettes, passing out coconuts.
Turtle looked warily down at his.
This could be the instrument of my
destruction, he thought.
This harmless looking snack could betray
me and change my life forever.
We'll start on this end, Whirlpool said
stepping over to the line of
dragonettes.
You three, loud and clear.
Tell your coconuts to float into the air
then return to your claws.
The 3 dragonettes on the end dutifully
spoke in unison, issuing commands to
their coconuts.
Nothing happened.
You may go.
Whirlpool dismissed them.
As they slipped back into the water with
their parents, Turtle felt his heart
racing as fast as his mind.
Whirlpool would be looking right at him.
He'd have to say exactly what he'd been
commanded to say.
How could he fool the test?
Enchant it now, he thought. before he
gets here.
He sank his claws into the coconut
shell.
Coconut?
he thought.
Don't move.
No matter what I or anyone else says to
you, you are now a completely normal
coconut who can never be enchanted.
Without work?
He had experimented so little with his
power, because of the need to keep it
secret.
He knew he could enchant things by
thinking about it, without having to
speak aloud, but he wasn't sure if spoken
spells were stronger and might overpower
a thought spell.
He also wasn't sure it was possible to
enchant an object to be enchantment
resistant.
What else can I do to distract them?
His gaze fell on anemone, sitting up the
beach beside their mother.
She held a coconut too, studying it, and
turning it between her talons like a
large opal.
Queen Coral was watching her, as though
anemone had been carved out of sea glass
perfect and shimmering and sharp.
Her eyes were full of all the things
turtle feared.
Grand plans, dreams, ambitions
expectations.
In Queen Coral's story of the world.
Of course, her one surviving daughter
would be magical.
Of course, she would be the 1st animus
dragon to hatch in 100s of years, she
would be chosen.
She would be a savior for the whole
tribe.
That's it.
An idea hit turtle like a lightning
bolt.
If the tribe already has an animus.
Then they won't need me.
As quickly as it had struck, his
excitement faded.
The type of enchantment he was
imagining.
No one had ever tried it before, as far
as he knew.
It was probably impossible, almost
certainly impossible, insane, in fact
especially since he couldn't touch her or
speak out loud.
It would have to be a thought spell from
a distance, and those were difficult
enough, even when they weren't immensely
powerful requests.
But the words were forming in his head
unbidden, and he realized he was going to
try.
If it was impossible, it wouldn't work
and he'd be in the same current as
before.
If it did work.
Whirlpool would be happy.
Anemone would be even more special, Queen
Coral would be ecstatic, and Turtle would
be safe.
I enchant my sister anemone. to become an
animus dragon too.
Anemone, become an animus dragon.
I enchant you to have talons of power.
Turtle!
Whirlpool barked in his ear.
Turtle jerked back, catching his tail
painfully on a giant conch shell.
Sorry, Turtle said.
What?
It's your turn.
Whirlpool nodded at the coconut.
And then at the 2 dragons beside him.
Pike and octopus are waiting.
Oh, yes.
Turtle fumbled his coconut out in front
of him and took a deep breath.
He heard the other 2 mumbling along as he
spoke to it.
Coconut, float into the air, and then
return to my claws.
Was the coconut trembling?
Or was that his own fear traveling
through his arms?
Did it feel lighter in his talons as if
it was about to lift off?
Oh, please, anemone?
Use your magic.
Turtle wished desperately.
A piercing shriek suddenly cut the air
making half the dragonettes jump and drop
their coconuts.
It was Moray.
One talon outstretched to point at
anemone, and a coconut that was slowly
drifting up into the air over her head.
Whirlpool turned to stare, and Turtle
took the moment to grip his coconut
forcefully once more.
Stop moving, you hairy idiot.
I enchant you to be a normal coconut, a
coconut that would never float anywhere
by all the whales.
The coconut seemed to nestle closer, warm
and heavy and still in his claws.
I was right.
Queen Kroll cried.
Anemone, you're an Adamus, you really
are.
No one looked more surprised than anemone
who stared up at the coconut in awe.
With the sun shining behind it, it seemed
to be glowing, and so did all the pinkish
white and pale blue scales all over
anemone.
I'm magic, she whispered.
The test is over, Carl called.
Whirlpool, we found our animus.
Look.
But shouldn't we?
We'll pull gestured faintly at the
remaining dragonettes, then shrugged.
Quite right, your majesty.
All of you are dismissed.
Turtle exhaled softly.
He couldn't believe it.
It worked.
He'd turned his sister into an animus
dragon.
So now he was safe.
His magic was his own.
He could keep being quiet, ordinary
turtle on the outside.
But had he done the right thing?
What if he had ruined Anemone's life by
protecting himself?
He hesitated at the edge of the water
watching his sister.
She certainly looked pretty happy.
Queen Coral threw her wings around
anemone as her council crowded closer
murmuring excitedly.
Would the queen have reacted the same way
to finding out he was an animus?
Would he suddenly be the one she loved
the center of attention all the time?
Would he have ended up with a harness
like anemones?
He shook a crab off one of his talons.
Remember, that's exactly what I don't
want, he told himself.
This would have been anemone's life
anyway.
Really, it wouldn't be any different.
She'd still be special and beloved.
She'd probably adore having animus
powers.
What about her soul?
A part of him whispered.
He pushed away the guilt.
Probably a myth.
He told himself. someone will make sure
she's careful with her magic.
He told himself.
She'll be fine.
Turtle slipped into the water quietly
unnoticed by anyone, and swam away
leaving barely a ripple on the surface of
the ocean.
Chapter 20.
Turtle thought of Kinkajou, of Kibley and
Winter, of peril, as he flew and swam
flew and swam without stopping.
He wished he had his friends with him.
Peril would be able to stop anemone
either with her fire scales, or her blunt
honesty.
Kibley would have some brilliant plan, or
winter would be able to fight her.
Not him.
He had no plan, no fighting skills, no
fire scales.
I could try honesty.
I've never given anemone the truth
before.
I'm not sure she'd be very grateful for
it.
The current took him north to a river
which turned out to be Winding Tail River
snaking through the mountains.
Whenever it was too shallow to swim, he
flew.
When the night unleashed brutal gusting
winds, he swam.
The windstorm was still going when he had
to leave the river sometime the next
day.
It was hard to tell whether it was
morning or afternoon, with the sun
swallowed up by clouds, and only a dim
gray light filling the sky from horizon
to horizon.
The landscape below him was equally
monotonous.
This was the mud kingdom, dreary and
swampy and bog riddled.
He let himself stop for a moment in a
grove of mist shrouded trees, so he could
use his healing stone on his exhausted
wings.
Then he replaced it in his pouch and flew
on.
He was starving, but he couldn't stop to
eat.
He had to catch his sister.
Another night passed in flying, and the
next morning, Turtle found himself over
the ocean, sunlight sparkling on waves as
blue as tsunami's scales.
Gratefully he dove into the warm water
and found a current that was going in the
direction of the deep palace.
As it swept him along, he was able to
catch a fish hurtling by, and eat it in 2
snaps of his jaws.
A sense of enormous relief washed over
him as he came in sight of the deep
palace.
For one thing, it was home, familiar and
comforting in every twist and crevice, for
another, it did not look like the sight
of an ongoing massacre.
Sea wings swam peacefully, busily, in and
out of the various entrances.
Dragonettes played around the fins of the
soldiers in the gardens.
The usual glow of aquatic conversations
danced over the coral and reflected
through the palace windows.
No clouds of blood rising from the palace
no dragons fleeing in panic.
If anemone was here, she hadn't started
killing yet.
What if she isn't here?
he thought.
Touching down at the main palace
entrance.
He'd look like kind of an idiot if he'd
chased her all the way back home for no
reason.
But then everyone would be safe, and he
wouldn't mind looking like an idiot to
make that true.
One of his older brothers was swimming
out of the palace as turtle approached
Finn blinked in surprise when he saw a
turtle.
I thought you'd gone off to fancy hugging
school, he joked, with flashing scales.
I did.
I'm just stopping by to say hi, Turtle
said.
He couldn't stop himself from adding, and
what does that even mean?
Hugging school.
Where all the tribes of pyrhea will learn
to hug out their problems, of course, said
Finn, grinning like a comedic barracuda.
Who are you here to say hi to?
Nobody's even noticed you're gone?
He laughed, and thumped Turtle's shoulder
hard enough to make turtles spin in the
water.
Oh, thanks very much.
Total responded, riding himself.
Have you seen anemone today?
Here?
Finn looked alarmed.
She's supposed to be with you.
Do not tell me Pike has lost her.
Mother will pop off all his scales one by
one.
No, no.
Turtle said.
She snuck away from school, and I thought
she might have come here.
But you haven't seen her?
Finn shook his head.
Where's mother?
Turtle asked.
Maybe he should warn her.
Although he didn't want her to kill
anemone on sight, which would be the
logical reaction.
Could he explain everything that had
happened?
Dark stalker and everything else?
In Auckland's favorite place, Finn said
rolling his eyes and nodding at one of
the gardens beyond the palace.
As usual, he spread his wings to swim
away.
Finn, turtles started.
His brother turned to look at him.
If you do see anemone in the next day or
two.
Maybe keep your distance, just in case.
You're freaking me out, little brother
Finn said, frowning.
I'm worried about her soul, Turtle
admitted, but I hope I'm wrong.
Finn blanched, no doubt remembering all
the albatross stories as well.
I've been meaning to do a mapping
excursion to the outer aisles, he said.
Maybe now would be a good time for that.
Maybe, Turtle said, adding the sequence
of glowing scales that indicated high
anxiety.
Maybe take our brothers with you.
All of them?
Three moons.
Finn flashed, a shadow of a grin
reappearing on his face.
It'll be more like an invasion than a
scouting trip.
The grin vanished again.
Thanks, turtle.
He swam off at top speed and turtle
headed for Aucklett's garden.
As he got closer, he realized why this
spot was our favorite.
Here, a few vents in the ocean floor sent
jets of warm bubbles shooting toward the
surface.
When he was a little dragonette, he loved
playing in them too.
Queen Coral sat beside the bubble sprays
watching her littlest daughter with a
smile on her face.
She held a slate loosely in her talons
but she wasn't riding on it.
At the end of her harness, Aucklet was
somersaulting and giggling and pouncing
at the bubbles as they shot by.
Mother, turtle flashed as he sidled up
beside her.
Oh, hello, she flashed back, glancing at
him briefly.
She didn't seem to recognize him as the
prince who was supposed to be at Jade
Mountain.
Turtle sat down beside her, at a loss for
words.
Where should he start?
Would it be wise to warn her about
anemone?
What if his sister wasn't really planning
to challenge her?
After all, she should have easily gotten
here before he did.
So where was she?
Maybe Dark Stalker was right.
An anemone was back at the Jade Mountain
Academy right now, eating fish and
bossing the other sea wings around.
If so, he didn't want to get her in
trouble with a queen.
But if Coral and Aucklet were in danger.
Shouldn't he warn them?
He looked up at the dark ocean overhead
wondering if a soulless anemone was out
there somewhere, circling like a shark.
Isn't she perfect?
His mother flashed.
It took total a moment to realize she was
talking about Aucklet.
The queen nodded at the Happy
Dragonette.
I was convinced I was cursed.
I thought I'd never get even one living
daughter.
And now I have 3.
She caught a wayward bubble in her talons
and smiled.
And I'm not afraid anymore.
That's the most amazing part.
I know the assassin is gone, so I can
just be happy to be with Aucklet, instead
of being terrified every minute, that I'm
about to lose her.
I never told you how sorry I was.
Turtle blurted.
He clapped his wings shut.
This was not at all what he had meant to
say.
For what?
The queen asked.
For the eggs that died, he said
miserably.
When I was looking for Snapper, when the
other guard got sick, and I couldn't find
Snapper anywhere, and dad was so upset
with me.
That was you?
She looked at him more closely, and he
flinched back.
But it wasn't anger in her eyes, or even
disappointment.
Was it pity?
Your father felt terrible about that, she
said.
Especially once we found out that Snapper
had snuck off to the Summer Palace and
wasn't even here.
Oh, I made sure her death was a little
extra painful for that.
What?
Turtle wasn't sure he'd followed her
aquatic correctly.
Snapper wasn't, what?
She was supposed to stay in the deep
palace in case she was needed, but she
left, Queen Coral said.
That's why you couldn't find her here.
Didn't you know that?
No, Turtle said.
No one ever told me that.
I thought Gil was going to tell you.
Coral mused.
Maybe he didn't get a chance before.
She trailed off.
Turtle's mind was spinning, as if it was
caught in a whirlpool.
He couldn't have found Snapper that day
not in time to help his father, if she
was all the way at the summer palace.
It wasn't his fault.
It wasn't his failure, and his father
knew it before he died.
Maybe he forgave me.
Turtle thought.
The 1st hopeful thought he'd had about
his father in years.
Sorry nobody told you.
His mother said unexpectedly.
You were such a little dragonette, and
you tried so hard.
And then, even more unexpectedly, she put
one wing around his shoulders and pulled
him closer.
Turtle's heart was definitely going to
explode.
What's your name again?
She asked.
Which almost wrecked the moment, except
that nothing could do that.
Turtle, he said.
It's turtle.
She smiled down at him.
I'll remember it this time.
He smiled back.
Holy mother of scavengers, she knows who
I am.
She cares about my feelings, and I didn't
even have to be a hero.
I'm just me.
Turtle.
Her dragonette, who tried his best.
He leaned into her, and thought about
heroes, and stories, and
misunderstandings.
He knew he still had to go find anemone
to do something heroic, and possibly
impossible.
He knew Dark Stalker was still out there
and he hadn't yet tried his best to stop
him, but he would.
But for now, for this moment, he let
himself just be turtle, under his
mother's wing, where he'd always wanted
to be.
Chapter 21.
All too soon, a sea wing messenger came
from the palace looking for Queen Coral.
A dragon from the talons of peace is here
to see you, he reported.
News about changes in the sky kingdom, he
says.
The queen made a face at Turtle and
Aucklet.
Official business, she said.
We have to get back to the palace
outlet.
Okay.
The little dragonette spun through the
bubbles one last time and swam over to
her mother.
Turtle, she cried, recognizing him.
Aucklett threw her arms around his neck
and hugged him tight.
He hugged her back, thinking, I won't let
anyone hurt you, little sister.
See you soon.
His mother flashed.
Turtle watched them swim inside.
His heart ached, but his wings felt
stronger than ever.
He was going to find anemone and stop her
no matter what it took.
I know the truth now.
The coral was trying to take me to
Snapper.
It only seemed like it didn't work
because it was trying to get to the
summer palace.
The coral.
He could use that to figure out where
anemone was.
A thought that really should have
occurred to him a couple of days and a
very long flight ago.
He prayed that it would point south
toward Jane Mountain.
Maybe it would lead him all the way back
to the safety of school.
The tiny red tree felt fragile and
brittle in his talons, as though it might
snap at any moment.
Anemone, he whispered to it, where is my
sister?
It wriggled in his talons, pointing up
and away from the deep palace, but not
south.
He let it pull him into one of the swift
currents that spiraled out to the
islands.
For a while he swam steadily, and his
spirits rose with every wing stroke away
from the palace.
She wasn't lurking there, lying in wait
for his mother.
Whatever anemone was up to.
Maybe no one had to die.
Left.
The curls suddenly insisted, tugging him
up out of the current and up, up, up to
the surface.
Turtle had to pinwheel fast with his
wings and tail to stay with it.
Cascades of green blue bubbles exploded
around him.
It was leading him to an island.
He could see the shape of the land ahead
of him, but he didn't recognize it.
Not until he popped out of the water and
saw the ruins jutting out of the jungle.
The island palace, the place where the
animus test had taken place, where he'd
cursed his little sister with his own
power, so he could stay hidden.
And there was anemone, digging a hole in
the beach with her claws, muttering
furiously to herself, wet sand covered
her webbed talons, and plastered her tail
so she looked half mud wing.
Turtle floundered forward in the surf as
the waves tried alternately to toss him
onto the sand, or to drag him back into
their arms.
The sun was unexpectedly bright in his
eyes.
Somehow, he'd expected to confront
anemone deep underwater, or in the rain.
This idyllic beach scene didn't fit his
idea of an animist showdown.
Anemone.
He gasped, staggering onto the beach.
The coral practically dragged him forward
so it could tap Anemone's tail.
His sister whirled around, her face
contorted with fury.
You boring lump of kelp, she yelled at
him.
You ruin everything.
Why can't you leave me alone?
You're my sister, he said.
He let his wings rest on the sand and
tried to catch his breath as he tucked
the coral away.
I'm worried about you.
Are you?
she scoffed, or are you worried about
what I might do?
Um, he said, that too.
Well, you can't stop me, she said
mockingly.
So there's really no point in you being
here.
Go back to your loser friends and your
hypnotized girlfriend.
You're the one who put that spell on her
turtle flared.
I didn't ask you to.
Because you're a wimp, who's afraid to
even try for what he wants.
Anemone said, but I'm not like you.
I'm getting exactly what I want and
deserve, and I'm getting it today.
She turned back to her digging.
What are you looking for?
Turtle asked.
Something Whirlpool said he hid for me
here.
She said.
Go away, turtle.
Anemone, he said.
I'm afraid dark stalkers put a spell on
you.
She laughed bitterly.
Well, that would be ironic.
I mean, I think he's enchanted you to
kill mother, and maybe Aucklet and the
rest of our family.
Turtle explained.
Oh, she said, and laughed again.
I don't need to be enchanted to want to
do that, big brother.
I think anyone who met you all would feel
the same way.
But I think this is his vengeance, Turtles
said desperately, for what Fathom did to
him.
Maybe, Anemone said with a shrug.
But if I do it, I'll be queen of the sea
wings, and then he'll have to respect
me.
And if that's what he was hoping for
maybe he'll be proud of me too.
How can you not care?
Turtle demanded.
Is it your soul?
Maybe he didn't enchant that necklace to
protect it after all?
Maybe, you've been losing it all along
piece by piece.
That whole idea of the soul is
ridiculous.
Anemone snapped.
Good dragons do bad things, and bad
dragons do good things all the time.
Nobody has an entirely good soul to start
with.
It's just stupid to think that it's like
a block of stone, and my magic is
chipping away at it.
It doesn't make sense.
She smashed her tail into the sand
cracking seashells and frightening small
crabs in every direction.
Where is it?
If he was lying to me, I swear, I'm going
to hunt down Whirlpool's drifting corpse
and kill him again.
Again?
Turtles' ears twitched.
What?
Again.
Anemone, what do you mean?
I'm the one who killed him the 1st time.
She gave him a scornful look.
Did you really think he accidentally fell
into that pool of eels?
We figured out that he'd been trying to
kill tsunami.
And then he realized how powerful I was
and he was going to tell mother and
blister.
She shrugged.
So I took care of him.
Three moons.
Turtle had been worrying about anemone
all this time, worrying about what she
might do, about how the magic he'd given
her might affect her.
And yet, when she did do something big
and terrible, he'd missed it completely.
Oh, she said, spotting a gleam of metal
in the sand underfoot, she pounced on it
digging furiously, and finally reared
back with a triumphant, aha.
In her talons, was a dagger as long as
her forearm, curved like a claw, and
gleaming wickedly sharp along every edge
3 moons, turtle whispered, anemone.
Whirlpool wanted to be king pretty badly
she said, turning the dagger to catch the
sunlight.
I think he was hoping to shape me into a
darker dragon by making me cast all those
practice spells.
He wanted me to go evil and try for the
throne.
He told me he'd hidden a perfect weapon
here, ready for whenever I needed it.
For whenever I wanted to challenge
mother.
She smiled at it.
I think it'll work fine on little sisters
too, don't you?
And big ones, for that matter.
But you can't.
Turtle said, feeling sick, all through
his scales and bones and muscles.
Sure I can. she said, widening her blue
eyes at him.
I won't make orca's mistakes.
I'll enchant this thing right now to be a
perfect killing machine.
It'll never miss.
It'll go straight from mother's throat
first, then Aucklet, tsunami, you.
Her eyes narrowed.
Moon?
Maybe Kinkaju too.
Why not?
He did say anyone who gets in my way.
This was it.
This was the breaking point.
His speeches weren't working.
He had to do something.
Even if it meant Dark Stalker found out
about him.
He had to do something.
His talons closed around the nearest
seashell, fan shaped, pale pink and white
like anemones scales.
I enchant you to break every spell.
Dark Stalker has cast on anemone the
moment you touch her. he said, and flung
the seashell with all his might.
It bounced off Anemone's side, and she
jumped back, blinking and startled.
What the anemone yelped, are you out of
your mind?
Necklace?
he said, reaching out one arm.
Come to me.
The silver collar around Anemone's neck
snapped off and flew into his talons.
I enchant you to be powerless from now on
he said to it, and threw the necklace as
far out to sea as he could.
Anemone's claws went to her throat.
But she said, how?
Dagger, turtle commanded, turn to sand
forever.
The dagger collapsed in anemones, talons
and scattered into the wind.
Anemone stared at him.
I'm an animus too, said Turtle.
I'm sorry, I should have told you
sooner.
That's ridiculous.
Anemone cried.
You?
You're nobody.
I'm the sea wing animus.
You are.
But that's because of me, Turtles said.
I'm so sorry, Anemone.
I'm the one who made you an animus.
Right here, the day of the talons of
power ceremony.
I didn't want anyone to find out about me
so I distracted them with you, and
everything that's happened to you since
then is all my fault.
No, Anemone screamed.
It's my power.
You can't just take it?
You can't just say it's yours.
You did not create me.
She launched herself at Turtle and
slammed him onto his back in the waves.
Her claws slashed the side of his throat
and pain blistered through his gills.
You didn't make me, and you can't stop
me.
I can still kill her, she yelled.
I can kill her with my bare claws.
I can kill her with anything.
I can make daggers out of seashells.
I can poison the drops of water around
her snout.
I can enchant her pearls to choke her, or
her stupid narwhal horn to stab her in
the heart.
In shock.
Turtle fought back, throwing her off
him.
She skidded onto the beach, and he leaped
after her, pinning her down into the
sand.
This is what Moon saw, he realized, this
fight.
A jolt of relief made his heart pulse
wildly.
But I haven't lost my soul.
I still don't want to hurt anemone.
Her scales were slippery under his claws
and sand sprayed up into his eyes
stinging and blinding him.
She sank her teeth into one of the webs
on his front talons, and he roared with
pain.
He'd thought breaking dark stalker's
spells would change her.
He'd thought he was setting her free.
Why didn't it work?
Anemone thrashed and stabbed at his
underbelly, sending more fiery bolts of
agony along his scales.
Knock my brother off me, anemone shouted
flinging one talon out at something
behind turtle.
He turned, and saw a huge rock lever
itself out of the sand.
It shot toward him like an attacking sky
wing, turtle ducked, and rolled off
anemone, covering his head.
Disappear, he shouted at the rock, with
an odd thudding sound, the boulder
vanished out of the air.
Anemone leaped to her feet, with her
wings spread.
All the crabs on this beach, she
shouted.
Attack turtle, do it now.
The sand erupted, as 100s of crabs came
swarming out of their burrows, from tiny
hermit crabs, up to massive talon sized
red monsters, with snapping claws.
Blue gray pincers popped out of the sand
right below him, and clamped down sharply
on one of his front talons.
Turtle yowled and jumped back and felt
more explosions of pain as claws dug in
along his tail.
Waves, he called desperately.
Wash these crabs out to sea.
The sea pulled back, as if mildly
offended by the order, then came rushing
in all at once in a huge tidal wave.
Turtle felt himself slammed to the sand
and through the water, he saw anemone
clawing to stay on the beach.
All the crabs were caught up and tumbled
about and carried away, sucked out into a
hissing, foaming ocean.
He didn't have a moment to catch his
breath before seashells began pelting him
each one aiming to stab between his
scales.
Death by 1000 cuts, he thought, trying to
wipe away the blood running into his
eyes.
Turtle tried to duck away, scrabbling
through the sand for something he could
work with, here, and here.
Two sand dollars washed up by the wave.
Protect me from the shells, he said to
them, and they shot into the air, warding
off the attacking seashells like tiny
flying shields.
Anemone.
I don't want to fight you.
He yelled.
Then you shouldn't say stupid things that
make me want to kill you, she yelled
back.
Swallow him up.
The sand suddenly collapsed under him
dropping him into a sinkhole, and then
immediately began pouring back over his
head.
Turtle flailed around in a panic.
He did not want to die by drowning in
sand.
He did not want to be buried and
forgotten here on this beach, leaving
Aucklet, and mother unprotected from
anemone, and the rest of my friends
enchanted by dark stalker, and Kingaju
under that awful spell forever.
He reached out with his magic, and
wrenched an entire palm tree out of the
ground.
It came skidding across the sand toward
him, nearly plowing through anemone
before she jumped out of the way, and
stopped, with its fronds hanging over the
hole.
Turtle sank his claws into the sharp
edged leaves and dragged himself out
talon over talon.
The sand behind him made an ominous glorp
sound, and tried to suck him back down.
Let me go.
Turtles shouted at it.
A flurry of sand exploded upward, then
settled into a normal non-carnivorous
beach dune.
Turtle clutched the trunk of the palm
tree, panting heavily.
This fight was uneven.
She was willing to use lethal force, and
he was not.
He refused to kill his little sister.
A faint whistling in the air warned him
to look up.
Something enormous was crashing down
toward him, a piece of stone wall from
the ruins of the island palace.
Crush him!
Anemone screamed.
Don't stop until you hit him.
Stop.
Turtles shouted.
The projectile wobbled for a moment, but
it didn't stop.
It kept coming faster and faster.
Shield me.
Turtle cried to the palm tree.
He leaped off and covered his head.
There was a muffled, smashing cracking
sound.
And when Turtle looked up, he saw pieces
of tree raining down around him.
The wall rebounded off the broken palm
and leaped for him again.
It won't stop until it hits me.
That's the spell.
Turtle grabbed the nearest thing he could
read, a shell that once housed a hermit
crab, and whispered, make my scales as
hard as diamonds.
Make my bones unbreakable.
Make me impossible to hurt, no matter how
hard that thing lands on me.
He wrapped his claws around the shell, and
crouched, with his eyes screwed shut.
I'm going to die.
The block of stone slammed into him with
such force that it left an imprint in the
sand.
It felt like the entire deep palace
landing on him.
For a moment, he couldn't breathe.
But he felt no pain, and he was still
alive.
Get off me.
He croaked at the stone block when he
could form words again.
Its original mission complete.
The block obligingly lifted away and
clunked down in the sand beside him.
Seaweed, turtle thought dizzily, wondering
if he was about to lose consciousness, go
wrap anemone's mouth shut, so she cannot
cast any more animus spells, neither by
voice or thought, as long as you are
touching her, but make sure she can still
breathe.
From the muffled shrieks he could hear.
He guessed that his spell succeeded, but
he couldn't move yet.
He had to lie there, waiting for
everything in his body to realize that it
still worked.
A moment later, Claws raked viciously
across his nose, and he jerked up to find
anemones standing over him.
She had so much seaweed wrapped around
her snout that she couldn't see over it.
She kept turning her head from side to
side, to glare at him with one eye and
then the other.
Only her nostrils were still visible, and
they were flaring with fury.
She clawed at him again, and he stumbled
back, before realizing that he'd barely
felt them.
He blinked down at his scales, which were
a mess of blood from the seashell cuts.
His sister leaped forward again and tried
to slice her claws across his throat, but
they ricocheted off as though, as though
my scales are hard as diamonds.
Turtles' talons were empty.
Where was the shell he'd enchanted?
Why was the spell still working on him if
he wasn't holding it?
Because I wasn't that specific?
He realized.
With most of his spells, he worded the
enchantment to work as long as he was
holding, Or touching, or wearing, the
animus touched object.
But with this one, I just told it to make
me impossible to hurt.
It was like the healing spell on Kinkachu
or the feather that fixed Flame's scar.
The effects were permanent, no matter
what happened to the object afterward.
He'd never really thought about the
difference before.
His mind spun to the spells Dark Stalker
had cast on his night wings, they were
all object dependent.
If Dark Stalker took away their objects
his subjects would lose those powers.
He must know he could make them permanent
but he's choosing not to.
With a sickening lurch in his stomach, he
tried to remember how anemone had worded
the spell on Kinkaju.
Did she say, as long as she has this
rock?
Or did she just say, make her love
turtle?
Was the enchantment permanent?
Even if Kingaju took off the Skyfire?
He couldn't remember.
I'm so sorry, Kinkachu, he thought, with
a wrench of agony.
Turtle realized that anemone was
glowering at him.
Her sides were heaving, slick with sweat
and sand and seawater.
Anemone.
He said carefully, please listen to me.
She gestured to her snout like, have you
given me any choice?
I'm not going to kill you, he said, and I
would really like you to not kill me.
Can we talk without attacking each
other?
He sidled a step toward her.
I'd like to think we can work this out
with words instead of violence or magic.
She rolled her eyes at him, which wasn't
a very reassuring yes.
All right, he said.
Let's try this.
Seaweed.
I want you to wrap around anemones arm
instead.
But still, as long as you're touching
her.
She cannot use her magic in any way, and
stay put until I remove you.
He added hurriedly.
The long strands of dark wet seaweed
began smoothly unrolling from his
sister's snout and transferring to one of
her forearms instead.
Anemone scowled down at the makeshift
handcuff, as though she was thinking
about cutting off her arm to get her
magic back.
You are so annoying.
She snapped at Turtle, as soon as she
could speak again.
And you're very powerful, he said, but I
can't let you go kill mother, or Aucklet
or Tsunami, or anyone else.
I don't believe you're that kind of
dragon.
Anemone threw her wings up in the air.
Of course I am.
I have to be.
It's my stupid destiny to kill the
queen.
That's what princesses do.
And I'm even worse, because I'm an animus
so I'm going to turn evil anyway, no
matter what I do.
I should just do it and be evil and be
done with it already.
You don't have to be evil, Turtle cried
appalled.
Not every animus is evil.
I'm not evil.
But you will be, anemone said
accusingly.
We both will be.
That's what happens to animus dragons
unless you're dark stalker, and you're so
smart.
Fathom wasn't evil, Turtle pointed out.
We don't know that, Anemone said.
First of all, what he did to Dark Stalker
wasn't exactly the kindest thing in the
world, and then he disappears from
history.
Who knows what else he did with his
power?
There were lots of animus ice wings who
didn't go evil either.
Turtles said stubbornly.
And the sandwing from 1000s of years ago
who disappeared?
Jerboa, as far as we know anyhow, and
stone mover.
So my choices are evil, missing, or
fossilized?
Anemone said.
That's appealing.
I think a spell to protect your soul
could work, Turtle said.
I just don't trust Dark Stalker to cast
it for you.
It won't work.
It's already too late for me.
Anemone shook her head.
Ever since Whirlpool died, I see him all
the time, in my dreams, in the faces of
strange dragons, everywhere.
I keep seeing those eels going after
him.
I see all the dragons I've hurt.
Now moon's there too.
And I hate what I did to her, but I also
feel proud of it.
Isn't that twisted?
Whatever soul I had, it's long gone.
So protecting it wouldn't be much use.
Maybe losing your soul isn't the right
way to describe it.
Turtle said.
Maybe it's more like, the more you use
your power for bad things.
The more you feel like you're entitled to
use your power for anything.
It makes it harder to go back.
Only forward, into more bad things.
He hesitated.
But, I think you can go back.
I think anyone can choose to do good or
be good, no matter what happened before.
I think you just have to try really
hard.
And that means stopping yourself before
you do even worse things.
She growled softly.
I suppose you mean like killing a bunch
of family members?
Well, yeah, he said.
That's one example.
She looked down at her talons.
So what do I do instead?
What if I can't stop myself?
and you're not here next time to wrap me
in enchanted seaweed?
He hesitated.
Do you want me to take it away again?
Your power?
I don't know if it'll work, but I could
try.
If you don't want to be an animus
anymore.
But then what would I be?
She spread her wings and talons, leaving
a trail of droplets from the dripping
seaweed.
Animus dragons are rare and special.
I like knowing that I'm powerful.
I want to be that powerful.
Who would give away their own magic like
that?
I'm just...
Scared of it too.
I know, he said.
I feel the same way.
Really?
She said.
Because you don't act like you want to be
powerful.
Turtle opened his mouth to answer, then
closed it again.
She was right.
He didn't act that way.
But he did want to be an animus.
It was the one thing that made him
special, even if only in secret.
He'd never give it up either.
I've cast a spell to hide myself from
Dark Stalker, he said.
I think we should do the same for you, in
case he does try to enchant you to do
something evil.
Oh, she said.
That explains a lot.
I mean, I was like, sure, turtle is
boring, but Dark Stalker really acts like
he doesn't exist at all.
So weird.
Now I get it.
Aren't I less boring now that you know
I'm inanimous?
Turtle protested.
He poked at his armband to pop out one of
the last Skyfire rocks.
You'll need this too. so he can't read
your mind.
She took the rock and held it up so the
deep sparkles in it could catch the
light.
There was a strange twitch in the air
like someone pinching the world around
them.
Turtle glanced up at the sky nervously.
Maybe we should also enchant something to
make Dark Stalker forget about our
explosion of animus spells.
He must be wondering what's going on.
He, is that how he always catches me
doing magic?
Anemone trailed off with a shiver.
He can sense animus spells being cast
Turtle said, nodding.
Then let's do that first, Anemone said
alarmed.
She grabbed a palm frond.
Hey, leaves, erase all the yikes.
She shrieked, as the entire beach
shuddered violently underneath them.
Erase all our spells from Dark Stalker's
memory.
She shouted as fast as she could.
The air was suddenly pressing in on them
as though they were being squeezed into
an invisible chest.
Turtle's ears popped painfully, and he
staggered toward anemone.
Did it work?
She yelled.
And Turtle realized there was a dark, high
pitched whistling sound drowning out all
other noises.
I don't know.
I don't see why.
It should.
Turtle's gaze fell from the gathering
clouds to his sister, and he was hit by a
sinking realization.
The seaweed, he cried.
He leaped forward and sliced through the
wrapping of seaweed around Anemone's
arm.
It didn't work because your magic was
blocked.
There seemed to be infinite, thick, sticky
layers of seaweed and they wouldn't come
off fast enough, no matter how he stabbed
and peeled at them.
You do this, Belle.
Anemone shouted, but the wind was now
screaming along with a sound, and sand
was blowing fiercely in their faces, like
the entire beach was rising up to attack
them.
Turtle clasped his sister's talons, folded
his wings around her, and held on tight.
Suddenly, there was a bending, warping
feeling to the universe, and Turtle heard
Dark Stalker's voice as clearly as if he
were standing right next to them.
Bring them here, Dark Stalker growled.
Every animous dragon in all the 7
tribes.
Bring them here to my throne room, right
now.
The world collapsed inward, into darkness
and unfolded again into pale sunlight
streaming through tall, narrow windows
across a vast black marble hall.
Outside the windows, the mountains of the
night kingdom, inside the hall, staring
down at them, dark stalker, wearing a
crown made of twisted metal with sharp
points.
Chapter 22.
Turtle gave a startled gasp and glanced
around.
All the way across the continent.
He just summoned us, like a tray of
shrimp.
There were still cracks of darkness in
the air.
Like it was a scroll that had been folded
and wrinkled too many times.
The cracks hissed and sparked, spitting
out turtle, anemone, stone mover, and
right behind dark stalker, and unfamiliar
sandwing.
The sandwing met turtle's eyes, her face
a mask of startled terror, and then she
vanished again in less than a heartbeat.
She was gone so quickly, the turtle
thought he might have hallucinated her
that perhaps she was a double image
accidentally reflected by the teleporting
cracks, especially since no one else
acted as if they'd seen her too.
Was that real?
He sat down, rubbing his eyes.
A splitting headache, was trying to
splinter his skull into small pieces.
I enchant this room so that no one can
cast any spills while they're in here
except me.
Dark stalker growled.
He loomed over anemone.
Where is your neck band?
he asked.
I lost it, she said.
I'll make another one.
Don't worry.
Someone gave you Skyfire, I see, he said
tapping the top of her skull.
Did you kill your mother?
Turtle guessed from his tone that he
already knew the answer.
No, Anemone said, lifting her chin
defiantly.
What do you care anyway?
Why'd you drag me back here after you
just ordered me to go away?
Dark Stalker hissed.
Who are you fighting anemone?
He asked.
Turtle flinched guiltily.
A scratch behind her ear was bleeding, and
there were scratches along her sides from
turtle's claws.
No one important, she said.
I was winning until you interrupted
though, by the way.
Those were battling animus spells, Dark
Stalker said.
And every animus in Pyria should be
here.
Which means...
He whipped his head toward stone mover.
The night wing lay awkwardly on his side
still encased in stone, but looking very
odd without his cave around him.
His talent twitched feebly, as though he
might be trying to right himself.
Stone mover, Dark Stalker said.
He tipped Stone Mover onto his talons and
leaned over to hiss in his ear.
Tell me the truth.
How many dragons are in this room right
now?
Turtle tried to wave frantically to get
his attention, to hold up 3 claws, or
mine to keep his secret or something, but
he wasn't fast enough, or a stone mover
was too slow.
For, Stone Mover said, sounding puzzled.
I knew it.
Dark stalker cried.
There's another one.
There's someone hiding from me.
He seized a sword that was hanging on the
wall.
Bring me a dragon.
Our hidden animus cares about very much.
Alive for now.
No, Turtle cried, but the sword was
already whipping out the door.
What can I do?
I can't cast any spells in here.
Do I have anything I can use?
He scrabbled open his pouch, all banged
up and covered with sand and searched
inside, trying to think.
The coral finder, the slate, the healing
stone, his hiding stick, the slate
Kibley.
He pulled it out and wrote as quickly as
he could.
Dark Stalker knows about me, trapped in
the Nightwing Palace.
Help.
As soon as he'd written it, he erased
it.
He couldn't risk dark stalker finding out
he'd sent a message.
Please see it soon, Kibley.
He prayed.
Hidden?
Stone Mover coughed, bewildered.
Yes, said Dark Stalker.
One of the dragons you can see is a
coward.
Planning against me in secret.
I think he's smart.
Anemone said sharply.
He knew right away not to trust you.
He knew there was something seriously
wrong with you.
You think everything you do is right.
You think you're so perfect, that you
don't even care about the dragons around
you.
You're the only one who gets to decide
what happens to everyone else.
By all the moons.
Dark Stalker growled.
He pointed an anemone.
Enchant this dragon to obey my every
command.
Now shut up, he barked at her.
Anemone's mouth snapped closed.
She touched her snout, looking startled
and outraged and terrified all at once.
No, Turtle felt the cold marble hall
pressing in on him.
That's the same spell he put on his
father.
He can make anemone do anything he wants
now.
That's better, Dark Stalker said.
He paced around her slowly.
You know, I've always had so many
questions about anima's power.
Maybe now, with you and Stone Mover both
under my control.
I can test out some of my theories.
For instance, is there a limit to how
many spells one can cast in a day?
What happens when 2 animus dragons try to
enchant something at the same time?
And of course.
How many spells does it take for a dragon
to turn evil?
He stopped in front of anemone, smiling
down at her.
For you, my dear.
I'm guessing it won't be very many more.
Turtle was transfixed with horror.
This was exactly what he'd been trying to
save anemone from.
It hadn't even occurred to him that Stone
Mover was one of Dark Stalker's puppets
already.
Maybe.
That's what he meant when he said his
talents weren't his own.
Maybe he sensed Dark Stalker taking them
over.
Oh, anemone.
How can I save you?
A clattering sound came from the hall
outside, and they all could hear a voice
coming closer.
This better be important, summoning a
dragon with a sword in the middle of
suntime?
I mean, someone has the manners of an
orangutan.
I am moving.
Quit pointing that, yourself at me.
Oh, no, turtle thought.
This bear poured over him like wet sand.
Kinkaju bounded into the throne room, with
a sword hovering menacingly in the air
behind her.
She was indignantly tangerine from horns
to tail, and turtle's heart leaped at the
side of her.
Hello, King Bossy, she said to Dog
Stalker, flicking her wings back.
You could have sent a dragon to ask me
nicely.
It's pretty rude to wake someone up with
sharp weapons.
I have to say.
Dog stalker slid over, and stared at her
thoughtfully for a moment.
Really?
he said.
Somebody cares about this dragon.
Hey, Kinkachu squeaked.
That's so unnecessary.
All right.
Dark Stalker said with a shrug.
Cowardly animus, he said, raising his
voice.
You see that I have your unimpressive
little rain wing.
Kinkachu scowled at him.
So now would be a good time to reveal
yourself.
Unless you want to see her sliced to
pieces.
He hooked the sword out of the air and
swept it around to point at Kinkachu's
throat in one graceful move.
No, Turtle shouted, taking a step toward
her.
Don't do it, Kinkachu said.
She closed her eyes.
Stay hidden.
You can stop him.
You have to stop him.
Not by myself.
Turtle said, not without you.
Yes, without me, she said.
I know you can.
Oh, monkey brains.
Does this mean I'm the hapless sidekick?
Blorg, that is so lame.
Better than the wailing victim who needs
rescuing, though.
Make sure nobody writes me that way when
this story becomes an epic poem, all
right?
And I would definitely like to be the
hero next time, please.
She glanced down at the sword and
shivered slightly.
I mean, in my next life, I guess.
Kinkajoo.
Turtle couldn't breathe.
Was this what drowning felt like for
other dragons?
The story doesn't make sense without
you.
You're the whole point of it for me.
Do please stop talking.
Dark Stalker said to her.
Last chance, animus.
In 10 seconds, this babbling dragonette
dies.
Turtle took his hiding stick out of his
pouch.
And it was so ordinary, unremarkable
boring.
Nothing anyone would ever notice, kind of
like him.
But it held some of the most powerful
magic in this room.
And it was the only thing that might
still be able to save the world.
This wasn't the heroic story he dreamed
of as a dragonette.
He wasn't standing at the gates to the
palace, fighting off attacking hordes
with a spear.
He wasn't defending his kingdom with
valiant strength.
And he might still be the idiot who died
while the real heroes saved the day.
But this was his chance.
A chance to be a different kind of hero
one who stood in the way, one who got
noticed, so that someone else could
live.
Heroes don't have to stab the bad guy in
the heart, or save the whole world.
Maybe it was enough.
More than enough, to save his sister and
Kinkaju.
All he had to do was stop hiding.
Anemone, he said urgently.
I don't know if this will work, but if it
does, get out of here as fast as you
can.
Go find Kibley and make him help you.
He closed his claws around the stick and
took a deep breath.
I'm not going to leave you in danger
anymore while I hide, but it means you
have to be the hero now.
Turtle glanced down at the stick again.
His heart was pounding, and his insides
were threatening to dissolve into sand
but he couldn't hide anymore, for
Kinkachu, for anemone.
For everyone.
He tossed the stick through the air to
his sister.
For a moment, as it was airborne, dark
stalker's head snapped up.
Perhaps a 1000 new futures were crowding
into his mind.
Perhaps he knew for a moment what was
about to happen, and he saw what he was
about to lose. and where it might lead.
But then Anemone caught the stick in her
front talons, and then, Dark Stalker saw
turtle.
And whatever future he had been looking
at was forgotten as his eyes flashed with
fury.
Fathom, he snarled.
A blast of flame shot out of his mouth
and enveloped turtle in fire, blistering
heat scorched over turtle.
He threw himself to the ground with his
wings over his head.
I'm not fathom, he shouted.
I'm turtle.
Kinkachu screamed, and leaped at Dark
Stalker's head, her talons wrapped around
his snout, her wings beat at his ears, and
she reared back, opening her mouth wide.
Jets of black venom shot from her fangs
and landed splat, sizzle. across Dark
Stalker's face, and in one of his eyes.
Dark Stalker roared and threw her off.
Kinkaju landed on the floor and skidded
halfway across the room.
Oh, moonfire and star vomit.
Dark Stalker shouted, clutching his
face.
Heel by all the snakes.
He lifted his talons away, and Turtle saw
that his scales were undamaged, but there
was a black hole where his eyeball had
been.
A moment later, it filmed over and a new
eye started to grow into the spot.
My accidental invulnerability spell
worked too.
Turtle realized, stretching out his
wings.
The fire had not burned him.
He was unharmed.
He stood up and looked around
frantically.
Anemone was gone.
She'd escaped in a chaos, small enough to
fit out one of the narrow windows.
He hoped she was on her way to Jade
Mountain right now, clutching his stick
erased from dark stalker's memory.
He hoped it would keep her safe.
If Dark Stalker didn't know she existed
he couldn't control her.
As long as she stayed hidden, she could
still be free.
He also hoped he could trust her.
Would she do the right thing, now that
she was free?
Would she know what the right thing was?
He darted over to Kinkaju, who was
struggling back to her feet?
Are you all right?
he asked, trying to help her up.
Oh, you're not a pile of ash.
She said.
She collapsed to the floor again.
That is such a relief.
I'm going to lie here and be relieved for
a minute.
Don't mind me.
I wish you would stop getting yourself
hurt, Turtle whispered.
Me too, she said.
Talk to the bad guys.
Tell them to stop hurting me.
She tried to move one of her wings and
winced.
Ow, ow, ow.
Here, Turtle said, giving her the healing
rock.
This might help.
He glanced over his shoulder, saw that
Dark Stalker was still holding his eyes
shut, and pressed the entire pouch into
her talons.
Pretend this is yours, he whispered.
Maybe something in here can help.
I'm scared for you, she whispered back.
Just making sure you get to be more than
the dead sidekick, he said.
You're a lot more than that to me.
I love you, turtle, she whispered.
Softer than ripples in a still pool.
You don't really, he said. feeling his
heart break a little more.
Anemone put a spell on you to love me.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, she said.
That's not cool.
But I feel like I love you.
And I'm afraid this is our tragic goodbye
so don't argue with me.
My apologies, Kinkachu.
Dark Stalker rumbled behind Turtle.
I didn't mean to hurt you.
Although in my defense, you did melt my
eyeball.
Turtle turned and found himself face to
face with Dark Stalker.
Those black eyes were seeing him for the
1st time, since dark stalker swarmed out
of the mountain.
It's all coming back to me.
Dark Stalker rumbled.
Turtle.
Yes.
Moon's friend.
Fathom's descendant.
You look exactly like him.
I believe I had a whole plan for you
before you muddled it up by hiding like
that.
He tapped turtle lightly on the nose.
Surprisingly clever, especially for you.
I would never have guessed you had it in
you.
Whatever you're going to do to me, Turtle
said, please, let Kinkaju go.
Dog Stalker chuckled.
I would never hurt a ball of fluff like
her.
Ball of fluff?
Kingaju protested.
I just melted your eye.
I am totally terrifying.
Kingajoush.
Turtle said, nudging her sharply.
No, I promised Moon I wouldn't hurt her
friends.
Dog stalker said thoughtfully, and she's
very fond of both of you.
Of course, she doesn't know where you are
he said to Turtle.
So, for the time being, let's stick you
in the dungeon until I decide how you can
be useful.
Dark Stalker bent down and took
Kinkachu's chin in his talons, looking
into her eyes.
As for you.
I enchant you to forget about everything
that happened in this throne room today.
You'll wake up from your suntime in an
hour, and carry on with your day, as
though everything is normal, and turtle
is not here.
Kinkachu went very still.
Her eyes flicked from dark stalker to
turtle.
His spells don't work on her.
Turtle remembered.
This might be the one thing he'd done
right.
She nodded slowly and took a step back.
Her expression was full of questions.
The turtle knew she couldn't ask any of
them without giving away that Dark
Stalker's spell hadn't worked.
Go on now, Dark Stalker said.
Turtle and I need to have a little talk.
Kinkaju gave Turtle an agonized look
bowed her head, and flew away.
She still had turtle's pouch.
Maybe something in there would help her
if she could figure out what any of it
did.
It's unfortunate for you.
Dark Stalker said to Turtle, that you
look so much like Fathom.
He spread one wing around Turtle, and
steered him toward one of the side
doors.
I have very good reasons to hate him, you
know.
It's going to make it hard to look at
you.
Although I suppose if you're locked away
deep in my darkest dungeon, we can avoid
that problem.
When we leave the room, I can cast a
spell, Turtle thought.
But what?
Something to help me escape.
His mind raced.
But just before they reached the exit
Dark Stalker paused and regarded Turtle
pensively for a moment.
I wouldn't normally do this, he said.
I always think an animus could be useful
in some way, if handled correctly.
But you managed to trick me once, and
that makes me a bit nervous about you.
So, I'm sorry.
Dark Stalker kept his talons around
Turtle's face.
And chant this dragon to lose all his
animus power right now, he said, so that
he shall never be able to cast a spell
again.
Turtle caught his breath and caught it
Gasping with disbelief.
A strange sensation scraped over his
scales, like a powerful scrubbing brush
scouring him clean.
It was gone.
The faint tingling in his claws that had
been there from the 2nd he hatched.
He'd never even known what it was.
Never guessed, that it was a sign of
animus magic, and now it had vanished
forever.
He'd always thought he was ordinary.
But he'd never been completely ordinary
until this moment.
Don't be too sad, Dark Stalker said.
To be the most powerful animus in the
world.
You have to be the smartest, and that was
never going to be you anyway, was it?
Now all the pressure is off.
You don't have to come up with something
brilliant to stop me.
Isn't that a bit of a relief?
Really?
Turtle's tail dragged on the floor as 2
nightwing guards led him away to the
dungeon.
Caught by dark stalker, imprisoned, just
as he had feared his story would end for
so long.
And worst of all, stripped of his magic
as well.
But anemone was safe.
Turtle had finally atoned for the talons
of power curse he gave her on the beach.
And Kinkaju was safe, and Kibli was out
there, ready to help.
Between the 3 of them, maybe they could
stop Dark Stalker.
He had to cling to the thin hope that
they could.
Because if they didn't, there was no one
else.
Epilogue.
In the kingdom of sand, 3 explosions
rocked the markets at 3 different oases
timed to go off simultaneously.
Dragons wearing black hoods and gold
medallions, stamped with a bird symbol
were spotted fleeing the scenes.
In the streets and tents and towns of the
kingdom.
Sandwings muttered and growled to one
another.
Who is doing this?
Why isn't Queen Thorn keeping us safe?
In the kingdom of the sea.
A class of young dragonettes on an
overnight trip was terrified half to
death by a pale phantom that dove from
the sky.
It swept around the island where they
were camped, hissing and snapping, and at
least 5 of the dragonettes swore, it
glared at them with beady black eyes.
Rumors spread quickly that the tribe was
being haunted, by the vengeful ghost of
albatross.
And far to the north, in the ice kingdom
in the midst of a blizzard.
Winter's brother hailstorm stood before
the wall of rankings, shivering with
fever.
His claws brushed over the last spot
where Winter's name had been not long
ago.
Why is this happening to our tribe?
Are we being punished for what happened
between me and winter?
A dragon trudged through the snow toward
him, but had to stop halfway, his body
racked with deep, lung churning coughs.
Is there news?
Hillstorm asked.
Are my parents any better?
No, the other ice wing wheezed.
They're getting worse.
But there's something else.
Someone else.
Hailstorm waited through another storm of
coughs.
What is it?
He said finally.
What's happened?
It's Queen Glacier. said the other
dragon.
She got the plague 1st. 3 days ago.
I know, said Hailstorm.
The world was swimming before his eyes.
Heat blurred his vision, pounded through
his blood.
I'm sorry, sir.
It's over, said the messenger.
Snow covered his wings, his tail.
Snow piled up around his talons, consuming
him from all sides.
He bowed his head, as though he was ready
to sink into it, and become a part of the
frozen landscape forever.
The queen of the ice wings is dead.
A guide to the Dragons of Pyria, updated
and edited by Starflight of the Night
Wings.
Welcome to the Jade Mountain Academy.
At this school, you will be learning side
by side with dragons from all the other
tribes.
So we wanted to give you some basic
information that may be useful as you get
to know one another.
You have been assigned to a winglet with
6 other dragons.
The winglet groups are listed on the
following page.
Thank you for being a part of this
school.
You are the hope of Pyre's future.
You are the dragons who can bring lasting
peace to this world.
We wish you all the power of wings of
fire.
Jade Winglet.
Ice Wing, Winter, Mud Wing, Umber, Night
Wing, Moon Watcher, Rain Wing, Kinkajoo
Sand Wing, Kibley, Sea Wing, Turtle, Sky
Wing, Carnelian, Gold Winglet, Ice Wing
Icicle, Mud Wing, Big Tail, Rain Wing
Tamarind, Sand Wing, onyx, sea wing, pike
sky wing, flame.
Silver Winglet, Ice Wing, Cheng Bai, Mud
Wing, Sepia, Night Wing, Fearless, Rain
Wing, Boto, Sand Wing, Ostrich, C Wing
Anemone, Sky Wing, Thrush, Copper Winglet
Ice Wing, Alba, Mud Wing, Marsh, Night
Wing, Mind Reader, Rain Wing, Coconut
Sand Wing, Snail, Sky Wing, Peregrine
Quartz Winglet, Ice Wing, Ermine, Mud
Wing, Newt, Night Wing, Mighty Claws, Rain
Wing, Siamang, Sand Wing, Arid, Sea Wing
Barracuda, Sky Wing, Garnet.
Sandwings, description.
Pale gold or white scales, the color of
desert sand, poisonous barbed tail, forked
black tongues, abilities, can survive a
long time without water, poison enemies
with the tips of their tails like
scorpions.
Bury themselves for camouflage in the
desert sand.
Breathe fire.
Queen.
Since the end of the war of Sandwing
Succession, Queen Thorn, Students at Jade
Mountain, Arid, Onyx, Ostrich, Pronghorn
Kibley, Mudwings.
Description, thick armored brown scales.
Sometimes with amber and gold underscales
large flat heads with nostrils on top of
the snout, abilities can breathe fire, if
warm enough, hold their breath for up to
an hour, blend into large mud puddles
usually very strong.
Queen, Queen Morhen.
Students at Jade Mountain, Marsh, Newt
Sepia, Sora, Umber, Sky Wings.
Description.
Red gold or orange scales, enormous wings
abilities, powerful fighters and flyers
can breathe fire.
Queen, Queen Ruby.
Although some dragons still support Queen
Scarlet, who may be alive and in hiding.
Students at Jade Mountain, Carnelian
Flame, Garnet, Peregrine, Thrush, Sea
Wings, Description.
Blue or green or aquamarine scales, webs
between their claws, gills on their necks
glow in the dark stripes on their tails
snouts, underbellies.
Abilities, can breathe underwater.
See in the dark, create huge waves with
one splash of their powerful tails
excellent swimmers.
Queen, Queen Coral.
Students at Jade Mountain, anemone
barracuda, pike, snail, turtle.
Ice wings.
Description.
Silvery scales like the moon, or pale
blue like ice, ridged claws to grip the
ice, forked blue tongues, tails narrow to
a whip thin end.
Abilities can withstand subzero
temperatures and bright light.
Exhale a deadly frost breath.
Queen, Queen Glacier.
Students at Jade Mountain, Alba, Chiang
Bai, Ermine, icicle, winter.
Rain wings.
Description.
Scales constantly shift colors, usually
bright like birds of paradise, prehensile
tails, abilities, can camouflage their
scales to blend into their surroundings
shoot a deadly venom from their fangs.
Queen, Queen glory.
Students at Jade Mountain, Photo, Coconut
Kinkaju, CMAG, Tamarin, Night Wings.
Description.
Purplish black scales and scattered
silver scales on the underside of their
wings, like a night sky full of stars
forked black tongues, abilities, can
breathe fire, disappear into dark shadows
once known for reading minds, and
foretelling the future, but no longer.
Queen, Queen Glory.
See recent scrolls on the Nightwing
Exodus and the Rainwing Royal Challenge.
Students at Jade Mountain, Big Tail
Fearless, Mighty Claus, Mind Reader, Moon
Watcher.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 9
Talons of Power, by 2ET Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Vanessa Melendez.
Executive producer Paul R.
Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text copyright 2017 by 2ET Sutherland.
Production Copyright 2017 by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.